e
good morning everybody uh we're going to
get started with the hearing on uh
Senate Bill 555 I see the prime sponsors
is
here Senator avart thank you for
oh
awesome and so for the record I'm
sending to Kevin avard all wet and as
you can see I'm
melting because it's it's like cats and
dogs out there but I am the prime
sponsor of s
sp555 and I am representing District 12
and I'm still out of breath from running
those stairs representative how are
you all right so thank you chair
chairman hunt you look a little
different today but that's
okay he's in uh Senate Commerce right
now so he'll be back oh I hope they
treat him nicely
there uh and for the record I am Senator
Kevin avard representing District 12 and
I'm here today to introduce Senate bill
um 555 which strengthens annual
reporting requirements regarding
pharmaceutical rebates and requires at
least 50% of the rebates to be shared
with the
consumers I'd like to start off by
providing a brief history of this issue
seeing that the legislator has
recognized the importance of this in the
past in 20120 we re we enacted RSA 415
A7 which requires rebates to be shared
in one or both of the following ways one
providing direct directly provided
directly to covered persons at the point
of sale to reduce the out of-pocket
cost secondly retained by the insurer to
reduce premiums the statute also
requires insurers to file an annual
report with the insurance department to
verify
compliance initial report from the
insurance department shows that insurers
are complying with the verification
Provisions by filing an
adapation but no details of proof of
compliance is part of that which is not
what the legislators contemplated when
they passed the law and acted and
additionally the statute sunsets July
1st
2024 Senate Bill 555 makes minor
modifications to the current law which
comes to us after discussion with the
insurance department the governor's
office this bill um provides uh New
Hampshire insurance department with the
tools appropriately uh with the tools to
appropriately verify the rebates held by
the insurers and which are being red
which are to reduce the premiums and yet
as it is drafted to ensure that no
proprietary information is made to the
public in doing so additionally this
legislation requires that at least 50%
of the rebates that the insurance
companies or the PBM negotiates with the
drug manufacturers to lower the actual
price shall be shared with the patients
at the pharmacy counter to help
consumers with they're out of pocket
expenses and why should consumers have
to uh why should have consumers have to
use the the list price when many of
these cases that are not in actual
company I would like to highlight that
this legislation also requires 50% which
in my belief is already a significant
compromise other states have adopted
laws requiring 100% of the rebates
shared at the counter and at least eight
other states are considering similar
legislation this year however this
proposal strikes a balance of
controlling premiums and helping
patients with their needs in in the most
at most in the pharmacies when they are
faced with out of- pocket deductibles
and co-pays imposed by insurers New
Hampshire consumers are paying more of
their out of pockets uh because of the
actual drug prices is not being used
when the calculation takes
place I want to provide you with an
example of how this would work and why
it's so important for our constituents
take Francis for example she has
diabetes and a chronic respiratory
disease she's enrolled in high
deductible plan with co-ace for
medicines and once her deductible is
reached let's assume she takes the
medication with the list price of $200
but for which her health parent receives
a rebate of 100 without this bill during
the uh the deductible phrase Francis
will pay $200 of her medicine even
though her Health Plan only pays
$100 if this legislation passes at least
50% of the rebate received by Francis
Health Plan would have to pass to her
when she buys a prescription which would
save her
money I'm in houses every
week I clean for a
living I see rich people people and I
see poor people I see people in
wheelchairs and with with all kinds of
prescriptions sitting on the
counter and I'm sorry to interrupt my
own testimony but you know there was one
lady where I did in
nsha she's by
herself she's got a whole row
of medicines and she's got her coins
lined up she got her it was
drugs it meant a lot to her you know 10
bucks can mean a lot to some people that
are destitute 50 bucks can mean a lot
there was another individual that I I
met he was in a wheelchair I did a flood
job for him nice house property taxes
went
up his his his food went up he's all by
himself even his dog food went up and
and he shows me his prescriptions of
$1,200 a month just the stay alive
military
guy we're not asking for 100% we're
asking for
100% so when she's buying prescription
with uh sorry for interrupting but um as
a result instead of paying the 200 for
her medicine she would pay no more than
150 and with the lower out- of- pocket
cost Francis may be more likely to take
her medicine prescribed by her doctor
potentially resulting in a better health
outcome and potentially avoiding
emergency room visits hospital
stays and other costly Services you'll
likely hear that the passing of the this
this bill will drastically increase
premiums and I'd like to point out to
West Virg that West Virginia whose law
also requires uh uh insurers and pbms to
share 100% of their savings uh they
negotiated with the medicine
directly to the patients in 2023
insurance rates finally indicate that
the premiums increased in West Virginia
are uh in line with national premium
increases in 2023 and did not
dramatically increase there is also um
Millan report which shows that in
Arkansas who also passed 100% that there
was no meaningful impact on
premiums again the proposal before you
uh allows the insurance of the pbms to
Ain 50% it's a
compromise of the savings of the premium
reductions and allows inure P of pbms
and of the higher percentage of savings
to reduce the premiums uh than uh than
West Virginia and Arkansas mandate you
may also hear about the rebates that a
pass through would be a difficult to
implement however it should be noted
that the insurance department filings
did require under current law Anthem
indicated that beginning in 200
21 they've implemented 100%
rebate in New
Hampshire and they share it with their
consumers at the counter for uh uh for
their individual and small and large
group
markets for some reason this never came
to our our test our our Hearing in in
HHS not sure why but it wasn't there uh
but I think it's significant that there
are people that in New Hampshire that
are are getting it at 100% but there are
not and I'm a little excited because I
also know that there's there's a lot of
resistance to this
bill and I find that objectionable
because we're trying to put money back
pockets um I think this is a very
important bill I think this helps people
that are on fixed incomes who do not
have
Anthem additionally when considering
this legislation the Senate adopted an
amendment to
further uh in further consultant with
several departments to exempt Medicaid
Medicare management programs and the
Ryan White uh HIV AIDS program and
self-funded plans such as the state
employees health benefits these changes
would result in no fiscal impact and I
emphasize that because somebody handed
me a fiscal impact that said it was
going to be $30 million out of the
state's pocket it wasn't true and I take
great offense to
mind the New Hampshire legislature has
an opportunity to truly help Granite
Staters afford their medications where
they need it most at the counter where
we recognize that four years ago we
passed the current law uh and S sp555
will help extend improve the drug
affordability for thousands of our
constituents and I ask this committee to
support this
legislation there are some very smart
people in this room that are going to be
talking to you that will have point and
Counterpoint I have to get back to
committee because I still have other
bills that we're we're uh trying to uh
exec so I'm going to ask you to hold
your questions and and answer have them
and I know the insurance Department's
here and uh and others so um I'm asking
you to pass this
bill I think it's a good bill I think
this puts a little bit of extra money
back into the pockets of people that I
them and I I know this would help them
that little bit will help
them and so with that God bless you all
and thank you thank you Senator avard
uh if you have written testimony would
you mind giving it to the clerk just
passing it
you uh Senator Susi did you want to
testify on this
bill and you support the
Bill thank you very much Mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
Susi I represent Senate District 18
comprised of the town of Lichfield and
five boards in the city of Manchester
um I don't want to repeat the points
that Senator avard has already raised um
but I am a co-sponsor of the bill and I
do think that as complicated as many of
the pharmaceutical issues are this is
one of the few pieces of legislation
that's distinct and that provides direct
consumer savings um we've talked a lot
about the cost of insurance and the
effec of Pharmacy benefit managers on
the system and the process of retail but
this bill would actually at the point a
consumer makes um their purchase uh
would realize the savings for those
consumers and for that reason I support
the legislation um I'd be happy to
spear thank you for answering my
question we were given from the uh
insurance department their analysis it
was a 2023 December analysis of the
insurance Market Market mhm and on page
49 of that market it says that in that
without rebates premiums go up
approximately $40 per person per member
per month now in the previous testimony
we talked about impacts to people at the
at the counter
MH we have finally made a dent in New
Hampshire with respect to getting more
people insured than we ever have in the
previous years we didn't have Medicaid
expansion
the single biggest reason people say
that they are not insured is the cost of
premiums according to the insurance
department
analysis the costs for premiums are
going to go up $50 $40 a month so we're
going to be dropping people off the
insurance
roles in order to give this in order to
give the benefit
which many people there are ways to get
some of these benefits other ways
question i' admittedly oh my question is
this are you're right I should asked the
question part have you when in making
this bill was any analysis done to see
what was going to how this was going to
impact the cost to the insurance base
that we have in this
state um thank you representative um I
you know I based um my testimony on the
fiscal note the fiscal note was
certainly what was considered when the
legislation was introduced uced um I I
think I would answer it in two parts as
well that when we're talking about this
we're not talking about every single
insured individual because as you know
the commercial Market is a segment um
there is Medicare there is Medicaid
there are different plans that are
self-run I'm sorry this analysis is only
on those groups that are covered by our
insurance department okay I I'm I'm
trying to answer your question
representative um so that that's the
first part of the question is that we're
looking at different segments of people
that are that are insured um the second
part that I would say to you is that
um there are major there is a major
insurer in this state that's already
giving 100% of the rebate so to suggest
that every premium is going to go up by
$40 um I don't agree with I I don't
think that's accurate that was not
information that was provided to us and
I just respectfully
disagree okay follow on follow
yeah I've talked to
Anthem and yes this year they do that
doesn't mean every year they will be
able to remember insurance companies are
regulated mhm 85% of the large market
and 40 and 80% of the small Market has
to go so my question
is I'm trying to put this in a in a
question format so my question is the
analysis has to be done over time and
the analysis has come from the insurance
department it's not like we made it up I
mean this is official information that
we were given uh it's very difficult to
find the basis on which you are
disagreeing with it on so can you
explain that by representative as I said
that analysis was done after the fact I
did not get the opportunity to review
the analysis before I was here I'm told
you I'm basing my testimony upon the
information that we had at the time we
voted in the Senate I do recognize that
it's a snapshot in time but I would
suggest that analysis is probably an
analysis that's a snapshot in time I
don't have it in front of me so I I
don't think going back and forth I I'm
not going to be able to read 49 Pages
between now and um the time the next
person is able to testify but certainly
we'll take a look at it afterward I'd be
happy to all right any other questions
representative M thank you Mr thank you
Mr chairman thank you Senator welcome to
Congress nice to see you um your
constituency is a little bit similar I
think to some of senator avard in that
you have um some City constituents so I
I wonder if you could speak to a a
little bit about the impact of
constituents who have uh multiple needs
for pharmaceuticals and prescriptions
and potentially as he
described uh high costs and scrimp and
save to pay for those and potentially
have to take their prescriptions every
other day or ration or just are unable
to comply with the prescription
orders and the longterm impact of going
off those prescriptions and the impact
on the health care costs
therefore thereby you know dealing with
the health problems caused by not being
on those prescriptions just say for
example uh a diabetic who goes off their
sugar management pills or injections or
whatever and then that drives higher
healthcare costs do you think that this
bill if it helps people stay on those
medications could that actually Drive
Healthcare cost savings is that has
there been any discussion or talk about
that well that type of
issue thank you representative um the
issue of insulin is something that you
know we've dealt with here in the state
to reduce cost it's been dealt with at
the federal level but you are right many
of my constituents do have to make
choices of whether or not to pay a bill
buy
groceries pay for certain
Pharmaceuticals that are costly there
are instances where people people are
making choices some of them for their
own health are bad choices because they
were prescribed medications that they
need to the extent that they're not
using them appropriately then you're
right there is a potential for greater
impact on cost um because it may create
more chronic conditions that lead to
other health care issues down the
road all right thank you looks like the
Chairman's back um I was going to call
Representative Leon next so I'll suggest
Senator good
morning good good morning for the record
I am representative Erica Lon
representing the town of dairy and uh
one time offered a position of providing
Wall Street an analysis over pbms uh
back in their early days I decided to
stay with medical implantable medical
devices because I thought those had a
larger net overall benefit to um to
society and to patients uh so looking at
this the whole intention of pbms and
these rebates is to be able to make sure
that when there are these choices the
the cost and the rebates are shared with
the people who are taking these
medications the cost of these drugs is
incredibly high and we discussed on
another bill the issue of Financial tox
toxicity if somebody's not able to
afford the medication that they should
be taken taking then that leads to worse
outcomes especially if they are taking a
lower dose or for goinging doses because
they're unable to pay for those
medications um drugs are expensive
because the approval process is
expensive but the process of having
rebates in order to help people pay for
their drugs is a good way to mitigate
that and I believe that it's absolutely
crucial that we pass this along to those
people who are taking these expensive
life-saving life improving or life
prolonging medications um so that the
cost to them is uh is mitigated as
opposed to having people within the
whole Healthcare ecosystem sort of suck
up those rebates instead of sending them
to the end users as they're intended so
um I I support this bill and uh with
that I'll take any questions but I I
have to say I haven't gotten quite as
deep into all those details of the
wording as uh the Senators so um keep me
at the surface for my questions please
okay representative
buros hi representative thanks for
taking my question do you know where
this disconnect may be between what
representative spear was talking about
that this will increase premiums and the
the Senate that said that that's not
going to happen do you have any insight
as to that um thank you for the question
looking at the fiscal node and how it
impacts Medicaid in Medicaid they use
that in order to offset the costs um we
may have insurers that are doing the
same thing but when you look at it um
individuals have individual needs and
right now the difference that you would
have on one of these private insurance
plans I'm really not sure I really don't
see how that would flow through to the
people who are the higher users of the
Health Care System who need these
expensive drugs in order to live or to
thrive and while that sort of spreads
the good amongst everybody these are the
people who have to pay this higher
co-pay and this higher out of pocket for
their need for the medication and to me
I think it's important to make sure that
those individuals are able to continue
um to afford and continue to take the
medication as prescribed um as opposed
to looking at the overall overall cost
of
insurance chairman
hun uh yes right representative Herbert
did ask before um you used the phrase uh
I think you said medical
toxicity and and and to me I immediately
said if that's if that's a real thing
and I suspect it is then what is the uh
are we holding
harmless those people who
are producing medical toxicity I mean is
it as if we're representing a a huge
constituency some are wealthy some are
not some are healthy some are not
and when you say something like that to
me that sounds to me as a uh a
litigation uh opportunity if the uh if
if some of the players here decide that
they want to or don't want to uh reduce
any prices or do any rebates U well
thank you for that question I was
talking about financial toxicity not
MediCal toxicity because any drug has
has an overdose rate you can overdose on
drinking too much water um so there are
risks with any treatment um yeah because
it it it distills your electrolytes um
but when you look at that there's the
medical toxicity and the dose makes the
poison that's part of the risk that you
take when you're taking drugs the
financial toxicity is making sure is
helping to do what we can without
undermining the whole process of
bringing new drugs to Market to make
sure that people are able to afford the
medications they need because if you
were cutting your pills in half or only
taking them half as frequently um
because of that non-compliance with your
prescribed medication you will likely
have worse outcomes there's other people
that just don't do the treatments they
may not take um a medicine that deals
with their side effects because it's
more expensive and because they don't
take the drug that helps with their side
effects they can't treat their condition
appropriately so um the whole idea of
rebates was to be able to push some of
that back to those end users those
people who were taking these medications
and I believe that having this drive
that back through to where should be um
is is a good step from us um you can
never remove any potential litigation
from the world of medicine but I don't
see this creates any new or unique risk
for
spear I'm trying to form this in a form
of a question and I don't want to say
would you believe but
in investigating this which is in that
way that I typically
have
rebates are a negotiation carried on by
pbms on a volume
basis to be able to put insurance uh to
to be able to put drugs on a lower level
in a formulary it is not nothing to do
with patients it has to do with where it
is in the formulary so that the patients
can have a lower
co-pay but if we're going to be taking
that bulk of money that was negotiated
out at the risk now right now anybody
any drug company any I'm sorry insurance
company is allowed to put the rebates at
whatever level they want and use them
how they can feel with their business uh
plan in order to meet their legal
requirements if we force them into one
segment and if we give those rebates
take those rebates away from the C cost
of premiums aren't we also just throwing
more people off the insured
roles which has no benefit to anybody
and is a very bad impact on the state as
we have seen over the years do you
see do you not see that I don't know how
to ask this question no thank you it's
an incredibly complicated process and
it's one where the insurance companies
the drug companies and everybody else
involved are continually responding to
legislation and rules at both the
federal and state level there are a lot
of things that we have done here and
that we've done in the state and we have
done federally that make Insurance more
expensive than it needs to be so I'm
highly sensitive to all those times when
we do things that make exp Insurance
more expensive than it needs to be um
and we need to address those when you
look at the use of these rebates to put
it in a different tier on the formulary
um there is there is some argument that
if you have something that has a co-pay
for $10 instead of $20 or $20 instead of
$100 that that's in effect getting a
rebate uh because it's on a lower
formulary but the question becomes is
what is the discount that they are
getting from the drug manufacturers in
order to shift into that formulary
because there's a benefit to the drug
manufacturers as well to have those
volumes um when I was an analyst
covering companies I also we they some
of those companies were device companies
but they also had drugs so the more
consistent of sales that they had even
if it was a lower price price point is
rewarded by investors so there's a
benefit to those drug companies from
having those consistent sales even if
they are at a lower price point so that
helps them and the pbms there's the
benefit to them in order to capture as
much of the rebate as they can what I'm
looking at is you know my neighbor who's
going to the drug store and trying to
make sure that she can afford her
medication and making sure that she is
getting some of that rebate not just in
changing what tier it's in because
they're not required to change the tier
in order to pass it along but just to
make sure that those people whose lives
depend on expensive medications get some
of this because drugs are expensive
because it costs over a billion dollars
to bring a drug to Market um and a lot
of the other efforts in order to give
lower cost drugs to patients um some of
the Compassionate Care some of those
have been short circuited because the
way that that the Medicare and Medicaid
payments happen if you give drug to free
somebody then you're going to have to
give it to free to everybody on Medicaid
or on Medicare so it's highly complex
but I think that given even all the
complexity this is a way we can help the
people of New Hampshire and I don't
think it's going to have a have a
premiums thank you very much thank you
uh the chair will call in DJ beton Court
from
Insurance good morning Mr chairman
members of the committee as you well
know by now my name is DJ bport and I
have the pleasure of serving as the
commissioner of the New Hampshire
insurance department I joined this
morning by Michelle Heaton the
Department's director of life and health
I'll be candid with you with the
exception of Senate Bill
173 no piece of legislation has absorbed
more of the Department's time and focus
than Senate Bill 555 not that we are
complaining we enjoy working on
significant legislation and we realize
that it is an important part of what we
do uh but the consequence of that is
that this will be some of the lengthier
testimony uh that I have provided to
this
committee so with that as it pertains to
where rebates should be applied be they
at point of sale or integrated into
premiums that is a policy decision for
you to
decide as has been mentioned you're
going to hear a lot of competing
testimony this morning and you will have
to determine what direction is best the
the only comment that I will make
because you are going to hear and in
fact you have already heard reference to
the Department's annual hearing report
that does touch upon prescription drug
rebates uh that uh piece of it of that
annual hearing was conducted by the
Actuarial firm of oliv Oliver Wyman and
they reported that the Actuarial value
of prescription drug rebates in 2022 was
$38 per per member per month which
represented an 11.7% increase from
2021 the $34 expressed as a per capita
annual cost with that all equates to
$456 per person in 2022 up from
$48 in
2021 across commercially insured markets
the total value of rebates again
according to Oliver Wyman was estimated
to be approximately $90 million in
2022 so along that line of logic if this
legislation were to pass with the 50%
rebate at point of sale provision
approximately $45 million could
potentially be absorbed into premiums or
applied as upward pressure on
premiums now the question that has been
asked I'm sure the question that perhaps
is on your mind is is that likely to
happen and I have a wholly unsat
satisfying answer for you I don't know
I'm not certain how the commercial
Market will respond to the 50% rebate
remit requirement at the point of sale
the reasons why for example are a person
has a $15 co-pay for a drug that costs
$500 if the rebate on that specific
prescription is $400 the co-pay is still
$15 and even if the $15 co-pay is w CED
to reduce the outof pocket cost only $15
would be credited at point of sale
despite the $400 rebate beyond that we
do not know how the market will
implement the systems to guarantee the
50% rebate some may try to work around
the requirement While others may choose
to eliminate rebates entirely
perspectives and opinions vary on that
point as you will hear and as you've
already heard uh but I just cannot tell
you with any certainty how exactly this
will play out as I have said how you
choose to proceed is your decision and
we will execute whatever decision you
make but because the actual anal
analysis was essentially work uh was
essentially Department work product I
did want to address it with all of that
said I am here to advocate for the
transparency and accountability
Provisions in the uh proposal before
you when the legislature established the
current Arrangement a few years ago the
department was tasked with collecting
reports from carriers on how things were
unfolding with rebates and premiums
unfortunately we discovered that those
reports the reports that we got and for
those of you who have gotten them and
have reviewed them I think would agree
that the law did not provide us with the
Authority or the tools necessary to get
get data uh that was of value that could
give us a comprehensive understand
understanding of how things were playing
out and frankly uh my team was a bit
frustrated that we lacked the ability to
provide something to you of high quality
we always try to do that when given a
responsibility or a charge from the
legislature so this amendment or the
proposal uh attempts to address that
issue by specifying more clearly the
data information and methodologies that
the carriers and pbms need to provide
the department so that we can adequately
report back to
you it strengthens our ability to
provide oversight to this important
segment of our healthc care delivery
system and this will better as I said
allow us to understand how things are
playing out and make public where
appropriate to avoid disclosure of any
proprietary information a much more
detailed analysis to uh policy makers
and the public so we do support as I
said those transparency and
accountability provisions of the
proposal
with regard to sections D and E of The
Proposal those sections are related to
anti- steering initiatives that some
other states have created uh to prohibit
our position is that laws prohibiting
steering by pbms to their male order
pharmacies inhibit the economic benefits
integration in terms of what we would
suggest you to consider as you go
forward is to try to find a legislative
approach that balances the importance of
transparency with financial incentives
to promote efficiencies in prescription
drug delivery we believe that that can
produce the best result for
consumers finally I do want to address
uh a bit of a misunderstanding of sorts
U the claim has been made and I've heard
it in a couple of different forums that
the New Hampshire insurance department
wrote this bill I want to clarify that
this is not a department initiative uh
this was not something that we want
wanted to wait into as I said at the
outset we believe that this was a policy
decision for all of you to make now that
being said in the fall we were engaged
by the governor's office uh he was
conceptually thinking about uh trying to
bring some ideas and proposals forward
on this topic uh he asked us to put
together a proposal that would uh
reflect a 50% uh rebate at point of sale
we provided him with language as we
would do to any of you that asked for
our assistance uh but this was not an
initiative of the department as I said
we simply provided uh the governor's
office with functional language uh to
carry forward uh what it is that he
wanted to put before you for
consideration so I did want to clarify
that and with that said Michelle was
there anything you'd like to add that
I've missed no Michelle says no so I'm
happy to take your questions okay all
thank you I I read the report in quite a
bit of detail and I thought it was very
informative but one of the things that I
saw was that for the last three years
out of
four in the report it keeps showing
rates going up little by little by
little by little so the pressure is
already there to raise
4.9% uh uninsured rate in this state
which is probably a record I don't know
you could answer that but it was down
from
6.1% a few years
ago do you envision that if rates hit a
certain point that people are going to
start dropping out of the
rols sure that's always a risk and that
is always something that we're very
sensitive to one of the biggest
roadblocks to Consumers being able to
get access to care is cost and it is why
this state and the federal government
have spent so much time and effort and
resources into trying to bring down
premiums particularly in our individual
Market I'm proud of the fact that the
state moved forward with a 1332 waiver a
few years ago that has helped bring uh
premiums down at individual Market
dramatically and the combined efforts of
the state and the federal government
have resulted in New Hampshire having
some of the lowest premiums in the
Northeast and I think that's something
that we can all be proud of uh so we are
sensitive
when we see proposals that could begin
to erode or undermine uh those efforts
um in terms of why premiums are going up
there's a number of different reasons
for that uh it's the reason why you all
many years ago put it in statute that we
have to conduct an annual hearing every
year to disclose the analysis of what we
are seeing that is driving health care
costs and premiums we do that every fall
uh we encourage enourage all of you to
attend but if not those sessions are
recorded and you can take a look and
it's not just the Department's work
product we do bring in Actuarial experts
uh to do that analysis as well Michelle
is there anything to add uh the only
thing I'd add is in the individual
market with the um expanded subsidies
under the um arpa as well as our 1332
waiver from in 2020 we had about 45,000
in the individual Market as of March of
this year that's up to
76,000 so we've had've seen large growth
in our individual market and as the
commissioner said we have the some of
the lowest premiums in the individual
Market in the country not just the
Northeast so I think um there's a lot of
different factors he said that can
contribute to premium growth but right
now we have some of the lowest premiums
in the country and we have um record
thank you very much oh we do have
questions I have a I have a question
thank you commissioner uh I don't know
if it's a Germaine question or not uh
how many markets do we have I have uh
Medicare Medicaid small large and
individual is that the market that we
have that's our insured
people so in terms of how individuals
get coverage there are a number of
different ways they can do that as
you've identif ified so obviously you
have your government sponsored program
so that's your Medicare Medicaid that's
not something we oversee that's done by
the State Department of Health and Human
Services in the federal
government you then have fully insured
plans that are established under Arisa
which is a federal law um most of your
large employers are self-funded again
that's outside of our regulatory purview
although we do try to leverage our
relationships with the carriers to
address consumer issues uh in those
plans what we oversee are the fully
insured individual small group and large
group market so that's kind of the full
Kaleidoscope of coverages that people
can access in New Hampshire okay follow
up just for a second further question
thank you uh could you let us know
approximately the percentages of each
one of
these we got that chart last week oh
okay yep you've got the chart but in
terms of what we oversee which is again
is the fully
insured um individual small group large
group Market that represents
approximately 30% okay of health
coverage in New Hampshire thank you I'd
also refer you to um our annual report
that breaks down in a lot of detail all
of the different markets the numbers
ratios and it also includes um some
stuff about the self-insured market as
well okay it's my stack ofil
somewhere okay
repres thank you Mr chairman I just want
to ask a higher level
question if the department is a supports
supposed or is taking no position on on
the bill as part of your answer but as a
policy question does the department in
general support reducing prescription
costs at the point of sale for
healthcare consumers and and if so do
you think that might help people in
their decision of whether they fill
their prescription or don't fill their
prescription and and in general help
them take those medications they need if
they have to make that tough decision to
walk away when the pharmacist says it's
50 hundred $20 or whatever sure and
ultimately would that drive better
patient outcomes so as a policy decision
do you
support lowering prescription costs at
the point of sale as a way to improve
patient outcomes well as a fundamental
matter obviously we want to see healthy
proposals that bring down the cost of
medications that people need how best to
do that as I've mentioned a couple of
times at this point as it pertains to
this proposal is a policy decision for
you to make again I don't know exactly
how this plays out so
could you potentially see lower costs at
point of sale perhaps but is there a
cost shift into premium that either
negates the saving or causes the saving
to be overwhelmed and and ends up being
a net negative to to the consumer again
I don't know exactly how that plays out
uh Dr AZ is here also works for our
department spends a great amount of his
time uh looking at those very very
issues issues uh and it's complicated
Michelle Dr anything to
add the only thing I would add is the
whole purpose of insurance is to have a
large number of individuals come
together to share that risk so by doing
that you're pulling you know the risk
that you get stuck with a high cost
prescription drug and have to you know
someone has to cover that is spread out
among everyone if you do point of sale
that risk is not not necessarily being
spread out among everyone so I just keep
that in mind too a big picture of how
Insurance works but there's a lot of
nuances here there's a lot of you know C
but that's dead on what the issue is
because it let's face it rebates are
adverse
selection in the insurance market right
now the biggest problem is the high
deductible plans that an employer
chooses that
deductibility so theoretically you
wouldn't need these baates if someone
chose a very low deductible you know
very high you you know coverage and then
you wouldn't need this rebates at all
but that if you choose the the the
problem is that by the rebate is you're
now mudding the
waters in terms of that choice that that
person made or their employer made in
terms of what insurance plan they chose
in terms of deductibles in co-base yes
represent MCU follow up yeah thank
thanks for the quick overview on risk
pooling and insurance which I think
everybody on this committee understands
risk pooling and the basics of insurance
whether it's car or health but thanks
for the quick overview but I guess the
opposite applies right when you when you
have uh you know healthy patients and
you pick off some of them least healthy
or unhealthy and you want to skew that
risk risk pool you could literally make
the exact opposite argument and say if
you you drive people away from taking
their medications you drive them closer
to some of the most common and most
expensive treatments like say just for
instance
dialysis right I mean that's one of the
biggest draws on Healthcare dialysis and
that's why there's the big efforts to
you know drive to home hemodialysis and
keep people away from kidney transplants
and I mean I can name 50 other disease
states that are exactly the same so the
issue is keep them on the medic ations
so that the other people in those pieces
of the pie don't bear the high risk and
we don't do the exact opposite of what
you're talking about so I mean the same
applies and and that is the problem with
the the high deductible and low
deductible I me because the Health Care
system has shifted from HMO over the
years from when I first joined your
committee years ago but it shifted so we
balance represent
spear I know that rebates don't apply to
all drugs I know typically they don't
apply to
generics they don't apply for drugs that
have no competition that are still
within their patent limits and patent
times and whatever other exclusivity
things they have do you have any idea
what percentage of
drugs either volume I guess it's really
a question for you either volume wise
cost wise or whatever that we will have
somebody from
the I'm sorry the Pharm we have someone
from the pbms who will help you no I was
okay could you repeat that
there so only a small proportion of
drugs actually fetch robust rebates and
so that's important I understand it's a
good question it's constantly
changing and it's mostly branded drugs
yeah okay thank you very much I think
set okay uh so I have Rachel Lam from
representing
thank you I appreciate that thank you
for receiving my testimony my name is
Rachel coddle leam representing Pharma
which represents a trade Association of
the leading Innovative brand name
biopharmaceutical manufacturers um and
I'm here today on behalf of our members
to express support for Senate Bill 555
as others have explained negotiations
between pharmaceutical manufacturers
Health insurers and Pharmacy benefit
managers result in significant rebates
and discounts and this bill would
require at least 50% of the rebates that
insurers and pbms receive from
pharmaceutical manufacturers to be
applied to lower the cost of medicines
for New Hampshire patients at the point
of sale this is a viable policy solution
that many states are considering and
some have already enacted to make
medicines more affordable because it
would provide patients with direct
immediate savings to lower their outof
pocket cost for prescription medicines
which in turn helps patients access and
adhere to the medicines they need our
industry is concerned that in 2023 alone
the approximately $344 billion do in
rebates and discounts paid by
manufacturers this is at national scale
are not making their way to offsetting
Patient costs at the pharmacy counter
and as it stands today in New Hampshire
insurers and pbms are not required to
share any portion of these negotiated
discounts directly with patients and to
see how these price concessions are not
currently benefiting most patients it's
very important to look at the growing
gap between the undiscounted list price
of medicines and a medicine's net price
after rebates and discounts on average
net prices for brand medicines are 50%
lower than list prices as a result of
these price concessions and in fact more
than half of spending on brand medicines
on average is retained by Health
insurers pbms and others in the
pharmaceutical supply chain and not the
manufacturer who researched and
developed the medicine but at the same
time and even while net price growth for
brand medicines has been at or below
inflation for the last 6 years many many
patients are being forced to pay more
out of pocket for their medicines and
this is because of an increase in
deductibles and the use of Co Insurance
the use of which has increased
significantly over the last decade the
share of patient outof pocket drug
spending attributable to co insurance
has more than doubled over the past 10
years while the share attributable to
deductibles has tripled And yet when
patients facing their deductible or
paying co-insurance the amount they must
pay for their medicine is often based on
the full list price and this is even
while their insurer and PBM are only
paying the discounted amount they
negotiated with the manufacturer and
this means that the cost to patients is
often much higher than the cost to their
health plan and that's for the same
medicine on the same prescription and
it's important to note that this problem
is unique to coverage of prescription
medicines patients do receive the
benefit of negotiated discounts when
sharing in costs for doctor or hospital
visits but they often do not receive the
same benefit for prescription drugs and
fixing this broken part of the system
and sharing these savings not only has
an impact for that patient at the
pharmacy counter but could have a
broader positive impact on the Health
Care System lowering patients cost at
the pharmacy can improve health outcomes
and generate savings through improved
adherence and the elimination of
avoidable health care costs poor
medication adherence is associated with
increased hospitalizations nursing home
Admissions and physician visits yet in
2021 61% of commercially insured
patients did not fill their new
prescription when outof pocket cost
exceeded
$250 when patients cannot afford the
outof pocket cost for their medications
this can lead to patients rationing
their medicines or not taking them which
can result in devastating consequences
to their health and as I start to
conclude my comments I just want to
highlight that passing through rebates
at the point of sale could save patients
on their outof pocket costs without
raising insurance premiums three states
West Virginia Arkansas and Indiana have
already enacted rebate pass through laws
and we heard testimony previously that
in Arkansas which requires insurers and
pbms to share 100% of the savings they
negotiate on medicines directly with
patients a review of 2024 insurance rate
filings indicates the plans are passing
through drug rebates to patients at the
pharmacy counter and that there has been
no material impact on premium rate
increases for Arkansas still New
Hampshire's approach in Senate Bill 555
which would require 50% pass through is
more measured than other approaches
requiring full pass through so in
conclusion our industry feels strongly
that Senate Bill 555 balances the goals
and controlling premiums and helping
patients where they need it most which
is at the pharmacy counter so for all
these reasons we urge the committee to
support Senate Bill 555 thank you
represent
spear I noticed in the list of people
that you say have some effect on the
price insurance companies deductibles
pbms all these folks
drug companies that manufacture drugs
are not listed in that
list so my question
is I looked uh but I've got to form this
thing in a form of a question
so you sure you're asking the right
industry that's that's who I'm talking
about the drug
manufacturers I see drug prices going up
on average uh somewhere between 6 and
15% a year based on analysis by a number
Medicare how does that factor into why
patients are having trouble affording
their
drugs I mean it doesn't that count and
realizing that I do know what the profit
rate is on drugs so be careful how you
answer that certainly no I appreciate
the question and I think I'd start by
saying that we certainly recognize that
we have a role to play and you know I
think if any any one of us could go back
to start and and go back to a system
that was much more simpler we certainly
would do that I think that manufacturers
though are as you point out I'm
representative one entity in a complex
supply chain um that takes a medication
from the manufacturer that researches
and develops the medicine to the patient
at the point of sale and there are many
entities along the way that um receive
compensation for Distributing that
medication to a patient and so um I
think that there are a lot of perverse
incentives in the system as it's
designed today and I think that
correcting some of these misaligned
incentives is is one way to start to
help patients not only in the longer
term but also um in the more immediate
term as as we feel strongly that this
do okay representative
Herbert
um I've been listening to this
conversation
you're going to ask a question right
would you believe but have you uh as
representing your group uh have
you have
you ideas as to what the
legislation would would should look like
from your
perspective I mean I have I believe the
fact is a lot of the
financing of R&D actually comes from the
federal
government and uh so as a result of that
uh I have I have I think it's important
to realize that the taxpayer and the
federal government have been the major
financer financer of
R&D and uh but okay I would like to hear
some ideas specifically that could be
part of this legislation or in addition
to this legislation that you think would
be more effective than the legislation
we
have thank you for the question I think
that um first I would start by um
suggesting that the private investment
in research and development um
manufacturers on average invest around
three times more than the total annual
budget of the National Institute of
Health and research and investment so
the Private Industry is really crucial
to not only um the research and
development phase but also bringing a a
fully formed drug to Market um however
to your question about um ideas I think
that we really do view this approach as
a very balanced and measured approach
that balances um controlling premiums
with providing direct benefit to
patients at the pharmacy counter and in
addition um concerning other ideas that
that our industry supports we in terms
of misaligned incentives which I've just
mentioned um we we feel strongly that
breaking the link between um Pharmacy
benefit manager compensation which is
currently tied to the list price of
medication I spoke a little bit about
that gap between the list price and net
price of medicine um that really creates
some upward pressure on list price and
we feel strongly that breaking that link
um would create a lot of room in the
system to to bring prices down
overall but that should be all drugs not
just your new latest greatest one
shouldn't it I mean I represent that the
brand biopharmaceutical manufacturers
and um you know I I think that a lot of
patients um who take brand medicines
have chronic and complex conditions and
though that's a reason we feel strongly
that this bill would would really
benefit those patients why shouldn't we
just ban these high deductible plans why
don't we solve this problem for
everybody just get rid of the high
deductible plans and and hope that the
uh pharmaceutical companies will just
lower their prices so that we don't have
as big of an insurance increase yeah you
know I think I think that we're willing
to have conversations and be a partner
with our other industry Partners to to
continue the conversation about the best
way to to lower the cost of healthare
for consumers and certainly we we really
think this bill is one way to do that it
is okay thank
you oh all right I give up thank you I
up represent bam yeah thank you for
taking my question why are
Pharmaceuticals so much more expensive
in the US than any other country in the
world I think that looking when we
compare you know pharmaceutical prices
in the United States and other countries
we're kind of making an apples and
oranges comparison um you know other
countries have resorted to government
price setting and in those countries we
know that patients um have access to
fewer new Med medications and it takes
longer um for for patients to get the
medications that they need and I think
that you know that might not sound like
such a big deal but if you're a patient
waiting um for a breakthrough new cancer
medication for example um in a country
in Europe that might not have the new
medication on the market um and that's
the life-saving treatment you need um I
think that changes the conversation a
lot so um I I think there are a lot of
variables there certainly um patients
you know who are in other countries that
do have government price setting
proposals um do not do not face um
excuse me do not are not subject to the
same middlemen the system that we are
are subject to here in the United
States yes among others okay thank
represent we you already past our time
and you I got a pile of cards here so go
ahead ask questions thank you Mr
chairman I'll keep I'll keep it quick
some of your testimony was really
interesting you talked about the um the
premiums not going down I'm curious I'm
sorry if I missed it did the rebates
start to get cut off so when
do you understand what I mean did did
the manufacturers then since they were
forced to pass them on did they just say
okay we're not going to do rebates
anymore no in those States the the study
the specific study which was produced by
mman shows that rebates are in fact
passing through to patients at the
pharmacy counter and and we don't have
evidence to date that rebates have have
decreased so they kept they kept doing
them anyways yes rebates were're passing
through we find that some companies
offer do the rebates and some do
not but in the states they passed they
kept doing them according to her her
testimony okay thank you
okay thank you uh chair we'll call
H oh hi thank you chair hunt it's h I
would like to invite uh Curtis Barry up
to testify along with me if that's okay
I'll go first if that's okay um good
morning Mr chair members of the
committee U my name is Curtis Barry here
on behalf of uh pcma which is the
pharmaceutical Care Management
Association the national trade
Association for the PBM industry um
seems to be the target uh first of all I
will uh say at the outset and I'll
probably repeat myself this bill does
nothing to lower the cost of
prescription drugs it cost shifts um
I've left you to to illustrate that I've
left you a package the front page looks
like this
pcma um the second and third sheets I
think are most telling uh second one
looks like
this going from 2018 to
2023 in
2018 it took the top seven brands
of name brand top seven drugs of name
brand Pharmaceuticals to equal all the
generic drug
spending in 2023 that's down to two only
two drugs equals the entire spend for
generic
drugs the second page illustrates for
you and I won't walk you through it but
illustrates for you the top 10 selling
drugs in their patent history this is
important because as you can see a
number of them most of them have the
lowest number of patents is 57 this is
the game that Pharma plays by extending
their patents and keeping the the name
brand drugs
expensive so what are rebates rebates
are a volume discount negotiated between
a PBM and a
manufacturer it's effective because pbms
typically the larger ones or the smaller
ones have a lot more lives than their
client
companies so a PBM can negotiate with a
manufacturer on behalf of tens of
millions of lives versus for example the
state of New Hampshire negotiating on
its own on behalf of tens of thousands
of lives there's leverage with
volume um this is why health plans of
all different types self-insured
governments commercial insurers use pbms
they negotiate steeper
discounts but as a couple of the
discussions just alluded to recently
rebates only apply to a small fraction
of of the dispensed drugs first of all
rebates don't apply to generics generics
are inexpensive by Nature rebates also
don't apply in the case where a drug is
the only choice there are not competing
drugs for a condition or a disease if
you're a manufacturer and you're the
only game in town you have no incentive
to lower your price the analysis shows
that less than 3% of drugs dispensed
have rebates meaning if to use the
figure that you heard from the insurance
department less than
30% uh of the commercial insurance to
which this applies is less than 30% of
the market so we're talking about less
than 3% of the drugs in less than 30% of
the market those people will benefit but
the rest of us um will see an
impact um one of the logistical issues
with the bill um rebates are typically
applied in the rearview mirror they
applied on a quarterly basis looking at
the volume in the previous quarter so
all this bill would ask is for an
estimate to be made and that's not going
to be
accurate
um this bill has three impacts from our
perspective one it drives utilization to
higher price drugs which then everybody
else will pay um two and please this is
not a a lower tier worry I hate them I'm
sorry for the pun but it it it is a
concern um it allows Pharma a look into
the proprietary and confidential
information that is the negotiation
between a PBM and a manufacturer on a
particular drug the US Federal Trade
Commission found in a report quote if
manufacturers learn the exact amount of
rebates offered by competitors the
required disclosures may lead to higher
pharmaceuticals um in addition uh at the
Federal level the Congressional budget
office looked at this issue and
estimated and this was specific to
Medicare because that's obviously their
per
purview it estimated that while some
Medicare beneficiaries would have lower
drug costs overall cost to the Medicare
program would increase by $170 billion
over 10 years causing premiums to
increase for all beneficiaries CBA also
estimated that Medicaid costs were
increased by $7 billion over the same
period
um continuing on the impact of rates
you've heard examples from other states
I suggest a longer look at when those
bills were effective most of them were
2023 with the exception of West Virginia
and what is the year in which the the
they're citing the rate increase is it
using the experience of that law being
in
effect um I'm not going to repeat uh the
insurance Department's data I think they
did a a fine job of that um in and
lastly I will um I think address some of
the assertions by the sponsor and others
about the fiscal note first of all the
sponsor cited a patient or someone they
know with you know kitchen counter full
of drugs given the previous
data I think it's fair to assume that a
lot of those are generic drugs or the
only game in town and the rebates aren't
going to apply
anyway but if we're cost
shifting does it help the system does it
help all of us if we're Shifting the
cost to everybody else with the co-pays
and increase the co-pay from $10 to
$15 but more importantly and also a
point that I don't think should be lost
if this is great policy for the patients
of the State of New Hampshire why did
the Senate specifically explicitly
exempt
Medicaid and I I apologize Mr chair this
sounds like a flip rhetorical question
it should be a serious question why all
so did the Senate explicitly exempt the
state employees health plan if this is
good policy shouldn't the state
employees and their families of the
State of New Hampshire benefit from this
policy the reality is as he alluded to
yes there was an impact and it doesn't
seem to make sense logically to me Mr
chair and members of the committee that
you can acknowledge that there's a cost
to the state the state employees plan by
passing this policy which the bill
exempts and that there's a cost to
Medicaid and the Medicaid director test
testified at the Senate hearing asking
to be Exempted but there would be no
cost increase to the commercial
insurance it just doesn't make sense um
I'll ask Sam to if I missed anything and
he's here to help answer questions if
there are any and I should be specific I
apologize the objection that I'm talking
to is the first page of the bill section
two of the bill uh essentially lines 27
to 29 we have no issue with the
increased reporting uh in fact I think
you'll hear testimony later on that the
second half of the bill which was in a
senate Amendment um was negotiated with
with the department and we're perfectly
fine with that so thanks the only thing
that I would the only thing that I would
add is uh Maine did take a look at this
policy proposal this year legislative
session and they did do a fiscal note
for the state employee plan and found
that for fiscal year 24 2024 2025 it
would be an increase in $2 million Al
loone to the state employee plan if this
policy were to pass and that bill did
die uh in committee due to that high
fiscal
note uh so I would with that they didn't
just pull it out of the bill like like
our Senate did they just killed the
whole
thing correct yes so we're happy to take
any
questions re in bullo first thank you
for taking my question do you think this
is just a Feelgood
bill I think that asked to you know the
old uh issue that that asks us to assess
the motivations I really can't answer
that Curtis has been around a long
time okay representative
McVey um thank you Mr chairman if if I'm
understanding you correctly you're
you're really saying in the long run
this is going to have the actual
opposite effect of what we're what you
you think the bill is proposing to do is
that correct yes that's correct I mean I
don't think there's any doubt that very
few people will benefit but you can't
take the figure whatever the figure is
from the insurance department $90
million you can't just take it out of
the system and have it go
nowhere and the reality is the minimum
loss ratio in terms of how rates are set
um is over a three-year average so
you're not going to really see the
effect for three plus years before where
you start to see the premiums will
increase represent preli thank thank you
for your testimony and allowing my
question um drug pricing is a bit of a
black box so can you help me understand
you represent pbms about how many are
there in the country and what how are
they compensated thank you for the
question representative pcas uh has
about 20 PBM members but out in the rest
of the United States I believe there's
about 60 other pbms all competing for
business that's my understanding
yes 60 sorry 60 60 that's it just 60 yes
okay and how are they compensated how
are they compensated how are they
compensated they administer prescription
drug benefits for payers uh through
self-insured and fully insured plans
okay but do they get a percentage of the
drug how are they compensated thank you
for the question it's all dependent on
how the plan wants to design their
benefit and pay for those benefits at
the end of the day it's a
contraction and under statute we are not
allowed to know exactly what is the
relationship between an insurance
company and health care provider so it's
actually the same thing is true for
hospitals doctors anyone who's who is uh
you know has a contract with an
insurance company it's secret secret and
the reason being is that the competitor
the other insurance company they want to
make sure that they don't know what they
got in the
contract representa
Herbert
um what does break the link mean to
you uh I'm sorry representative could
you repeat the
question the uh uh the representative of
the
manufacturers I asked her a question is
if you're going to improve the
legislation what would you advise and
the advice came in the form of break the
link which doesn't mean much to me so
I'm trying to figure I I'm I what is
break the link evidently doesn't mean
anything to him either so I'm not
familiar with that phrase
so no answer we okay anybody else seeing
none thank you very much for your
testimony okay Holly Stevens from Nami
good
morning good morning chairman hunt
members of the committee my name is
Holly Stevens I'm the director of public
policy for Nami New Hampshire uh the
National Alliance on Mental Illness Nami
New Hampshire is a nonprofit Grassroots
organization whose mission is to improve
the lives of all people impacted by
mental illness and suicide through
support education and advocacy and I'm
here today um speaking in support of
Senate Bill uh
555 at Nami New Hampshire we have heard
from many Granite Staters who are not
able to afford their
medications they resort to skipping
doses taking reduced Doses and delaying
filling their medications due to their
inability to afford their
medications uh further in June of 2023
the Center for Disease Control and
prevention National Center for health
statistics released a data brief which I
have included um as a part of my
testimony um regarding adults that did
not take their medications as prescribed
to reduce the out-of-pocket costs uh
they found that 8.2% of adults aged 18
to 64 did not take their medications as
prescribed due to the cost but what they
also found was this jumped up to
20% for folks who had a disability and
it was 18% for folks that reported not
feeling well or um having medical
conditions that impacted their their
health
um we know that um when folks don't take
their medications as prescribed it
worsens their symptoms and could lead to
costly hospitalizations it would be
unnecessary if the medications were more
affordable there's been a lot of
discussion about increase of premiums
and this impact that this bill might
have another thing that increases
premiums is when people have to be
hospitalized hospitalization are
extremely costly and so if someone's not
able to take a medication that could
cost a few hundred dollar that results
in them being in the hospital that costs
thousands of dollars that can also
increase
premiums um the sharing of these rebates
um will help some people um be able to
afford their medications that could end
up prevent preventing uh costly other
interventions in the long run and one of
the things that's not in my test
testimony that I wanted to share with
this committee is the fact that I myself
out of pocket pave between 5 and $600
for my
medications those are medications that I
need in order to be able to come here
and testify because without them I would
not be able to work I would not be able
to function um so I just wanted to
relate that that it is a real issue um
and it's an issue that impacts a lot of
people including people who come here
um and testify before you um I we do
urge this committee to seriously
consider passing this bill and I'm happy
to answer any questions that you may
have uh represent spearers first
sorry I'm sorry I
caved I thought you said you were done
I'm not done I I'm never
done I just take a break uh thank you
for my uh asking uh allowing me to ask a
question
I I I understand the point that you're
making and I appreciate
that but the T drugs that we're talking
about for which rebates are available
are brand name
drugs and do you know that have no
competition do you know if any of those
do have competition applies that's why
they're doing the rebate is because they
do have comp but but of the drugs that
people need
that are covered by your organization
that you deal with do you know of if
that in fact is what is causing their
their uh co-pay
problems I don't know that for sure but
I do know that there are a lot of um
brand brand name brand new anticho
medications that are on the market and I
think the insurers would probably be
better um better able to answer the
exact um psychiatric medications that
are subject to rebates um but I'm also
happy to um talk with um uh Miss croll
and um Miss Dunlap to find out um and
then provide you the information about
medications that they have rebates for
that are um psychiatric
medications okay representative
buros thanks for taking my question I
thought it was an excellent point you
raised about cost going up of f these
folks don't get their medications do you
know if there's any studies been done
about those costs versus you know what
the discussion we've had here about
raising
premiums I don't know but I'm happy to
look into that and get back to you I
think that' be I I think that' be an
interesting um statistics to have I will
I will absolutely look into that and get
you represent muu thank you for taking
my question thank you Mr chairman are
some of the medications that individuals
you work with with in the Mental Health
Community are some of those qu those
medications long-term medications that
then eventually need to be switched to
newer brand name medications because
when they're on them long term they
develop cardiovascular or cardiac side
effects like SSRI medications that cause
cardiac issues and then a newer one
comes out and then the
providers want to try them and so
they're very
specifically subject to some of these
rebates is that is that something that
you encounter in the mental health thank
you for the question I I haven't looked
into that um again because I don't
prescribe medications I'm a lawyer by
trade not a doctor by trade um so I
don't know um the exact uh treatment
protocols that folks have but again it's
one of those things that I'm happy to
talk with some of the doctors at New
Hampshire hospital and and get back to
you on uh their experience with some of
these psychiatric
medications okay
thanks thank you very much thank you
chair we'll call in Sabrina Dunlap from
Bill thank you chairman hunt and members
of the committee my name is Sabrina
Dunlap I'm director of government
relations for anthm we are opposed to SB
um and I I not noted uh I heard it was
mentioned by the sponsor that Anthem
does 100% at point of sale and that did
not come up during the Senate hearing
and I just want to note that I was
actually here during the Senate hearing
because you were discussing I believe HB
1081 one of the ambulance bills um so we
were in fact opposed to this bill in the
Senate and we remain opposed to this
bill and I think the key issue is that
this bill interferes with how carrier
and pbms make decisions that best serve
their members with respect to point of
sale
rebates um you know different car
carriers take different approaches to
the amount of rebates to give at the
point of sale but that simply reflects
the diversity of our members and
approaches that we take in doing what is
best for them in terms of access to
medication and lowering
costs by forcing all carriers to give at
least 50% of rebates at the point of
sale s sp555 takes away the flexibility
to do what is best for our members and
it does nothing to address the high cost
of
drugs the price of drugs are set by the
drug companies so if we want to tackle
the high cost of drugs this bill does
not do
that um so I think I will I will wrap up
there and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you so if I understand
your testimony correctly you're saying
is that uh we should pass enabling
legislation to allow a pharmaceutical
comp insurance company to choose what it
wants to do with those rebat Ates I
believe that's the current state so I
think um our current state of affairs
gives carriers the choice to do what we
think is best right so you might think
that some year that by advertising that
you do rebates that you might actually
get more customers you would use it as a
marketing
tool I don't know how to respond to that
but I appreciate
that okay thank you representative belli
thank you quick question so um can you
give us maybe some insight if you know
as to why Anthem decided to you know do
the 100% rebate what factors maybe went
into that decision thank you that is a
very good question um I am happy to chat
more I don't want to misstate anything
it goes above and beyond my
understanding of math and actuary I will
say a lot of a lot of thought and um
different factors went into it I'm sure
and I I do believe it has not always
been 100% um and so the the simple
answer is it's a business decision
obviously we think that's best for our
members at this
moment representative buros thanks for
taking my question this may be um and I
don't know if you can answer this but
what do you think would be a better
route to take rather than this bill to
for to help somebody for example taking
Humera who's just got these outrageous
costs and they they can't do it what
would be a better
solution thank you for that question um
I think it's a great question I I think
I'll keep it simple and say I think the
fundamental problem is the high cost of
these specialty drugs um and I know that
is a complex system and so it's not just
you know pulling one thread or another
everything is sort of woven together so
it's not necessarily that simple but I
do think at the end of the day that's
what we're all grappling with is the
high cost of specialty drugs and those
prices are set by the drug companies
representative
mcade oh thank you Mr
chairman would you say that current
keeping the current system would
potentially allow a more competitive
Marketplace than what would be dictated
in
555 thank you for the question I think
what we currently have is a um system
that allows carriers the flexibility to
do what they think is best
so yeah well would you say would be more
competitive and could in fact lead to
more uh price
breaks I I don't know that I don't know
sorry thank you very much thank you
chair will call on Andy
good morning and thank you for letting
me uh testify and support of Senate Bill
555 my name is Andy low I'm the
executive director of the New England
rural Health
Association we are the rural Health
Association for all six of the new New
England states we're the only Regional
Health Association recognized by the
national rural Health Association we
have over 450 members uh we repres
present critical access hospitals rural
health clinics rural
fqhcs Human Services mental health
providers oral health providers Etc
around New England work with with
leadership uh for all of those
organizations uh I'll make this really
brief uh and summarize what was in my
testimony we know through the national
rural Health Association the CDC the
federal office of rural Health policy
and others that rural people are older
sicker and poorer than their Urban
counterparts there is a higher ratio of
co-occurring chronic illness among rural
residents than among the the more
urbanized population so what I'm here to
do is to ask you to think
about this smaller group of people who
could left be left out of the equation
when large numbers of people are used in
a formula to calculate uh certain kinds
of uh
policies please just keep in mind that
our rural residents are in fact uh with
a higher uh volume of a higher
percentage of chronic co-occurring
conditions which uh are costly to treat
they're costly for the people themselves
let's keep in mind that please that
these people are going to rely on
methods of reducing their out-of-pocket
costs for their
medications it's critical for them we
know that the downstream effects of
people skimping on their medication not
taking their medication is going to
result in an overall cost of Health Care
to the entire system we know it's going
to result in more ed visits more
hospitalizations more
rehospitalizations so I'm asking you to
think about those population our rural
populations around who uh may be
somewhat underrepresented these days
I'll leave it there and thank you and
take any
questions representative M thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mr low for coming in
tonight um do you do you think that in
the rural communities that passing this
bill might help improve outcomes from
some of those chronic conditions that
cost us the most I do thank you so in
New Hampshire we can't we the premium
set by an insurance company is flat all
the way to the state regardless of your
rural or not
rural so the only the only way I could
say that yes if someone wants to pay a
lower co-pay is to choose a higher you
know a lower deductible
plan because the premium is set is flat
to the whole state it doesn't matter
whether you're rural or not
I'll I'm accepting what you say that I
didn't know I don't see that there's a
question there I don't have any response
I'm merely pointing out that our
patients uh are in need of some kind of
re thank you um my question is you
represent New England rural Health
Association yes the New England rural
Health Association do uh does the
association deal with the natural paths
or alternative medicines
because what I've seen in my lifetime so
many people that take so many drugs that
are unnecessary One Drug to replace the
other drug for counteracting that do you
deal with any alternative you know um
positions I I'm sure that we have some
members who are in that organization
it's not probably a majority it's not
even close to a majority we probably
have some I I can't comment on that
group in particular okay thanks thank
you very much thank you uh chair we'll
call in Peter bragon from Harvard
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record Peter bragon
representing Harvard Pilgrim Healthcare
the states uh not for-profit health
insurance plan serving about 50,000 of
our state's residents our friends and
neighbors uh with their health insurance
needs um here in opposition to the bill
as the as noted by the chair I will
start though by uh there are a number of
areas where I agree with Senator avart
uh certainly Harvard pkam Healthcare uh
supports the initiative to make the
reporting more transparent section one
of the bill which is um lines 1 through
21 on the first page uh a few years ago
we passed a law that said or you I guess
you passed a law to um require uh some
attestation by the insurance companies
that they are passing the rebate values
on to members through the premiums and
but there was no details and so what the
department is receiving is information
that's not really helpful so section one
of the bill actually calls for more data
to be brought so then people can look
and see okay does this benefit we
believe um improving the transparency in
the reporting would demonstrate how
using pharmaceutical rebates to lower
premiums benefits our policy holders so
I agree with Senator avard on that I
also agree with Senator avart that drugs
are expensive I I think nobody disagrees
with that um unfortunately I don't think
this bill deals with and will address
the situations he brought up one of the
people he talked about was a veteran uh
this doesn't apply to tr care uh a
federal health insurance program for
veterans another one was retired this
doesn't affect uh Medicaid Medicare uh
Social Security people on retirement um
and so that's something we see a lot of
time is people using anecdotes that
don't really apply so I agree though
with rard that drugs are expensive and
as a previous speaker said we don't set
the drug prices the drug companies set
the drug prices so if the problems the
drug prices are too expensive then um
the problem is with the drunk companies
themselves and the third thing I agree
with Senator avart on is what he said
about West Virginia he said the 2023
rate filings show the same increases in
rates in West Virginia as other states
and that's very true unfortunately the
law requiring the rebates to go back to
the uh members that point of sale uh
came in in 2022 and I passed along out
to you um an analysis of West Virginia
from acas signups that shows right in
the middle there in the yellow column
12.83% increase in insurance premiums in
the individual Market in 2022 the law
was passed in 21 insurance companies
factored it into their rates for 2022 a
12% increase oh by the way New
Hampshire's increase at the time
depending on how you count it was
between 1 and 3%
uh I will agree with Senator avar that
since then it's been the increases have
been the same because that first year of
133%
so we believe that and I think the data
shows that uh the passage of a bill like
Senate Bill 555 will certainly increase
costs you know we have very few tools
available to help decrease insurance
premiums everything else is pushing
premiums up we have very few tools that
help us reduce premiums pharmaceutical
rebates are one of those very small
number of tools that we have and we
believe that Senator Bill 555 erodes the
usefulness of that tool um certainly
remitting the rebates at the point of
sale will benefit some people uh as was
said about 3% of drugs so let's just
assume for a second 3% of individuals
may benefit from that but it will
significantly raise the cost of premiums
or cost share for for everybody else and
that's not just an issue of oh no I have
to pay more money uh I pay I don't know
close to $600 a month um so I'd have to
pay more it's not really that it's what
happens and I've talked about this
before on the insurance premiums on the
insurance cost sharing when you squeeze
one out the balloon right if you take
the cost away somewhere else the
insurance fery is not going to show up
and take that away that has to be
recovered somewhere else it's going to
be either higher premiums or increased
cost shares deductible co-pays which
will have the effect of people no longer
getting insurance or getting insurance
policies that they themselves end up in
the situation where they can't afford to
pay for the drugs or the doctor's visits
or everything else so it's not just the
pure dollar issue it's what it does to
people and causes more people or
companies a company with 50 individuals
um you know multiply all these Effects
by 50 and so they're going to reduce
what they have and so our goal is to see
as many people as possible have health
insurance especially in the the small
group Market which we see uh as as
eroding over time how significant would
those increases to Consumers be while we
saw in uh West Virginia certainly it was
133% um currently the and by the way a
number of uh insurance carriers in New
Hampshire do this differently so Harvard
Pilgrim uh takes all the rebates we
receive and apply that to premiums other
companies as we discussed Anthem uh
sometimes uh reduces premiums by those
rebates other times they return the
rebates to the point of at the point of
sale um for us uh the value of the
rebates uh we currently use reduced the
premiums by about 7% the value of the
rebates is about 7% of the premiums um
it's logical to assume that a bill that
requires 50% of the rebates to go back
to the consumer at the point of sale
that's probably roughly a 3 and a half%
if our total value is 7% half of that is
3 and a half% that remaining 3 and a
half% has to go somewhere and like I
said it's not the insurance F I don't
know enough about Harvard pilgrims rates
I know my rate like I said about 600
bucks a month so three and a half that's
another 20 bucks a month um for this
member per month so it's a significant
increase uh in the insurance rates that
people have to pay in addition to the
the effect on the premiums that way
there's going to be administrative cost
uh we don't own our own PBM one of the
questions was why does Anthem do it this
way and I don't know why Anthem does it
that way Sabrina doesn't know either but
there's a lot of factors involved and I
don't expect that she would and I
hopefully no one ask me why Harvard does
it the way they do it uh but I do know
this that uh Harvard plgrm Healthcare is
a regional not for-profit health
insurance company uh the others in this
market are national for-profit health
insurance companies uh who own their own
pbms they're big enough they're
profitable enough they can own the PBM
you get a ton of cost savings when you
PBM and you get to charge People Like Us
uh a percentage of the fees in order to
do the work for you so in addition to
the the money that's going to go back to
the consumer at the point of sale that's
going to affect the premiums uh there's
an administrative cost that we have to
pay for somebody else to do all this
work to get the point of sale to work
and then finally we have to build a
cushion in there because there's a line
in the bill and I don't know what line
it is I'll look while I'm talking
$10,000 there it is on page two line 36
a fine not to exceed what un fortunately
it's not to exceed that makes me feel
better $10,000 per violation so if we
make an error with our point and as was
mentioned earlier these are estimates we
don't know until halfway through the
next year what those rebates were we
have an estimate of what they're going
to be based on our contracts but a lot
of it is based on volume we don't know
what those rebates are going to be if we
give the wrong rebate to somebody it's
$10,000 it's $10,000 per violation so
we're going to make a big cushion on
what we give back to the um the person
at the point of sale in order just to
cover our ass if you pardon the
expression uh to make sure I know I know
I'm sure you YouTube Remember YouTube
It's the former it's the former Center I
me had to had to throw that um so
there's a to compensate for the fees we
have to add more money to that so
there's a significant increase to the
cost both in terms of the money taken
away from the rebate pool that we use to
reduce premiums the administrative cost
and then this extra cushion that we have
in in addition to that um again I
pointed out it's been pointed out some
carriers already do this Anthem already
does it sometimes uh we don't I
mentioned uh you know they can own their
own pbms they're uh not non-for-profit
they're National so there's a lot of a
lot of things basically what this bill
does is it favors National for-profit
Insurance companies at the expense of
regional not for-profit health care
companies we believe it should be a free
market let the companies decide what
they're going to do let the companies
decide have some plans that do it this
way and some that do it that way let
some compan do it one way let others do
it another way and let the market sift
out what works out the best um I'll
point out that has already been pointed
out that the original bill um apparently
included the state health insurance plan
for employees as well as Medicaid and
based on testimony at the Senate hearing
oh no that will cost the state too much
money for those who say this won't cost
the state any money why did they
exclude self-insured plans like the
state's plan and Medicaid because it's
going to cost a lot of money
and then finally it's just the
philosophy of insurance right we
estimate what our costs are going to be
each year and we build our premiums
based on that and we by spreading those
costs across the entire base of our
clients and our members but in the same
way we should be able to do that with
our revenues as well we we spread our
costs across all the members we spread
revenues across all our members and that
results in lower premiums for everybody
so those are my main points I appreciate
questions thank you very much thank you
word good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is Heidi croll I
represent uh ahip America's health
insurance plans and I work at Gallagher
Calahan and gartrell um we are opposed
to S
sp555 um we object to the proposed
mandate in section two of the bill that
would require at least 50% of the drug
um manufacturers rebates to be used uh
to lower the patients out-of pocket cost
at the point of sale um as you've heard
this only would apply in the fully
insured Market um it would not apply to
Medicaid Medicare the VA Tri care um
self-funded obviously not the state
employee plan um and we do also object
to the provision in section two that
would increase um the fines on carriers
for each violation from
$2,500 um which is a standard um
throughout the New Hampshire's um health
insurance laws um so a four-fold
increase up to
$110,000 um that seems excessive and
unnecessary um the insurance department
already has the statutory Authority and
the tools should it need to take
enforcement action against a carrier um
including um suspending or re even
revoking a carrier's license to do
business in New Hampshire
um uh similarly to the comments that um
uh Peter bragon made um we would I would
note that carriers don't object to the
enhanced reporting requirements um to
the insurance department those um
changes were proposed by the department
and they are changes we are happy to
live with um then I would also note that
carriers do not object to the current
law which says that carriers must use
the drug manufacturers rebates um to
either lower um the premiums uh at the
point of sale um or some combination
thereof um so taking a step back as
you've heard um Health in from some of
the other speakers uh health insurance
carriers um in our opinion are Americans
bargaining power um negotiating lower
cost of care and lower drug prices for
plan enroles and that includes
negotiating um discounts off the list
price of drugs and being able to
maximize the impact of those discounts
um for all plan enroles by passing those
savings through as reductions in
premiums and other improvements um to
benefits um and I would say that I think
carriers are getting 100% of the rebates
from the pbms um I think those contracts
now are are are clear in terms of what's
coming through um as you've also heard
um you know these rebates um are just on
a select um brand named drugs that have
competition um so if there's no
competition um or if it's a generic
um there's uh um no rebate and the
reason that the manufacturers um are
willing to offer these discounts is so
their drugs can get um better placement
on the carrier's formularies and be
prescribed to more patients um and being
placed on the form getting better
placement on the formulary um means
being on Lower tiers and lower tiers are
um going to skip over some of this
because I don't want to repeat what
other people have said
[Music]
um most insurers in New Hampshire um are
using the rebates to help lower premiums
and lower cost sharing for all enroles
in fully insured plans and as you know s
sp555 would mandate that they would have
to divert 50% of the rebates um away
from reducing premiums um and over to um
the point of
sale and as you've heard um from Harvard
Pilgrim you know for carriers that are
currently using rebates to reduce
premiums this bill will increase um the
premiums for members that's just plain
and simple when you redirect money away
from one pot toward another pot um
premiums will have to go up um and as
you've heard you know Anthem is one
carrier that is um you know has recently
chosen to apply the rebate at the point
of sale um and you know certain folks
have pointed to this as a reason why the
Mandate in 555 should apply to all
carriers um and I find that um argument
a little bit puzzling in and our current
law promotes consumer choice where the
carriers have the opportunity in the
fully insured Marketplace to
differentiate themselves from one
another and offer different products
that apply the rebates in different ways
um the individual or the employer
whoever is purchasing the insurance plan
gets to choose whether they want a plan
that uses the rebates to lower premiums
or whether they want a plan that applies
the rebates a point of sale and so the
fact is that the New Hampshire
Marketplace is functioning just as the
current law intended um consumers want
and frankly deserve this Choice a
national survey that came out in October
of last year found that 91% of employers
say it is important to have flexibility
in choice in how their organization uses
rebate dollars our current law allows
for that choice and our current
Marketplace is offering that choice um s
sp555 would have the government
intervene in the this Market um and take
away that choice for New Hampshire
consumers uh ahip does not support that
um and I think you have correspondents
from the Bia the business and industry
Association that indicates that they
don't support that either um I also want
to address the question of how patients
who use rebated drugs benefit when
carriers are using the rebates to lower
premiums and approve the benefit
designed for all of the enroles um so
first these patients benefit from lower
co-pays or lower co- Insurance um
because the rebated drug is on a lower
tier um and in some cases that means
that could mean that the tier actually
brought them down from a co- Insurance
to a co-pay which is um also mean
savings for the patient um secondly um
they would benefit just like everybody
else would from lower premiums um and a
third point which hasn't been mentioned
here today is that um patients will see
lower um cost sharing overall when rebat
rebates are applied to premiums due to
Actuarial value requirements so
Actuarial value of plan is based on net
expenses after rebates so cost sharing
across all medical and all drug benefits
is reduced by rebates so it's not just
um the premiums that are lower but the
total cost sharing um is lower as
well
um you've been pointed to the um New
Hampshire Insurance Department's annual
report um uh page uh slide 49 um again
as you've heard um the uh rebates in
2022 lowered the per member per month
cost of prescription drug expenses by
$38 down from 100
$147 per member per month down to 109
that is a 26% reduction um and as you've
heard also at the bottom of slide 49 it
talks about how the total rebate dollars
um uh in 2022 was 90 million and so
we're talking about diverting
redirecting as much as 45 Mill million
half of that um away from premium
reductions um we've also talked about
the fiscal note on S sp555 as introduced
um and how the um Department of
administrative Services estimated that
this bill would have cost them $2
million Medicaid director estimated that
it would have cost them at least $30
million um and so as you've heard the
Senate was quick to carve out Medicaid
and the state employee plan but for
reasons I cannot explain was still happy
to impose this mandate on um businesses
New Hampshire's employers and the
individuals in the fully insured Market
um if this is a good policy um it's not
clear to me why the state would um be so
quick to exempt itself um except that
there's the actual there's the cost
associated with it um there's other cost
um when the Trump Administration adopted
a similar point of sale rebate mandate
in the Medicare part D program cms's own
actuaries estimated that it would
increase premiums by 25% it would have
cost taxpayers between 202 and 400
billion dollar um and would have led to$
137 billion windfall for pharmaceutical
manufacturers um Congress has
continuously disallowed this Federal
effect um I'll close and would be happy
to answer questions in closing nothing
in s sp555 addresses the root cause of
high drug cost for consumers which is
high list prices set by manufacturers
and their um and their profit driven
motives
um a a recent AARP report um looked at
2117 drugs that were on the market from
2006 to 2020 for these drugs the
cumulative price increase inre over that
time was nearly
280% while the increase in general
inflation over that same period was only
32%
um when considering a bill like s sp555
please consider New Hampshire's
individuals and small employers who are
doing their best to keep up with Rising
healthc care cost and Rising drug prices
in the form of higher premiums and
higher cost sharing um those are the
people who would ultimately pay for this
proposed mandate um with numbers in you
know the tens of millions of dollars per
year ranged um so we support the new
reporting requirements um we would be
happy to live with the um current uh
questions representative Pell so um
thank you for allowing me the question
what what is you talked about the
formulary placement I'm not sure we
really talked about that a lot so is
that going to have a we allow this 50%
rebate what impact would it have um on
the formulary placement so that you know
will will these drugs remain at a point
where they're more expensive without the
rebate changing where they are uh placed
on the formulary
list it's a great question um
I think I want to get back to you on
that question I don't want to give you
the wrong answer
yeah represent M thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question since
your client ahip opposes sharing the
savings with the patients at the point
of sale any suggestions on how we can
improve outcomes and reduce those
prescriptions C prescription
costs how do you how do you suggest we
do it
yeah you know carriers have um a lot of
programs around um medication to you
know working with their pbms um to try
to ensure to really work with patients
um but I think at the end of the day
we're trying to make sure that we're and
and so the P those patients still would
get the benefits as I described they
would have the benefits of lower
premiums they would have the benefit of
overall lower cost sharing and they're
going to have the benefit of lower
co-pays and lower co- Insurance um but
again at the end of the day um if drug
manufacturers really want to make their
drugs more affordable for patients um
then the solution is very easy they
should lower their drug prices for
everyone um so we would put the question
to
them and thank you very much for your
testimony and with that we'll close the
public hearing on Senate Bill
555 and start 55 seven as quickly as
possible do we have do we have a system
to let Senator Apprentice know we're
ready
is I see another card heading its way
okay when we get started uh sorry about
the delay Senator not a problem thank
you very much and uh I I appreciate the
opportunity once again to be before our
house Commerce and consumer affairs
committee to introduce legislation this
is Senate Bill 557 this prohibits
discriminatory actions against entities
that are participating in the 340b drug
pricing program um and so starting off
with just talking a little bit about the
340b program and I know I have one maybe
two folks here with me that um have
direct experience with this in New
Hampshire and can talk why putting these
Protections in place is important but
according to the americ American
Hospital Association for more than 30
years the 340b drug pricing program has
provided financial help to hospitals
serving vulnerable communities to manage
Rising prescription drug costs so
section 340b of the Public Health
Service act requires pharmaceutical
manufacturers participating in Medicaid
to sell outpatient drugs at discounted
prices to Health Care organizations that
care for many uninsured and lowincome
patients these organizations include
Federal grantee organizations such as
certain types of hospitals our critical
access hospitals our federally qualified
rural Health Centers sole Community
Hospitals rural referral centers really
here in New Hampshire we're talking most
about critical access hospitals and the
federally qualified Health Centers but
they serve U this disproportionate share
of low income and IND you know or IND
IND oh I know I'm so sorry I uh had a
late flight and have not had enough
coffee so please excuse me um Indigent
populations um so this program allows
340b hospitals to stretch their limited
Federal resources to reduce the price of
Pharmaceuticals for patients and expand
services to the patients and communities
that they serve hospitals under 340b the
savings that can provide for other
programs that also serve the uninsured
or Indigent population um in terms of
free
vaccines care services in mental health
clinics and Implement medication
management and community health programs
so the money they save by participating
in 340b they can transfer ref to other
effort efforts that support this
particular population so according to
hersa our health sources Health
Resources and services ad Administration
which is the federal entity uh which is
responsible for administering the 340b
program enrolled hospitals and other
covered entities can achieve an average
savings of 25 to 50% in pharmaceutical
purchases despite significant oversight
from hersa this program's proven record
of decreasing governmental spending and
expanding access to Patient Care um some
want to limit that by scaling this back
getting in the middle of it or
drastically reducing the benefits that
eligible hospitals and their patients
receive from the program so that is why
a number of states uh one of the states
I was recently reading about was Nevada
have adopted laws that don't allow for
any discriminatory practices to get in
the middle of this particular program so
I am as always happy to take questions
that you have if I don't have the the
answer I can either get it for you or
have somebody behind me who has more
experience actually administering this
program speak to you and um I was just
saying to someone that I feel like I'm
here more than I'm at Health and Human
Services so this is a good year all
right thank yes we do things a little
differently on the Senate you just from
the Senate no no I'm talking about like
I've been before your committee lately
three times in the last two weeks it's
all good so so um who's doing the
Discrimination who I mean what what a
problem we solving here who so one of
one of the um you know and respectfully
um thank you for the question chair hunt
U Pharmacy there's you know Pharmacy
benefit managers who can be in the
middle of the pharmaceutical companies
um I was pharmaceutical companies
manufacturers um and insurers there's
they can get in the middle of this um
and actually Implement a policy that
might say limit where somebody can
actually access these particular
medications so do you know if that's
true here in New Hampshire that some
insurance company or some people do not
know that if it's true but we're trying
to prevent it from happening based on
what's happening in other states and I
would look to um I know that this has
happened in other states and that's why
states are adopting this this is a
proactive measure um and folks from um
Dart withth Health that are here that
actually run a program can speak more
specifically here so okay right friends
to my left thank you very
much I think we're all set thank you
it's I do have to I'm going to return to
um a Committee hearing that I'm in but
you know how to find me if you have any
questions thanks so much okay so Matt
yeah former member of the House comerce
chka thank you Mr chairman uh for the
record Matthew Hood um representing
Dartmouth health I'm here with Kristen
chupka who manages the 340b program for
Dartmouth health
we will try to help you catch up some of
your time from your last hearing uh and
be brief which is just to say that
Dartmouth health does have members
critical access hospitals uh
disproportionate share hospitals Etc
under the in the Dartmouth Health team
that benefit from the three 40b patients
for its patients and then I will hand
the microphone over to Kristen to talk
about the program and the
benefits thank you Mr chair members of
the committee I'm very grateful for the
opportunity to speak in support of this
anti-discriminatory bill on the 340b
program as Matthew mentioned I am the
director of the 340b program for the
Dartmouth Health System um but most
importantly I'm a pharmacist I've been a
pharmacist for 20 years and this program
that I've been involved in um not only
at Dartmouth but at another Health
System um since 2013 has been one of the
most rewarding experiences in my entire
career um and that's why I'm here today
to speak about why it's so important and
and get your support
um as you are probably aware the 340b
program is a federal program designed to
stretch scarce Federal resources as far
as possible reaching more eligible
patients and to provide more
comprehensive
services so under this program drug
manufacturers offer their products to
covered entities at a discounted price
if they wish to have their products
reimburse by Medicare and Medicaid and
so that's really at the heart right um
and so as consumers of healthc care I
imagine that you go to your local
pharmacy you pick up your
prescriptions um at Dartmouth health and
other 34b programs across the state of
New Hampshire um they enter in with
contracts with these local pharmacies to
help procure medications through this
program with the involvement of the
covered entity so that these medications
can get in patients hands this
contractual Arrangement allows patients
to pick up their prescriptions at these
local pharmacies so that the eligible
entity May capture
savings and these savings are not
additional right the the number of
prescriptions a covered entity can write
is finite and so these contract
relationships allow us to capture where
our patients are being
served manufacturers started to prohibit
the use of contract pharmacies for 340b
discounts in 2020 it is rapidly and
aggressively gotten very worse for us to
be able to capture those savings due to
um almost 30 manufacturers now with
different policies and they continue be
to become uh less inclusive as the years
have gone
on patients do have the right to choose
where they receive their medical care
and so where we're able to really
benefit the 340b program is through our
retail specialty at mail order
pharmacies we can't solely just use that
though because of our rural environment
and expect a patient to drive to to our
Pharmacy when they may be already coming
to our services that are an hour or two
hours away so that's why we want to
embark on these contracts with our local
pharmacies across the state um some
patients do opt for mail order if the
distance is too great um and then
furthermore they may be required by the
PBM to use mail order pharmacies um
across the US and in Arizona and even in
California Dartmouth Health has patients
getting care in Pharmaceuticals shipped
to New Hampshire from all the way across
the country some of these Pharma
manufacturers are stating we can't
embark on contract phes out of a 40 m
radius of our covered entity and in our
rural environment that's just not
feasible so there is a need to continue
to maintain contract pharmacies to
enable our covered entity to capture
those savings uh for those patients who
are mandated to choose other services or
who have the right to choose where they
want to go within our great state so we
talk about 340b savings and so I wanted
to share what Dartmouth health does
beyond charity care um with the use of
the 340b savings that we're able to to
to realize so I did mention that we have
our our system of retail pharmacies and
so patients who are underinsured or
discharged may get re admitted due to
the costs of these newer drug therapies
this shouldn't be news to anyone in this
room many patients who are insured have
those large deductibles and can't afford
those medications um and so they return
to the hospital for complications due
and not being able to afford those
therapies our pharmacies offer a full
medication discount list um and this
does include discounted medications to
all so my father from the state of New
York if he was admitted he can go into
that pharmacy and get that medication at
that lower discounted rate so it's not
just for patients that are members or uh
patients of our of our health
system I think that's really the most
important point of how we use that at
our own
pharmacies another thing that we do with
the 340b savings is we support the
treatment of over 200 hemophilia and
other bleeding disorder patients with
life-saving and critical therapies um
benefits there include nurse management
care coordination Community Based
education and support for Youth and
Adolescent with self-management skills
and mental health support with this
disease um patients are living longer
and longer with hemophilia um and so the
better they can treat themselves the
better they'll be we also support
treatment of over a thousand patients
living with HIV and we are the only Ryan
White grantee holder in the state of New
Hampshire benefits including in that
Ryan White group are uh multiple Care
Service locations throughout the state
um with continued expansion of prep
support we have a community health
worker participating in the care of
patients suffering from drug addiction
and emergency funding for patients under
the grant for needed medical services
and
supplies we have developed and funded
the Dartmouth Cancer Center food bank
with 340b savings we also Sur uh support
local businesses with grants direct to
support housing growth for those who are
homeless adults with developmental
disabilities and access to transitional
homes we operate the Mary hitchock
Memorial Hospital addiction treatment
program for those with opioid use
disorder and we are constantly opening
new service lines um especially notable
is an Express Care Clinic at New London
Hospital that um was filling a gap in
that community
and so just to close contract Pharmacy
is incredibly vital and we need to
maintain the hersa uh allowance of
letting us have those relationships with
whatever pharmacies need to be able to
care for our patients um and our system
pharmacies are just not able to care for
them all and so by Contracting where our
patients are are going um or located
where they live we can bring that
savings back and continue to fund
initiatives as mentioned um you know
like the medication discount list the
opioid treatment mental health all the
things that are are Forefront in our
minds and we want to continue to support
Community initiatives in the state of
New
Hampshire and welcome any questions
thank you very much uh representative
Herbert is there um any anybody
uh any entity or political entity uh the
manufacturers who exited this uh program
I'm assuming and I I'm pretty sure uh a
lot of their patents uh were funded by
uh the federal government what is your
exactly your question has anybody
thought of uh bringing litigation and to
these people that are leaving the
system thank you for the question
representative there is litigation on
both the federal and state levels
pertaining to the 34b program 25 states
have initiated legislation on the state
level to navigate
the the contract Pharmacy space five of
which have um enacted legislation to
date thank you great thank you very
much oh do we have a representative
spear you went very
quickly and even though I'm from New
York I couldn't keep up
ior um that's probably why I talk so
quickly uh you said uh farma has been uh
instrumental in trying to shut these
programs down can you elaborate on that
a little bit yes so in 2020 Eli Lily um
started with the Restriction um by uh
saying that covered entities couldn't
access the 340b drug pricing uh point on
their drug Calis from that point um
other manufacturers jumped in and said
contract Pharmacy uh price points would
not be available to covered entities um
mostly this is due to I think
some language in the action ual statute
that they are leveraging to use this as
um a way to not allow uh to provide that
340b price point um there's a long
pathway of the restrictions and how they
have become tighter um but basically
it's gone from One Drug to the scope of
drugs to um no contract pharmacies then
they asked us to report data uh we did
report data and as soon as we did that
after a year um a good hunk of them I
would say about nine or 10 of those
manufacturers decided that uh we didn't
need to submit data anymore and that
they were not going to extend pricing
anymore um so it's just progressively
gotten worse since
2020 so that that's the kind of
interference that you want this bill to
try and fix correct thank you Mr
chairman may I just add very briefly for
the committee this is a fairly
narrow um response to the scope of
issues that covered entities and far pH
ceutical manufacturers and pbms are
navigating this purely pertains to the
contract uh
Pharmacy eligibility for the program
right but the reality it's a federal
program so technically it doesn't have
too much force of law but we want to
send the message that we do not want
them to continue to discriminate when it
comes to this Federal wonderful Federal
program that is a Marvel that Congress
ever passed it in the first place and um
yes and in New Hampshire we would want
to send that message and be clear about
what can and cannot be included exactly
okay seeing none thank you very
McCracken from AMS gag health and
support of the bill good morning or
afternoon
now you have to push the button on there
you go that
better thank you very much uh chairman
hunt and members of the house Commerce
and consumer affairs committee I'm going
to try and skip over a lot of things
because you've already heard them so I'm
going to just jump to a little bit a
little more practical application so I
work at amamos Health we federally
qualified Health Center we have about
16,000 active patients in the greater
Manchester area and we're a 340b covered
entity right so this impacts us in a big
way and we're able to do the same thing
that Dartmouth talked about about using
the savings from that program to benefit
our our patients and I'm going to tell
you a story about a a real patient right
so we have uh a individual who um lost
her U permanent employment took a
position as a consultant for a period of
time didn't have insurance and had
regular medications that she needed to
take she was a little more than the
federal poverty level so she didn't
qualify to get any covered benefits but
she need did regularly to take her
medication so she used our 340b program
to buy the medicines at a significantly
reduced cost that she never would have
been able to buy on her own so some of
the medications might cost $200 or $300
for a one month supply and if any of you
have um individuals in your home who are
aging and are taking medication
regularly you know how those costs can
add up but we're able to provide a
formulary for this individual and buy
these medications for them with a very
discounted price so we have a $4
formulary and a $12 formulary and that's
very affordable so there's really great
things that this program does but when
they try and limit where you can offer
this service and how many pharmacies can
cover this service for you makes it
exceedingly difficult to do the right
thing by the patients that you're trying
to serve so I am very much in support of
this um it's no cost to anybody in New
Hampshire um no cost to taxpayers the
discounts are provided by the
pharmaceutical companies themselves so
as she noted to you this has been under
attack since 2020 and I think one of my
colleagues from another federally
qualified Health Center is going to talk
to you about the real impact for us over
over the period of the time that this
has happened we've gone from a
significant level maybe $1 million down
to less than $500,000 in savings that's
part of how we support the care that we
provide to people who are Indigent so
this is a huge impact and who's going to
cover that who's going to close that Gap
taxpayers aren going to close that Gap
we need we need to take advantage of
something that was designed specifically
for this purpose to help the people that
are most in need and the
predatory um aspect of what was kicked
off by Eli Libby is having having a
really deleterious effect on a lot of
your safety net providers so we
sincerely hope that you'll consider um
supporting this and helping us do what
we can to protect this program and the
people that it serves thank
you thank you very much got one card
left uh Ed Shin Shala
sh was very good from AMS Community
Health Services thank you I I want to
thank Chris as a colleague and um the
patient she speaks of are in a
Manchester area um and have uniquely
Urban challenges um I'm the CEO of AMC
Community Health Services in the North
Country we have 26 towns in our service
area there are 30,000 residents and we
see roughly one in three of our friends
family and neighbors to do that we've
strategically located five care delivery
SE sites from the north of Whitefield
down through through Littleton Franconia
come down 302 to Woodsville and then cut
across 25 uh to our Mount musaki Health
Center which has actually been a health
center since 1957 so we're proud to
continue that Heritage so when we think
about the restrictions we've had
economically it represents a 70 some per
reduction in the
savings um over in there's a chart that
I've given you you can track that uh
since 2017 most significantly as was
mentioned with Eli Lily with a
restriction in um the pharmacies we can
use and I think one of the things I've
enjoyed about New Hampshire is we try to
be regulator light and if I would like
to do business with representative hunt
um that's free market we can have a
conversation come to terms of what that
looks like depending on services and and
money's rendered so I I I take exception
that um someone from not in New
Hampshire is infringed on my ability to
care for our patients and and and have
free trade amongst the pharmacies to
which I would like to do business with
when we look at the
access um which one Pharmacy am I going
to pick for my
patients if I pick the Walmarts there's
one in Littleton there's one in
Woodsville there's one in Plymouth which
patients do I tell do I tell Whitefield
well if you want meds you got to go to
Plymouth do I tell Warren you have to go
to to Littleton so it's created an
access issue um independent of the
economics and when we think about taking
our
medications uh that we look at taking
our blood pressure medications those are
important to prevent stroke and to
prevent heart attacks and if we start
heading down a stroke and heart attack
Road um it's not a good experience the
uh qu outcomes are not guaranteed in we
an emergency department
uh $750 to $1,500 a hospital day is
$2,000 ICU is $10,000 and our Primary
Care is $200 and uh blood pressure
medications are pretty affordable and
especially with our sliding fee scale
that we fund with a 340b they're even
more affordable so there there's a
significant Downstream economic impact
bad experience can't guarantee you're
going to survive this which is tragic
and it's not inexpensive and it was
completely avoidable as long as people
from out of state don't tell us how to
do business in New Hampshire um so when
we look at our savings in addition to
the the 340b investment into affordable
medications the Health Care system is
complex anybody who's I work in it and I
I still am challenged to sit down and
figure out when I'm a patient how to do
it so we have patient Navigators that
help people address food security
Transportation so they can get the
appointments sit down and sort through
the Myriad of insurance possibilities so
they can make smart Intelligent
Decisions and then we also put it into
oral health and currently we collaborate
with Midstate uh we provide the physical
plant they provide the staff uh and
we've matched our voucher to the $1,500
State Medicaid uh to make it easy so uh
Midstate has a sliding fee scale for
dental we have a voucher and New
Hampshire Medicaid so I think we've done
a nice job collectively wrapping around
people uh to make sure they have good
dentition uh so more than willing to
field any questions on this but just
ability to increase access to patients
going back to be able to choose which
pharmacies we want to do business with
um and it's really based we follow the
patient you know if a patient doesn't go
there we don't contract with them so I I
thank you for your time um and your
interest in this area we try to keep
your friends family and neighbors um as
healthy as we can thank you
thank you for your service rep represent
believe you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um what the question
do
you do you deal with the pbms we do um
and then in the in the testimony I
believe that I documented we had an
in-house
Pharmacy and due to what I would
consider I'll take the ad due to the
contract we were provided because we
were
340b uh covered entity we got a contract
different than if we had not been and
what that means is we're an open
pharmacy so if you're our
patient we behave within 340b if we not
we still get you your medication but we
have to purchase it at 80% of average
wholesale
price the contract was taking a piece of
the savings so we lost savings on our
patient but they took so much savings
that if you're not our patient we
actually lost money we couldn't even
break even on that uh I was taught that
you can re-engineer and not hurt
people's lives so I worked with
Littleton Regional Hospital when we
closed our Pharmacy they opened a retail
and they have a wonderful meds to beds
program if your hospital doesn't please
have them contact me you leave with your
medications uh so when I had my hip done
I left with a blood thinner and an
antibiotic and I went home with a bag of
ice uh my wife didn't have to leave me
in the parking lot or God forbid leave
me home alone which is never a good idea
idea um so that that that was very
frustrating we now have a pharmacy on
site it's Genoa it's a strategic partner
um so I didn't give up patients have
access it's just not my Pharmacy um but
that
was predatory
Contracting um very frustrating thank
you see no more questions we thank you
very much for your testimony thank you
and having no more cars I will close the
public hearing on Senate Bill 557 and
1:5
e
okay we'll open up the public hearing on
set of Bill one
96 and I assume we have a pink card oh
you do not I will get you a pink card
okay no no no don't do it now don't do
it now no please do not do
it on my way out okay all right good
afternoon oh yeah this bill's dead
right indeed it is actually so let me
introduce this bill this is Senate Bill
196 and um this bill was brought forward
um because there were some issues
initially regarding the interpretation
of Statute by the department of
insurance as it applies to ride share
companies like uber and Lyft um however
the companies and the department have
agreed on an interpretation of Statute
and at this point the bill is no longer
necessary therefore I ask the committee
for an itl vote Perfect all right thank
thank you Mr chair committee members
you're on a roll you'll do that again
I'll see you in an hour and a half thank
[Laughter]
you
okay so James you're you're here for the
next one
too you're all set that one
right okay there I see you in general
You're All Hiding back in the corner
right
okay did
you all right uh and yes so I open the
hearing and I close the public hearing
on Senate Bill 196 at 120 boy we're
now
e
senor Fon thank you for having me folks
happy be in front of
you good afternoon Mr chair members of
the committee for the record I am
Senator Donovan Fenton I represent
district 10 and I'll be very brief I'm
here before you today to introduce
Senate Bill 325 which would establish a
committee to study the issue of
insurance appraiser
licensing the reason for this bill is
that we are seeing a disconnect between
the damage appraisal of vehicles and
what is actually going to cost to fix
the car Auto damage cost analysis has
been has become highly skilled and
because because cars are for far more
complicated now the cars also have to be
rebuilt to spec and meet manufacturer
guidelines you don't want your car to be
rebuilt missing things in some cases we
are seeing underpayment of the actual
loss what that means is the AO Body Shop
does the work to make the car new but
the payment for the damage said um you
don't need to adhere to certain
specifications so who is right question
one way to fix this is to look at
license insurance appraisers this way
the appraisers are not potentially
influenced by who the insurance are who
hire them and this is a study committee
I'm happy to take any more questions you
have we do have a question
representative buroughs thanks for
taking my question Senator why a
committee which a lot of us don't feel
go anywhere a lot of times versus a
bill well studying committees are thank
you for the question study committees
are important um you know I think uh
it's a complex issue there's a lot of
stakeholders involved and I think we
want to hear everyone's um everyone's
side of things before you make this bill
um you know you're going to hear a lot
from the autobodies auto body shops are
small independent owned oftentimes
they're small family businesses
generational businesses and I think we
should do everything in our power to
help them um and this bill was written
um with the Department of Insurance you
know we wrote it together a lot of uh a
lot of uh parts of this and um you know
AO body work has changed drastically I'm
not sure if any of you have gotten you
know work done in your vehicle before
but now you use specialized tools and
equipment and software so it's a it's a
very intricate profession
now yeah so um I have to admit I was
reading this bill and I I I did not
realize it's about utob body because it
doesn't say Autobot so we have a
licensing
of insurance appraisers we have a
license for this are you asking if we
have it now yeah not though I not
independently not that's not what I
understand no oh so we have no lure of
appr independent appraisers correct and
then A and B is because this is kind of
open-ended and but you want it to be
only for
Autobody no I mean first of all Mr chair
thank you for the questions um not
necessarily only auto body that's the
impetus of the bill uh this is strictly
dealing with independent appraisers
damage independent so that means they're
not working for an insurance company
they are but they're not employed by the
insurance company think of it as like a
1099 that's the way I understand it okay
so they're they're hire hired by the the
insurance comp to the okay oh boy all
right well I I did th the study
committee I did not get that when I read
this s Comm but now I get it all right
any other questions from the committee
[Music]
melier would you
believe in November is it your mic on
thank you would you believe in November
I hit a deer with my
car oh dear and the initial appraiser
appraisal came in for like it was
$8,000 I got my car back eight weeks
later and the final bill was
$28,000 so a big big difference thank
you I I would believe we you know um
it's kind of right a passage if you hit
a deer in New Hampshire it seems like um
and and I will say this you know there's
no reason to be opposed to a study
committee to look at this disconnect you
know just like what you said the this
stuff is happening you just heard
testimony uh or question I should say
about you know uh the disconnect between
an appraisal what you know what someone
else says so I think uh looking a little
anybody
yes so what the way I'm understanding is
this have a study committee so and what
you're looking at is having independent
this wouldn't and the committee could
find that companies could have their own
appraisers this would just be an
independent appraiser correct I think
spear I'm not exactly sure who to
address this to how would this study
committee get started I mean is it
looking for volunteers I don't know how
they work oh okay yes we'll talk about
how a study committee work if you'd like
great ignorance is bliss yeah right you
want
her okay investig all right
representative pusc and then uh thank
you Mr chairman um Senator I have a
question relative to the makeup of the
committee uh I was wondering why the
insurance commissioner or the
commissioner's design was not on the
study committee thank you great question
um representative um you know if the
house feels so inclined to amend it to
add him that's a that's a great uh thing
to do I think um you know we all we all
love study committees especially during
the summer evidently not because you
only have one Senator well you know it's
uh if I could convince some colleagues I
would um and it's a very bipartisan bill
I will add that no you know um I've
talked with commissioner beton court on
this bill uh we wrote it together
essentially um so uh he is very aware of
it
um yeah if you want to if you want to
throw him on there feel free to
followups further question may inquire
uh as the fir as the first name member
uh would you be uh have any issues with
you being IED the fifth um no I'd be
happy to serve on it you know it's uh I
work a lot in my my daytime job with
auto body so I know the industry very
well thank you
absolutely yeah would you believe that I
had a Toyota that I bought from I I know
I would believe that sir and and don't
you know that that auto dealer who I
bought it from said um yeah mice eat eat
the cables of Toyotas all the time and
you should just call your insurance
company and have them pay for it well
you bu you buy a new car you get a mouse
with it you know that's what you do you
send them home with
it I have a quick question okay oh re
prelli yes thank you thank you for
taking my question I'm I'm just help me
understand why you think licensing
Insurance appraisers might help this
issue what is your thinking sure
appreciate the question representative
so you know we're looking at just
studying the issue because there's
clearly a disconnect you know I've heard
from a lot of auto body shops and
there's actually some auto body shops
behind me that you're going to hear from
as well um and I think they can describe
the issues and problems they're facing a
little better than I can because they
live this day-to- day after you know
they spend time with the insurance
companies these appraisers uh that's
part of their job because they're
valuing the damage on the vehicle how
much it cost to fix labor costs things
like that um so I think you know a way
and having these conversations with the
auto body shops and um individuals in
the insurance companies that you know
perhaps these individual uh appraisers
maybe there's a disconnect there and
maybe that's why we need licensing for
these individual uh appraisers I don't
know if that answered your question kind
of okay well there's always John Hunt's
rule of lure we create lur so that we
can take it away from you when you're
bad okay thank you very much thank you
all so much I got to zip back to my
committee so thank you we understand all
PR and welcome back to the house
Commerce
Committee um so I'm here right now as
consumer mainly
I've had numerous vehic be damaged over
uh the appraisers that the insurance
companies hires are not impartial turn
your mic on yeah turn your mic on and
and you push that button down below
right there and and can you state your
name please yep Steve P spin in
um over the years I've had numerous
claims insurance claims and U the
insurance Insurance appraisers come out
that the insurance companies hire and
they all tell me that they are writing
appraisals according to what their
insurance customers tell them to do
appraisers need to be disinterested
impartial and independent there is a New
Hampshire law already on the books it's
underneath the fraud
section
uh I have brought that to the attention
of the insurance department in New
Hampshire here uh they wrote me a letter
back in February 2nd of
2023 uh that they we have already what
they stated was we have already told you
we do not regulate Insurance appraisers
so I went to the uh Attorney General's
office for help they told me that they
do not interfere with the uh insurance
department that goes underneath the
insurance regulations I decided to take
it upon myself and Sue an insurance
appraiser
the judicial court and Keen told me it
all falls back to the Attorney General's
office so I went full circuit with this
whole damn thing
already
uh I have a car runnel business I
probably have half a dozen different
claims a year I have one outgoing right
now with
Progressive Progressive came out I think
they've up to six appraisals on my
vehicle this is one of their staff
appraisers uh they cannot name a shop
that is willing to repair my vehicle for
any of the insurance appraisal prices
but then again they're withholding the
money that's owed to me on my claim they
tell me that I have to get my car
repaired which my car I don't want it
repaired so I'm going to go trade it
probably to Fenton's family and uh get a
new
vehicle
uh I have a couple appraisals here for
my body shop business now go put my body
this independent appraiser says he
follows a code of ethics on his on their
website that he's going to be impartial
independent yada yada
yada he was hired by Vermont Mutual to
appraise a vehicle my my shop lot okay
he appraised it at 53 bucks an hour
straight across the board for
labor no calibrations no pre and post
scans no safety
nothing then my customer filed a claim
for the same accident conquered group
came up got involved same appraiser same
vehicle same damages he comes out writes
an
appraisal for quite a bit more money at
60 bucks an hour and 65 but then
includes for all the pre- and post scans
calibrations and whatnot right up front
why is this a apprisal the same vehicle
have two different appraisal two
different prices two different insurance
companies
involved what is going
on in the insurance department let's
just go on
daily if the insurance department did
their job we wouldn't be here
today got another appraisal here uh that
this was a fairly new Toyota 4Runner
1500 customer told me their truck is
over at the GM dealer I went over and
looked at it the uh last
week Geico will fight tooth and nailed
not to pay the shops but body labor
rates or the repair procedures that GM
requires
the GM dealer can just write a oneline
or Geico can put on their appraisal a
oneline estimate they'll pay 115 bucks
for
labor but when it comes to the body shop
labor 60
bucks what is funny is some of this
labor that they included in here from
the dealership my shop completed for the
dealership because the dealership
couldn't do it but since a dealership
build it
out the insurance company will included
on their apprais appraisal when it comes
won't the repair
procedures all the appraisers have
access to them if they don't have access
to the repair procedures from the
vehicle manufacturers then they
shouldn't be doing appraisals these cars
are computers rolling computers
they're got so much technology built
into them and the insurance appraisers
either a they're stupid
or they're just taken upon themselves
with or taking directions from their
insurance companies to
do to underwrite the value of the the uh
damages Insurance appraisers should be
appraising vehicles that is it they
should not be adjusting losses for the
insurance companies Insurance appraisers
uh apprais Vehicles according to
assistant commissioner n hand that's
what he told me on a a phone
conversation and adjusters adjust claims
what is happening nowadays is the
insurance customers of these independent
appraisers are being provided guidelines
uh pricing structures of how to uh value
these damaged
Vehicles so basically they adjust
adjusting the appraisals to the terms
and conditions of the insurance contract
that's not the job of an insurance
appraiser a few years
back I applied for a part-time position
for extra pocket money for one of these
third-party appraisal companies an
independent appraisal company this
company was mainly doing uh handl
appraisals and claims for USAA and I got
my hands on a copy of the paperwork from
that appraisal
company and if it made me sick what they
wanted me to do
and how to Value people's you know
damaged Vehicles it's fraud what is
happening out there is plain fraud and
the New Hampshire law supports that what
I say here the problem is no one wants
to enforce the loss out there on the
books I mean I hate to say be up here
asking to start licensing uh independent
appraisers but something's got to be
done either
a the Attorney General's got to do their
job B
the insurance Department's gotta got to
start doing
something but we shouldn't be up here we
shouldn't be seeing the New Hampshire
Insurance consumers vehicle owners they
heard fellow up here saying he his
initial estimate was 8,000 bucks then it
goes to
28 yep I see it every day these
Insurance appraisers they'll come out
they'll write five six 10 eight
different appraisals they'll start off
at a th000 bucks next thing you know at
the end of the day they're up to 10,000
and they still short pay the uh
Insurance consumer another three or four
grand I got a I got a couple appraisals
here from Liberty Mutual they're famous
for it they don't want to send anybody
out to look at their car they don't want
any
appraisers and and they call their
paperwork appraisals and the insurance
department considers them
appraisals and and it's not uncommon for
them to have five six seven eight
appraisals go from a thousand bucks to
eight to 10 to $10,000
world very frustrating as a a consumer
seeing
myself yearly monthly take money out of
my pocket to pay and get my cars fixed
and then to see my my uh Body Shop
question so you've been around ke your
whole life yep and we all have long
memories and so my question to you is
would you liken this situation to the
good old days bad old days maybe when
you went to Keen Co-op and they gave you
alone and made the appraisal fit the
amount of money you needed before
appraisers real estate appraisers were
licensed is this that same situation
except they're doing it in reverse where
they're underpricing the cost because
they're trying to save the entity money
is it similar to that and should the
these appraisers be licensed like real
estate appraisers or is this a different
scenario pretty much the same thing you
know I had a loss on one of my homes uh
three years ago Foundation collaps into
the lake insurance company sent the uh
their appraiser out they determined it
was not not
on but at least the appraiser had some
ethics you know that came out and these
appraisers that come out here to look at
Vehicles there's no ethics or anything
and you're talking about them
undervaluing claims we have the a
appraiser here that for Vermont mutual
and conquered group Hill inflate claims
too to pun to punish the consumer the
vehicle owner and the body shop for
instance we repaired a fairly new
Hyundai in the last couple months
probably two months ago quot at roughly
nine grand to fix
it but since we and my
customer wouldn't agree to their labor
rates that he wrote up wrote up an
estimate 27 Grand just to make the chir
go away so we fixed it had a sit out
front for the customer to pick up he was
going to make up the difference
but the insurance company says no don't
want to set presidents with that then
the guy writes an an appraisal and
overfat that just so the car goes to the
auction another case State State Farm
that was one of the local insurance
companies based right here in conquered
another one largest company in the
country State
Farm yep 22 Hond Accord since we refused
to put a used steering rack Ed Ste uh
salvaged steering rack salvaged tie rods
on the car and my customer wouldn't
agree to the labor rates my customer
said no you're rebuilding it the way
Honda says we order all the parts
getting into the repairs State firm
comes down totals the vehicle
overinflation appraisal makes it go
away so it goes both ways goes both ways
shop doesn't want you know customer says
well we want it fixed right insurance
companies is going to push back and
they're going to punish you for it
ways yeah okay you
testimony did you have yet written
testimony yeah we go okay okay have one
card left George russos representing the
Hampshire domestic insurance
in
apci I didn't know you were involved
with the
CIA I need a bigger card to put their
name down
um so thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee uh George russos I'm
lawyer with Orin Reno and Conquer and uh
as the chairman said I repres represent
the New Hampshire Association of
domestic insurance companies uh which is
a group of uh local some local companies
smaller companies and and and a few
larger companies as well that write a
lot of insurance business in New
Hampshire and
apca is the American Property Casualty
Insurance Association which is a
national trade
Association um I think uh the prior
speaker has given you a good taste of
what a study committee would be like on
the issue of Licensing
appraisers and um if you want to hear
more of the same then um you can go
ahead and serve on the on the committee
and I would interrupt my short summer to
be present to listen to some of the
testimony and offer another view but um
let me just say that um a few things
about what appraisers do what insurance
adjusters do and what insurance
companies do uh with respect to uh
adjusting losses and then you can decide
whether you think it's worth you know
studying the possibility of Licensing
appraisers um uh first of all appraisers
are hired by insurance companies to put
a value on property and there's
appraisers that uh work with personal
property artwork or jewelry or equipment
or other things that are insured and
that are the subject of loss as well as
uh real property uh damage to roofs or
anything else with respect to the
property and also again and that's what
we're here today I think to talk about
although the bill is broader than that
uh automobile insurance losses and
so they are not licensed but claims
adjusters are
licensed uh they are the persons who by
by Statute it's RSA
402b uh investigate negotiate or settle
property casualty claims that's what a
does Insurance appraisers work for
claims
adjusters and their job is
to obtain facts surrounding a claim or
to furnish technical assistance to a
licensed adjuster so that's that's how
the system works and appraises under the
uh claims adjuster statute are not
required to be licensed so what happens
if a claims uh
appraiser does a poor
job let's say unethical as the prior
speaker suggests they all are uh or
incompetent as they apparently all are
as well well then that appraiser is
responsible to the adjuster who adjusted
the loss the adjuster is licens the
adjuster is the one who will be called
upon to make that claim right and
furthermore the insurance company that
employs the claims at
Jer is licensed by the department and
subject to the laws of the of insurance
as is the public adjuster including the
consumer prot the unfair Trade Practices
Act that governs the conduct of
adjustment of these claims and a rule
that goes into a great detail about what
the responsibilities are of the company
uh and the adjuster to treat consumers
fairly when they have claims so uh some
of I know this is familiar to some of
you Mr chairman you've been through and
some of you've also been through this
sort of issue before where uh what it's
when you strip it all down there are
some auto body shops who believe they
should be paid more uh for the work that
they
do um and
uh uh that is really nothing to do with
this what this bill is about licensing
appraises isn't going to have any effect
on what uh uh what the adjustment of the
loss is which is again the insurance
adjuster that that does that under the
uh Authority granted to the adjusted by
the insurance company but just to
briefly
uh go over what this this law is is
welldeveloped
as and has been around uh since the
invention of the automobile the the
because automobiles have been involved
in accidents and people have uh dealt
with the issue of how to uh how to
respond to those accidents and
responsibilities of insurance companies
to do so so under the law if a
automobile is damaged it is uh
the the insurer is required to bring it
to its pre-accident
condition uh they are required to use
parts that are of like kind of quality
the insured is uh has the ability to
pick whatever repair facility insured
wants to uh go
to uh if there's hidden damage that's
not disclosed at the first estimate but
later disclosed that's obligation of the
insurance company to pay for the hidden
damage uh the law sets forth what the
time frames are for the adjustment uh of
claims 10 days to respond to a claim and
then
thereafter uh uh time periods to to
conduct the uh repair a lot of times now
these repairs and it's it's no fault of
an insurance company or of the repair
shop but these supply chain issues still
exist in there's plenty of stories now
where uh the parts just aren't available
or the the The Body Shop is backed up
and there's a lot of delays still in
repair of vehicles but again that's
beyond the scope of what I read this uh
this bill to uh attempt to
address um so if you want to have a
study I think that's
um not delighted to spend the summer
here but uh or even any part of it but
I'm willing to uh the the uh Bill CER uh
a u a committee to meet within 45 days
of the effective date and then to report
ultimately by its recommendations by
November 1 of
2024 so my only suggestion to you is
that this ground has been covered and
and covered in in a great deal of uh
detail
um I'm not optimistic that um a study of
this issue is likely to bring about uh
any uh change in in policy but again uh
if if you want to study it so so be it
thank
you okay representative burough has a
question say a would you believe um
would you believe that the previous
speaker did not disparage all appraisers
um and say they were all crooked he was
giving examples from his own
that seeing n thank you very much thank
you uh I thought we were all done but we
do have another card here Dan Bennett
from the New Hampshire aor Dealers
Association who would like to speak in
bill uh good afternoon Mr chairman
members of committee Dan Bennett uh
sorry for the late submission was tied
up downstairs um nire Dealers
Association is a trade Association
representing the motor vehicle industry
about 500 businesses in New Hampshire
about 14,000 employees uh we make up
about 24% of the state's retail sales uh
we also represent about uh 60 Collision
repairers in the state some are
associated with franchised uh automobile
dealers but many are Independents um I'm
proud to say that actually more of our
our body shop constituency are
independent independent shops um so
we're here in support of the bill um see
uh no harm in a in a study committee um
and actually some some practical
Solutions probably could result that
would benefit not only the shops um but
also the carriers um and most
importantly the consumers if
efficiencies um were to be found and
gained in the repair um and Appraisal
process um obviously vehicles are really
complex um you can't do an accurate
estimate just by snapping a iPhone
picture and emailing it to someone you
have to tear the vehicle down get into
it and find out what's broken uh hidden
structural um stuff so photo estimating
is is is problematic for the industry um
and it significantly slows down the
process by um injecting this
supplemental repair um and delaying the
cost so um you submit uh for
reimbursement and then another one and
another one and it significantly slows
down the process for their pairer but
more importantly for the consumer too
and you know if you all are familiar
with your automobile insurance policies
your rentals only have so many days
right so the longer the process goes the
more likely you're getting closer to
that you know rental window where it's
no longer available and then the
consumer has to go to the hip and and
pay out of their own pocket so uh if
there's a way to speed up the process
speed up the appraisal and estimating
thing that's a win-win-win so uh it's
it's our opinion that um this this bill
is um is well- intended um and again
could yield some positive results for um
you know the the three-legged stool
which is the carrier the consumer and
the repairer so um with that being said
we hope you support the bill um and I'll
any guess we're all questioned out thank
you sir thank you having no more cards I
will close the public hearing on Senate
Bill
325 and since we're a little bit behind
schedule we'll move forward to Senate
Bill
and daily is going to uh introduce the
Lang good afternoon chairman hunt and
members of the committee my name is D
Fett and I'm the Senate majority caucus
director I'm here to introduce Senate
Bill 137 FN on behalf of Senator Lang s
Bill 137 FN is a request of the New
Hampshire craft Brewers Association and
the bill would repeal the Nano B license
and it would create a four tier
licensing and fee structure so domestic
sales under 500 barrels per year would
be $240 domestic sales of 51 to 2,500
barrels per year would be
$480 domestic sales of 251 to 15,000
barrels per year would be $1,200
and domestic sales of more than 15,000
per year would be
$1,692 so transitioning to an
introductory transitioning to an
introductory beverage manufacturing tier
would likely generate Revenue because
lenses would have an option to pay an
additional restaurant or satellite fee
from an enforcement perspective this
bill would help to simplify rsas and
allow for better communication between
Brewers and the New Hampshire Liquor
Commission the new license structure
would allow for small businesses to
operate under a standard set of rules
and regulations while having them pay a
larger fee as they grow and increase
their sales this legislation would help
bring greater parity to the licensing
structure as well as provide a
consistent experience for customers
going from one location to another the
Senate amended the bill to make a small
change of the effective date from July
1st 2023 to July 1st of
2024 so thank you for allowing me the
opportunity to speak this afternoon I
believe there are some folks here from
the craft Brewers Association who should
be able to answer any questions you have
great thank you very
much uh so we'll have Andrew provencher
who is going to represent the New
Association thank you chairman hun for
the record my name is Andrew preventure
I'm here on behalf of the New Hampshire
Brewers Association uh we have a number
of breweries that are here today to
speak in favor of this uh legislation uh
wanted to uh just kind of highlight a
couple items uh CJ Hayes who's our
executive director is uh not uh in the
state today uh but certainly will be
available soon if there are some
additional technical information or
questions that folks would have uh the
nhba represents 86 independent craft
breweries in New Hampshire uh many of
which are small and family-owned we have
a number of uh Nanos uh brew pubs uh and
beverage manufacturers and uh everyone
agrees that this legislation is a a
great step forward and the next step uh
in New Hampshire's uh simplification of
our of our license fee structure the
Nano uh designation has been very
popular and successful and has served
the industry extremely well and we don't
see this as much as a elimination of the
Nano as a reclassification of the Nano
into a um this tiered structure the fees
that were just mentioned
are the same fees that are in place now
um there are some circumstances where
you could have a a current Nano who will
end up having to pay a little bit more
money uh after this there's some
scenarios where you have a beverage
manufacturer who will pay a little bit
less money uh but as you see in the
fiscal note uh we don't believe that
there'll be much of a uh a major change
in regards to uh income uh we do think
that this will help simplify this
process a lot also allows a a uh a
brewer to get into the business at a
tier one level uh and then kind of level
up as they maybe get more popular or
they're selling more beer uh and move
their way up through the structure as
opposed to starting as a nano having to
get a new license type and switch over
to a beverage
manufacturer uh one thing we did want to
mention uh when reading it is that we do
think there's a small clerical error uh
that we would ask the committee to um
potentially uh fix for us and this would
be on line uh
23 and 24 of Page
6 uh it mentions uh it puts a annual
production uh limit and we believe that
that probably should be struck so it
currently reads no unopened container
sold by a beverage manufacturer license
with an annual production under 2500
barrels annually shall be opened or
consumed on the licens premises um we
believe it actually should read no
unopened container sold by a beverage
manufacturer license shall be opened or
consumed on the license premises and I
believe the um New Hampshire Liquor
Commission will be able to to speak to
this as well um otherwise we um hope to
earn the committee's support and we feel
like this would be a uh a great step in
the right direction for what is a
growing uh industry and uh a strong uh
part of the New Hampshire economy happy
to answer any questions and like I said
we have a few Brewers who will be
awesome all set thank thank you if you
have written testimony the clerk would
appreciate okay Drew I left let you hang
in too long last week so we'll call you
up sooner this time yes come on up Drew
Klein representing desiah Barlett is
talking about how important we need to
be
efficient uh Mr chairman I I I see I've
testified a lot before this committee
thank you for the opportunity and
members of the committee I'll try to be
um pretty brief I want to give you guys
the Josiah Bartlet Center with the New
Hampshire's free market thing tank and
our take on this bill I mean we our
mission is to promote Economic
Opportunity and prosperity for all
Granite Staters and we see this as
hitting both of those uh from the
opportunity standpoint and the
prosperity standpoint so as some of you
know have you've been doing this Brewery
legislation for a while um Vermont and
Main really got way out way way out
ahead of New Hampshire on Craft
breweries for decades and we fell way
behind and the reason for that was
uh their regulations were better and it
was easier to start small breweries and
grow them in those two states the
creation of the Nano Brewery n plus and
micro Brewery licenses back in the day
were really really helpful for New
Hampshire and it really grew New
Hampshire's Craft brewery industry but
now we're seeing that those rigid
categories are creating problems for the
industry because unlike the other states
of Northern New England um our Nano and
Nano plus hold uh Brewers in those
license categories so if you if you're a
startup you want to start small you're
locked into that rigid category that's
not the case in Maine in Vermont so we
went and looked at those uh statutes in
Maine in Vermont and it's much much
easier to start and grow a beverage
manufacturing business there so in Maine
for example you get a brewery
license which allows the manufacturer of
more than 50,000 gallons of beer and
they do it by gallon there and a license
fee of $1,000 or a small Brewer license
which allows you to make up to up to
50,000 gallons with a license fee of
just 50
bucks that's it that's their two
categories very easy in
Vermont they have um slightly different
you obtain a beverage manufacturer
license for $285 annual fee if you want
to then sell beer that you make on
premises that's a separate license it's
a retail license for 70 bucks then they
have other retail licenses for wine and
spirits but you're not locked into that
startup category whereas in New
Hampshire you're at a big competitive
disadvantage if you want to start as a
nano or Nano plus and grow unlike in our
neighboring states in Northern New
England you have to go back and apply
for a separate license so it's very
burdensome so our breweries are again at
a disadvantage to the competitors in
Northern New England and it's one of the
reasons why in The Craft among craft
beer ficient Autos Vermont is actually a
pretty legendary state people will
travel from Massachusetts through New
Hampshire to get to Vermont breweries
now thankfully over the last 20 years
we've been able to add a lot more craft
breweries here but
we're the way we regulate them is
hindering the growth of the industry so
as we look at this we look at uh this
particular Bill creating the four tier
system boy is it much smoother it's much
easier so you can start a business in
New Hampshire and instead of being
locked into that rigid category where
you have to go back and apply for a
separate
license you want to grow great you just
go back you pay a bigger fee and and
this is one of the really I think genius
parts of
s137 it's not just about the barrels
it's not just about growth it's about
what you can offer your consumers right
so the consumers don't care and I know
you some of you have heard this from
Brewers before and you'll probably hear
it today they don't care if you're a
Craft brewery a nano brewery a brew pub
they don't even know these categories
all they know is my neighborhood bar my
small town you know Craft brewery I want
to go and get a good beer and and some
food they have to tell their customers
all the time sorry we can't sell you
wine sorry we can't sell you a beer from
another Brewery sorry we only have these
limited options and the customers don't
understand because they're not locked
into that rigid categorization in other
states as well as much as we are here in
New Hampshire what this bill does it
allows you to pay different fees for
different te and offer a much different
variety so it's just it's so much more
flexible for the entrepreneur and the
business when we look at this from the B
center point of view just from a
regulatory standpoint it just makes much
more sense it's more intuitive for the
business owner it's more intuitive for
the customer it creates a lot more
flexibility and the market changes the
Craft Beer Market like everything else
changes rapidly so it gives those
business owners the opportunity to say
you know what maybe we want to add some
Selter maybe we want to add some
different options we can do that we to
the state we apply we pay a fee we can
do that quickly it's just much more
flexible so our overall take on this is
it would be a big Boon for Economic
Opportunity and Entrepreneurship in New
Hampshire but also for economic growth
once you see once you get this change in
place I think you're going to see a lot
more people try and experiment and do
startups um and if we get a a more
robust industry here that's more
flexible and more customer friendly it's
a small effect but it will you know help
and I know you guys have heard this
before when it comes to recruiting young
people recruiting Talent um people from
out of state they want a vibrant night
life they want a vibrant restaurant
industry they want variety and this will
I think do a little bit to help keep
people here so I think it's a good bill
of great thank you very much for your
testimony thank you I I have a question
oh we do have a question representative
Herbert sorry slow with the trigger um
I'm I'm not sure you know the answer but
uh do we get Mike it's a little far from
does the state get a percent of
sales that I think I'll leave to a more
of an expert on the actual they do I so
we were getting revenue from this so
yeah so the way this the way I look at
the licensing here
is revenue shouldn't be your primary
concern about this right you want to
grow the economy but when you're
creating more flexibility and ease of
growth for businesses I think you're
going to end up getting a lot more
Revenue in the long term over this even
if some businesses uh change their
classification cuz under this some uh
brew pubs for example might want to go
to a small tier tier one or tier 2 uh
manufacturing license but because you're
creating that flexibility you're easing
entry into the market I think you're
going to see a lot more businesses come
into the market it's going to create
more competition it's going to create
more economic activity so I think in the
long run the revenues are going to go up
not just from the fees but from the
taxes from the sales from the r meals
tax I think this is an economic winner
not just for the economy as a whole but
for state
revenue thank you yeah for the record um
a licensing fee should only it should
never be perceived as a revenue
generator it should only be the cost for
the Department to enforce the statute
however in the state of New Hampshire we
do have a rooms and meals tax and that
was a original issue with the Nanos
because some of them thought they might
be exempt from the rooms and meals and
we had to clarify that uh yes they
absolutely pay the rooms and meals tax
when they sell their beer list they give
it away for free which technically
they're allowed to
do and uh and then of course they make
business profits tax and bet tax and all
those good things that help the state
revenue thank you very
much okay uh next up is uh we'll have
good
afternoon Hi how are you uh my name is
Kiren nevs I'm a co-founder and owner of
Tuckerman Brewing Company and also
president of the New Hampshire Brewers
Association and referring back to your
question about taxes yes we do pay rooms
and meals tax uh we also pay an excise
tax to the state and we pay a federal
excise tax as
well uh but yes but so sorry so I am
here uh testifying in support of s SP
137 uh this legislation will simplify
Brewery licensing New Hampshire and it
will put all Brewers on an even playing
field this will eliminate confusion for
Brewers and their customers when
different Brewery license types have
different uh rules of operation right
now um we're a beverage manufacturer we
started in 98 so we've been a beverage
manufacturer in the state for 26 years
but this the industry has changed
dramatically in that time uh but since
then the Nano B was added uh The Brew
Pub has been around for a long time but
we all have different abilities as to
what we can do in terms of selling uh
beer and uh whether we have food
requirements required so it gets very
confusing as to who can do what SP 137
would put us all as beverage
manufactures and then it would be sort
of all a cart like if we wanted to start
a restaurant attached to the brewery and
serve uh serve more beer then we would
add a restaurant license to that for
beer and wine or if we wanted to sell
cocktails we could add a liquor license
to that as well but it would be more of
an all a card system but it would add
put us all sort of on an even playing
field
um and we have find found over the years
that there's been a lot of confusion
when a customer can go a couple miles
down the road to a nano brewery and
they're able to order food from a food
truck and also order many pint as many
pints as they want but if they come to
our place before we added our restaurant
license we were restricted to order uh
selling one or two pints at a time and
it just gets confusing for customers and
I think it puts New Hampshire breweries
at a disadvantage because when they come
from NE neighboring states and they have
a much uh easier time visiting local
breweries and their experience there it
sort of puts us at a disadvantage when
they can't do that in New
Hampshire uh but yeah uh and I'm happy
questions repres burough hi this is a
would you believe I live in your area
you know I'm in the Mount Washington
Valley Valley I just want to say what an
amazing addition Tuckerman has been to
the valley it's a place where young
people go I guess I don't qualify in
that that description anymore but um you
know a great place where people come for
events and you have great food and I was
very disappointed how tough trivia night
was last
week that can't be tough but no thank
you very
much okay thank you very much all right
thank you guys uh Damon Lewis from
vulgar
Brewing yeah so I'm sorry I'm a little
nervous first time doing this sort of
thing but uh I'm Damon Lewis from vulger
buring I appreciate everybody's time and
Chairman's time um it's funny because
literally what is described as my exact
situation we have opened in 2019 in
Franklin New Hampshire we were licensed
as a nano brewery uh as of tomorrow we
will be licensed as a beverage
manufacturer uh and the only reason for
that change for us is we wanted to carry
cider uh we don't want to up production
we're not looking to do any of those
things but under our Nano license we
cannot bring in any product that we
don't make and we are not allowed to
make cider U because we want to provide
more options for the people that come
into our place and some are gluten-free
obviously a brewery is is not a good
place for that so we want to provide
those options um so for us it's it's
kind of does bring everybody on the same
playing field we now be buying cider
from a distributor so they actually have
a revenue stream they didn't have before
because we were not even able to do it
if we wanted to um so I really just
testifying support um for that reason I
mean it affects us drastically and of
course the licensing fee until this
would goes into effect hopefully uh we
had to pay an extra $1,200 just to to
have that right um with no plan changes
to really use any of the other benefits
that currently the beverage manufacturer
tier provides um so being able to scale
up and add that would be a huge deal for
us and we're a small Brewer compared to
a lot of places so uh $1,200 does matter
to us you know I mean it matters to
everybody but that's somebody's paycheck
you know one week when we're slow in the
winter those sort of things so um just
want to raise my support and if anybody
has any questions about that process
because it did take about four months to
change that as well um I'm happy to
answer them you know at any time
so guess we're all set thank you thank
you uh chair will call in Erica
petar hit the hit the button there you
go there we go thank you chairman hun
the rest of the committee for hearing
this um most of my points have been
touched on so I Will Not Waste too much
of your time um but this is a bill that
we've been working on for a few years as
most of you know um we think it's
incredibly significant for the Brewing
industry not just to simplify the
licensing process and help with that uh
streamlining communication with the
Liquor Commission um reduce costs offer
more growth opportunities in an easier
way um but we genuinely believe that it
will help all aspects
all stakeholders in this industry um you
know from the breweries with the ability
to do something with an alart license
for a retail outlet for example a lot of
us really like finding those open spots
in possibly rundown Main Street
communities where we can't produce beer
there it's not big enough but we could
bring some Vitality back to some small
towns um if we can just set up our
retail space there currently not an
option for Nano breweries but it is for
for beverage manufacturers um I think
we'd see a lot of benefit in some of
these smaller towns um I'm in Peterboro
we are now just a local hub for
Neighbors to meet sit around have a beer
like Damon I would love to have a cider
for many of the people that come and
just drink non-alcoholic seltzers to
hang out um so it benefits all of the
breweries I think it could really
benefit some of our smaller Main Street
communities um it also will increase our
relationship with distributor
um on day one as soon as I can I'll sign
on with somebody to get cers in my top
room um and we do think it'll encourage
more people to add that restaurant
license or Food Service license to their
beverage manufacturer now that it'll be
an easier process so I think everything
else I plan on saying has already been
said U but if you have any questions I'm
happy to
answer have a question representa Ammon
thank you Mr Sher thank you for your
testimony you did a great job um this
question may be for you or maybe the
Liquor Commission so if you don't know
the answer um this act takes effect July
1st
2024 uh how does the transition how how
do you imagine the transition would work
from the old licensing scheme to the new
licensing scheme does everybody have to
apply July 1st I think that how I
imagine it it's probably not how the
Liquor Commission will answer that so uh
that's definitely a better question for
them
yeah yeah the bill will go to a
subcommittee so we'll be revie the
process
thank you very
much anybody want else speak on
it seeing none they will close the
public
hearing moveing right
ahead not too far behind now Senate Bill
433 establ commission to study the
marketing of e cigarettes and El liquid
in the state including legality of
available products appropriate wholesale
retail compliance and tax collection
same I didn't
daily so daily for that we'll introduce
it for Senator
Lang good afternoon again
good afternoon good afternoon chairman
hunt members of the committee my name is
Daley F I'm the Senate majority caucus
director I'm here to introduce Senate
Bill 433 on behalf of Senator Lang
Senator Lang originally brought this
bill forward due to concerns regarding
perceived unequal enforcement of the
cigarette tax as well as how it is
applied the bill as introduced would
have created a commission to study
enforcement and collection of The Vape
tax imposed by RSA 78 col 2 uh section
2B one and two uh enacted in 2020
however as amended by the Senate the
charge of the commission was broaden to
include studying the marketing of
ecigarettes and E-liquid in New
Hampshire including the G the legality
of the available products appropriate
wholesale and Retail compliance along
with the tax collection system the
commission would include members of the
House the Senate The Liquor Commission
the Dr and members of the public who are
engaged in wholesale or retail sale of
tobacco products thank you very much for
allowing me the opportunity to speak
again today uh there are some members
from the New Hampshire Vapor Association
who are here and we'll be able to answer
any questions that you
representa thanks for taking my question
can you explain like I'm just looking up
here about eLiquid you is that mean you
actually drink nicotine uh no to to my
understanding when you have a electronic
cigarette you can add what is called a
vape liquid that contains it's a liquid
form of uh nicotine that is combusted
within the uh uh device in order to
smoke it that's how I understand it do
not drink it can you put it drink what
was that can you use Diet Coke
comment magic okay thank you very much
thank
you okay uh Alison Preston who's going
to the New Hampshire Vapor Association
in
and Bri you're gonna guys are tag
teaming on this yeah
okay uh thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee my name is Alicia Preston
I represent the New Hampshire Vapor
Association we are in support of this
bill uh Brett who owns 11 vape stores in
New Hampshire can explain a little more
in detail why but in general since the
tax which is relatively new I believe
just three years went into place there's
been some discussion as to whether all
the taxes are actually being collect
collected how they're being collected
and is there potentially a better way to
do so to make sure that they are our
understanding is there's probably
literally several million dollars worth
of taxes that are not being collected
out there and representing the vapor
Association we want it to be done
properly um it undercuts obviously if
people aren't paying their taxes it
undercuts those that are doing it
properly um and I think Brett can speak
to a little more
detail awesome uh thank you all for your
time my name is Brett scottt and uh
again kind of building off from that so
specifically here in New Hampshire I own
11 stores and I pulled some information
from the Department of Revenue to better
understand what percentage of the Vape
tax we're paying and we are paying at
that time when I did that we were paying
26% of The Vape taxes being collected by
the state of New Hampshire that's out of
11 stores and uh though I would love to
tell myself that we're 26% of the market
share I know that's not reality
um these products are sold in
Convenience Stores um I mean if you
drive Salem alone there's a lot of
stores um you know and there's a lot of
these stores throughout the state so
there's a major problem with this when
you look at the uh cigarette Market
There's an actual tax stamp on those
products um that market it's a Level
Playing Field because there's an
identifier the tax has been paid um it's
very closely tracked uh so there's good
control of that market this Vape Market
there is not tracking any identifier on
here that's been paid and the auditing
that's currently done is very generic uh
and therefore it makes it very easy for
people to evade paying the taxes on
these products and it's a major problem
and I truly believe that the amount that
is not being collected is substantial
and would absolutely be worth the time
to revisit to to take a look at this and
see if there's a better way to make sure
that the tax is being paid and uh that's
ultimately what I'm here for is uh
seeking a Level Playing Field and I
discussions repres M uh thank you and
thank you for taking my question your
your
26% what is that in dollars how much is
that mean amount in dollars we're paying
over $200,000 a month in
tax that's just out of the 11 I mean I
own stores in other states but that's
specific to New Hampshire just out of
you okay thank you so the amendment you
had sent me we do have a copy of it if
here Kristen that let make sure she get
that
Amendment
yeah secret
secret okay and anybody else who's also
interested in a amendment to deal with
this 433 issue but uh fundamentally is
that uh we're we're dealing with a fly
by night kind of uh in in in business
it's not big tobacco and we're which big
tobacco is is highly regulated and we I
don't think they put stamps on it
anymore per se right they on cigarettes
they do they still have still have that
stamp on absolutely some reason I
remember I some reason I thought we got
rid of oh okay we got rid of the the
real stamp there used to be a a stamp
stamp that used to be you know the tag
stamp familiar that we that I was around
for when we repealed that but so okay
thank you very much thank you all right
is there anybody else who would like to
testify on Senate Bill
433 see
none we will close Senate Bill 43 it's
business
okay
soes now we're behind ahead of schedule
Mr chairman quick question about
tomorrow yes the are we changing the
schedule at all tomorrow or deleting one
or changing sub what happened was Senate
Bill 354 which we're hearing
today because um senator in was not
going to be able uh to make it
tomorrow uh and so I moved it today so
evidently if you have a calendar that
still has 354 tomorrow uh you can ignore
it um otherwise uh tomorrow I believe
we'll have then after the the morning
we'll have then heard all our Senate
bills and and um so the tomorrow
afternoon is free and then starting the
following week we have two weeks in
which we have to do subcommittees get
through all the bills and execute we
have to have everything out by the
15th of May so we're GNA do two days
next week we'll do two days next week
and I'll I'll try to divide it up by the
subcommittees um and we'll try to just
you know Trot through those um it used
to be we'd always say well it's almost
easier when you have Senate bills
because they've already been through the
grinder on the Senate side but uh this
year it feels a little different about
the vigilance the senate had on their
legislation yes representative
spear since we we have a few minutes
before the next start could you explain
about the study committees because we
have two bills now oh okay chapter study
committees yeah so chapter study
committees is after uh the bill has been
signed by the governor um then it goes
to and you can see what terms of whether
their appointments House and Senate um
and traditionally it's always been
Senators never show up on the second
year so that's why there's only one
Senator on these study committees and
then and chalk full of three or four
house members because evidently house
members are more than willing to show up
for a study committee I generally myself
personally the study committee should be
really well focused on getting something
accomplished or what they're doing when
you have a study committee that's going
to be a little general and just overall
it's you know it's it's going to feel
like if you get appointed it's going to
time so um otherwise the they are
appointed by the speaker so if there's a
study committee you see that you really
want to get on I do urge you to uh let
speaker let the speaker you want to do
the one that's not kind crazy the
interesting thing is it does it they can
they can wave the rule about how we
don't meet in July and
August so that if the if the chairman of
the committee and
um is interested in actually you know
spending more time and delving into it
they could actually meet in the
summer and I would have to say that's
number one reason why I avoid being
appointed to a study committee because I
I don't want to drive up from Rhode
Island June 15th I got on June 15th you
have to volunteer for this I mean it's
not like you can no you'll be you they
um I would say say that often the
speaker will call me up and ask me who I
think should be
appointed and since you
asked so yeah no it should be you you
really want to interested in in doing it
um there's a committee and a
commission so okay so yeah committee
difference between a committee and a
commission a committee is only going to
have house members appointed to it a
commission
is uh it's a free-for-all so uh for
instance the marijuana bill was a
commission so that had all kinds of
interested parties who had some skin in
the game would then get appointed to the
commission um and then you have limited
amount of legislators per se we're on a
commission
so any else you want to think I should
add on that well the the the interesting
thing is uh who calls the first meeting
usually says uh it's based on the bill
yeah who with the bill number was a
Senate bill so these say the first named
Senate member will call the first
meeting sometimes the Senate never calls
the first meeting and so the thing just
happen probably we should not have
passed it in the first
place
I was going to come over and get your
problem I got my
uh the nuclear Mission had a report that
got
e
what ready we'll open up the public
hearing on Senate Bill 354 and here from
the prime sponsor Senator inis good
afternoon Senator good afternoon Mr
chair members of the committee Dan inis
from district 7 Bradford New Hampshire
happy to be here this afternoon to
introduce to you Senate Bill
354 and this is an interesting Bill and
I'm sure there'll be a lot of discussion
in testimony that follows me and uh many
of the folks behind me will be able to
answer some of the technical questions
that I might not be quite so precise in
answering but I can uh generally present
what we're doing here and why we're
doing it so imagine you went out to
dinner and you've got a gift
certificate and you've enjoyed your meal
waiter comes over leaves the check you
put down your gift certificate and a
credit card when the server returns with
your payment you notice you've been
charged the full amount despite of
having gift certificate which doesn't
much make
sense and it doesn't seem right to you
well that's essentially what we're
dealing with in this particular bill is
a situation where you have assistance in
paying for a medication and the
insurance company says that's great and
we're not applying that to your
deductible so if you put yourself in a
medical position instead of
dinner my sister-in-law for example has
just wrapped up chemotherapy $10,000 a
month insurance pays about 8,000 of that
80% the other
2,000 comes from the pharmaceutical
company and in this situation like many
others the insurance company says thank
you very much but we're not applying
that to your deductible so you as a
patient still have to cover that
deductible to get to the place where you
don't have to worry about it anymore so
effectively the companies are double
dipping at the expense of the patients
and in my view and the view of many
others it shouldn't really matter to the
the insurance company who's paying for
the medication if the insurance company
isn't paying for it
themselves so it's a fairly logical uh
bill I think that we're bringing forward
here and I'll read to you an excerpt
from an article that appeared regarding
the a similar bill in the state of Rhode
Island so we had a patient who was being
treated um very expensive treatment and
this patient had gone through two
treatments um and was ready for the
third and when they placed the order the
representative on the phone said that he
would owe
$2,400 in payment he said that can't be
right because I should have met my
deductible already so he contacted the
insurance company and after many hours
on the phone was told that because the
plan included a copay accumulator
adjustment program which is what this
bill tried to eliminate any support for
his prescriptions that didn't come out
of pocket
would not be counted against the
deductible so again why should it matter
to the insurance company who's paying
for the medication just so it's being
paid and shouldn't that apply to the
patients
deductible there are an awful lot of
organizations that support this those
organizations that work with patients
with hemophilia who take medication all
the time the American Cancer Society is
supportive among
others some people say well if this goes
through we're going to see a big
increase in health insurance costs
that's simply not true in the 19 states
where similar legislation has been
passed the global health healthy living
Foundation has found no significant
change to health insurance premiums in
those 19 States and I think that speaks
for itself so let's make sure that
co-pays count regardless of their Source
whether it's big Pharma someone helping
a patient out through a GoFundMe or some
other source or the patient themselves
let's just it all apply to the
deductible as it should and I'm happy to
take any questions okay let me start
first because I like stories and you
told us a story yes I did okay so when I
have a gift card
MH somebody paid for that gift card
correct there was cash paid somewhere
along the line so when I'm applying it
I'm taking advantage of the fact that it
was that piece was
paid yes so in your
example who
paid for that coupon I see where you're
going with this and it's essentially a
credit from the pharmaceutical company
so the pharmaceutical
company is when when you turn in that
card that that discount card yes to the
pharmacy yes the pharmacy is expected to
turn it in just like a coup like he gets
gift gift C C or no corre uh coupons yes
and it's going to turn it in and fer or
and fiser will pay
it they will pay it that's the
understanding that I have that they
really would pay it well the pharmacy
the far the pharmacy where you're
fulfilling the prescription is getting
paid right why say I care it's at the
end of the day the the um the issue is
that is a this coupon is is going to get
paid the pharmacy is going to get its
paay correct and therefore the pharmacy
would then notify the insurance company
that's correct
that the sum of actually they wouldn't
notify as far as the're concern they're
saying is they're going to be paid and
so therefore it's really now a cash flow
problem for the pharmacy okay because
the pharmacy is going to want is going
to take that coupon corre they're going
to tell the insurance company that they
paid it that's right that it got paid
yes and it's up to them the pharmacy to
go get the money from the pharmaceutical
company correct and it that's a
different story isn't it now I don't
know if it is or not okay well that was
a different story than I was told I
would encourage you Mr chair ask that
question some of the folks behind make
sure that's exactly the way the bill is
supposed to be handled I knew I could
count on you
okay now we have questions
representative
spear insurance companies have set up
formulary formularies with the pbms
yes when a coupon is made available it's
usually made available for a spe
specific branded drug that's correct
that bypasses the formulary it bypasses
all of the insurance companies
accounting for how they're going to
build on their uh premiums okay and now
essentially kind of guided towards a
drug rather than being able to have an
analysis that says this a perfectly good
other drug that costs half the price but
you're not going to get it because
you've gone onto this coupon thing and
you don't want it and you don't want to
change so in the instead of the
formulary being used as a guidance to
find all the drugs that are available at
a specific tier now we're having drug
companies Market directly to the
insurance uh Market directly to the
patients bypassing all the efforts that
are made and I saw that that I saw that
Medicare considers this a kickback
scheme and that they won't even allow it
so my question to you
is how is this going to
solve or or maintain price
maintain uh premium prices and the cost
of premiums when we can't even control
what drugs are being sold to the uh cons
to the patients when there are perfectly
good drugs
available I'm not sure I understand the
question
um let's say let's say we amend this
bill to say it can only be for generic
drugs only for generic correct well
there was an amendment that
it shall not apply in the case of
prescription drug for which there's a
generic alternative so we're kind of mov
I'm doing the opposite I see that you
are yeah I mean words the assumption is
we don't want someone to buy a to get a
drug because because they have that
coupon right that they're going to take
the one that is more expensive than the
generic one and therefore that's where
you're going to see the increase in
premiums because now like a heroin
dealer you've given them that cheap
price because you gave them a couple of
coupons and got them hooked and now
they're going to want that name brand
product and when those coupons run out
you're but Mr chair respectfully I think
you're treating this as if it's a coupon
for something in the grocery store where
the consumer makes a full choice of what
they're going to be taking in this case
you have a doctor offering a
prescription and a specific medication
for a particular patient with a specific
problem that to me is a different
scenario if there is a generic
alternative that's effective then I
would agree with you that should be the
first choice of care assuming it works
if it doesn't and there are cases where
it may not biosimilars and whatnot um
then I think this situation still
applies I understand your argument but
it's not a really a free Choice market
for most patients with cancer there are
specific drugs treat specific cancers in
specific ways and that's what the
doctors describe this bill it says it
cannot have
a generic or any other more affordable
drug well as it's written now it says
the requirement shall not apply in the
case of a prescription drug for which
there's a generic alternative so
effectively we're saying start with the
generic right okay but with the key
element my remember was my my uh
mother-in-law that the doctor wanted to
put her on
eloquest and El this is years ago yeah
El just came out and it was like know
the hugely expensive but she was
Medicare anyways yeah so I don't even
know whether Medicare how how Medicare
treats it back then but the issue was
that that yeah he gave her a coupon but
the coupon it was only limited there was
only that first visit yeah and then
after that now she's on the more
expensive the eloquest and never was
really offered the opportunity to get on
something that might have been less
expensive in going forward yeah I think
you know the desire all the time is to
try to keep cost down and get patients
the treatment they deserve and if a
generic does that then fully supportive
of that um if not and there is an exp
more expensive alternative that works
better your side effects more effective
and this comes into play then we'd like
to see that count toward to the
deductible but I appreciate your point
so so basically the the end of the day
is that because that patient got what
that doctor referred because they were
taking the coupon the fact that there is
a consequence for everyone else who
doesn't have that opportunity that the
overall pharmaceutical costs are going
up because the more expensive drug was
was the one that got the name you know
the name brand not that to you it's that
fairness of that we're all we're all
paying we should all be happy that that
patient was able to get that name brand
drug wow that that's what we really
should be happy about I think one of the
concerns I hear as an undercurrent in
your comments is that insurance rates
will go up because if those drug costs
are going up well the drug I'm assuming
the drug is more expensive in fact
insurance cost should go up too but
analysis of the 19 states that have
passed similar legislation hasn't proven
that to be the case and only thing I
educate and make sure everybody knows is
about the mlr the minimum loss ratio
yeah and that minimum loss ratio takes a
while for you to to see it because it's
on a rolling threeyear average
understood so you really don't know how
much impact those coupons had until you
know you're out three years out three
years out
understood okay representing M thank you
Mr chairman I also like a good story and
I even further like a good analogy if I
can combine the
two so what I like to ask you about is
are these coupons at all like restaurant
gift certificates if you
probably not but it is a good analogy
that helps people to understand the
concept well if if you if you had just
so you know there are two kinds of GI to
it there's one that you actually paid
for I'm talk about then there's another
one that is they they do a sale they're
doing a discount trying to entice you in
now the reason I say this is because I
wrote the law and that is if someone
underlying pays for that coup that gift
certificate it cannot EXP expire in New
Hampshire in many states they were
expiring them in two years but if it's a
gift certificate that had no underlying
dollar value then yes they can expire
chairman when we discussed that many
years ago on behalf of the restaurant
and Laing Association
and and and and I loost so the qu the
question is is this at all like having
that do the pharmas carry this uh credit
as a liability on the books and and it
then should the consumer you know expect
to get value for that coupon and and
they have it as a liability much like
yeah the restaurants would have or do
and that's why they wanted to expire
them and we had that we had that
discussion many many years ago having
been in the hotel business
representative I know exactly what
you're talking about and selling the
place you've got that liability that
you've got to credit the buyer with
right I can't answer for the
pharmaceutical companies on how they
handle the accounting on this perhaps
someone who's yet to testify can address
that for you thank you for the
question no I was thinking the banking
credit debit and you know erases the
transaction out that's all I wanted to
know when you said credit yeah I said oh
okay well the pharmacy's got toes
here yeah that's what I'm
that's the house oversight committee did
a study over five years on Medicare they
found
that once a coupon
expired a person was now in favor of
that drug that they've gotten used to
the drug price went up an average of 12
to 12 to 133% okay
versus the situation where they don't
allow coupons which they don't allow
anymore they did not see that increase
okay so when you say that it will not
cause an increase in drug prices that's
not what Medicare found I understand and
other states have found the same thing
California did an incredibly extensive
study on this and it showed a very
similar kind of an increase that once a
person got moved into that drug
you know that is it's marketed directly
from the drug company to the patient
going beyond the even in some cases the
doctor going usually beyond the doctor
and Beyond the uh the uh insurance
company's
recommendations uh they're now got
somebody locked in and prices are going
up so when where are you getting I mean
I'm not clear on why you
say this this goes against everything
that the formulary does which is to to
en encourage uh competition if you will
and this takes takes that away right
because we're marketing directly from an
insurance comp uh from a uh drug company
to a patient even the doctor doesn't get
involved in some of those cases so I'm
not clear on why represent are you
saying that Medicare does no longer
allow this no they do not they consider
it Medicare considers coupons
I want to use the right words an illegal
Kickback that's what they write it's an
illegal Kickback if we were to write
this bill to say that the coupon can
never expire once a consumer has been
given a coupon that that coupon will
have to last as long as that patient
needs that drug Representatives I think
you're trying to bring this down to a
consumer level a coupon for poptarts
right versus toaster strudel as a
medical consumer I don't get those
choices I work with the doctor the
coupon is for a specific purpose for a
specific drug drug at a specific time
it's not for a hotel room three years
from now or for a discount on Pop-Tarts
next week which I think would be a great
thing I love Pop darts um you seen the
movie but I I understand the reasoning
and the logic I don't disagree with that
logic I'm just not sure it neatly fits
this situation we are the Commerce
Committee you know that yes I understand
consumer I'm a bit of a Commerce
Professor myself representative Amon has
a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for giving your testimony um curious
about precedent in other states uh has
this been done elsewhere and how
recently and to what effect it's been
done in 19 States and it's been
successful in all of those to the best
of my knowledge
yes okay
all right any other questions seeing
none thank you Mr chair thank you
committee this is a great discussion I
really appreciate the thought you put
into it I do hope we can get to a place
where we can do something with this and
I thank you very much for your time I do
have one more question oh you have one
more question go ahead I always
do I'll try to answer representative
it's your bill section
three section three
yes this is a program of maximizers and
efforts by the insurance companies to
help patients with uh very expensive uh
specialty drugs correct and this bill
specifically wants to take that away if
on one hand we're talking about wanting
to
support drug access to
individuals why do we have this in here
to try to take it away how is it taking
it away I'm not sure I
follow oh I have a paper on it okay I
will give you the paper I would like to
see it stay tuned all right thank you
very much once again thank you commit uh
next we'll have the insurance department
and we got Jason aies and Michelle
it good afternoon
uh for the record I'm Jason AES director
of Health economics at the insurance
department and I'm Michelle Heaton I'm
the director of life and
health yeah I thank you for your time so
the insurance department has some real
concerns for Senate Bill 354 as this
passage will contribute to increased
premiums however this is a policy
decision that is the board faces Ure a
plan design accounts for payment of
covered benefits and patient cost
sharing to pay claims if an outside
stream of payment such as a
manufacturer's coupon is used to offset
total cost sharing responsibility then
reactively insurers will have no other
choice but to increase premiums in
subsequent
years this passage of the bill will
inhibit generic efficiency which refers
to the Market's rate of uptake of newer
lower cost drugs this also applies to
biosimilar which are sometimes refers to
as
generics I would suggest the language
change on section two of the bill to
also include biosimilars in addition to
the word generics there because most of
the drugs effect fet rebates are
actually not classified as generics
rather
biosimilars okay where is
it we've all learned about biosimilars
in previously
so that's all we have and we'll happy to
answer any questions you might have okay
thank you we do have questions
representative Sullivan has a
question can you explain I mean I I
think the previous speaker was going and
closer to the
mic when the uh previous the sponsor was
speaking I was going to ask the
questions that both the chairman and
representative spear were asking with
regards to the with with regards to the
idea that we're sort of subsidizing or
the or the pharmaceutical company
subsidizing ing a
premium name brand drug which is going
to be more expensive right but it seems
the language in here sort of addresses
that in terms of the generics and maybe
we make a change about biosimilar so
what is your
thinking that this is going to drive the
cost now to the extent that there's
somebody who is getting a name brand
drug and that's the only choice there is
um is it because somebody who needs it
simply won't buy it because they can't
afford it without this like what's
what's the thinking that that you want
us to think about because you said it's
going to drive up premiums well I I
heard the sponsor talk about rational
Choice that's an economic theory that
consumers in perfect markets perfect
competition have choices poptarts he
mentioned I love poptarts but but
delivery of Medical Services might be a
little bit different with prescription
drugs the market could benefit by
competition and so we've seen that
clearly in the small molecule drugs to
generics generics can be as much as 85%
cheaper compared to the Branded small
molecule drugs however in the biologics
market we don't see any type of cost
savings like that one of the main
reasons is because there's not a lot of
competition so any any kind of policy
that inhibits the uptake of new lower
cost biosimilars or generics will by
Nature be a cost driving policy so any
way that you could introduce competition
to that market would be by by the same
definition and by the same token um you
know exert downward pressure on prices
for these expensive question F question
but it's different yeah okay um all
right so I get what you're saying and I
agree with you completely um what what
I'm struggling with is if there's a
generic available and I know we want to
add language in about bio
similars then is that a moot point or or
or explain to me rather how the the name
brand drug if that's the only thing
there and it's being subsidized how
that's what's the channel through which
it's costing I agree we shouldn't be
subsidizing name brand if there's a
cheaper generic out there and it sounds
like the language in here doesn't allow
for that so I'm still not following you
just cited bio similar which we need to
add in and generics as something that we
want people to use if it's available but
if it's not available what are we
supposed to do and that's it seems like
this is only addressing when it's not
available
yeah I think with regards to that part
of it um section one it it shows that
this has to do with whether or not the
value of the C coupon can apply to the
cost sharing responsibility of the
patient and so what that does is it
shifts you know plan designed for
insurers depends upon a combination of
covered benefits and patient cost
sharing responsibilities which varies
widely across the health insurance plans
that we regulate
by now allowing an extraneous Force to
apply for cost sharing that the insurer
doesn't doesn't include in their
subsidies for payment for covered
benefits the the next year that will
almost Force the insurers to increase
premiums because now there's some
other some other outlet for that the
value of those coupons leaving the cost
sharing pool so another question further
question me inquire I understand what
you're
saying what I'm trying to get at is What
alternative does that person have if
it's only the name brand drug and if
there's only the name brand drug and
some and that name brand producer gives
them a subsidy to buy it and that's the
only option there's no biosimilar
there's no
generic
then what is the CH so are we saying we
just don't want those people to take
those drugs I mean that like I'm not
following the logic how this drives
price I get the whole Market idea like I
trust me I'm on board with that I
wouldn't be even having this discussion
or debating this if it were not didn't
have this language already in here about
the generics and and the need as you
said to add in BIO similars but it
sounds to me like this is only
addressing when this only applies when
there is no generic and there is no
biosimilar once we change the language
so how does that drive cost short of
keeping somebody from getting the drug
that they need that the money that would
have been paid to the cost sharing now
doesn't apply to the patient
deductible I think I understand that but
if if he's saying is is If there really
is no other choice if there is no other
choice there really is no other choice
and that this is the right drug and so
there is no really cost shifting going
on it's just more expensive because it
is the only choice I think the concern
is that if there's only one available
the drug manufacturer can
and this is concerned I'm not saying
this is necessarily done they can be
increasing the price that the carrier is
going to pay but then they're going to
fun all savings directly to the patient
so the overall C cost of prescription
drugs may go up but the consumer isn't
necessarily seeing that because they're
getting the advantage of the coupon so I
think there is a potential that there
could be some manipulation with the
prices there and that's what could lead
to overall drug spend going up cuz
they're not the one internalizing the
cost so I I get that but so the
alternative might be then then that
person just doesn't get the drug like if
they truly can't afford that deductible
that seems like that might I mean if
it's a $2,000 I don't know what the
deduc I think because I mean I've is the
most extreme case there if you're
talking about commercial health
insurance plans there are a variety of
options available some of them with very
low cost sharing very low deductible but
you end up paying more in premium if
someone were to be on this high cost
drug one of those other plans may be a
better fit for them because overall
their out- of pocket costs are going to
be minimal so they do have access to
these drugs I think there's a
combination of a lot of factors there
but the drug is going to be available to
them if it's the only drug available and
they would have to pay whatever that
plan design dictates they would have to
regardless of whether there's a coupon
or not and that's kind of what they have
agreed to when they've purchased the
plan so if they have you know High a lot
of uh medical costs and a lot of
prescription drug costs they may want to
get a plan that has you know those lower
cost sharing amounts final question or F
further question so this is probably
more of a would you believe would you
believe I I do actually agree with what
you said about the bio simar we should
add in there and I do agree that we
should not be in any way subsidizing
people to use name brand drugs when
there's something similar generic
biosimilar whatever that all makes sense
to me um and to the extent that there
are different insurance plans that that
might be great when it comes to renewing
time or whatever but um I think at some
level we want to make sure that people
aren't somehow priced out and if the
only way they can get access to one of
these name brand drugs when that's there
are no Alternatives is and the only way
they can afford their portion of it is
by getting some sort of coupon for lack
of a better word then um I think we we
don't want to like discount that or try
to disuade that practice and it seems
like a potential unintended consequence
would be
drug companies sto doing it because they
don't count anymore and now people maybe
don't lose access to drugs and that's
just a concern I don't know if it's a
Val concern but it's the one that pops
in my head real quick when I'm thinking
about this for after this discussion
thank you for coming in and sharing okay
represent
Pier outside of the deductible slash U
coupon Market or maybe taking advantage
of the coupon Market insurance companies
do offer plans called maximizer plans
and what these plans will do they will
pay the whole price of the drug if a
person needs it but it's outside of the
deductible like any other drug that they
may have to take they may have to pay a
deductible for that drug but if they're
taking a drug of which there is no uh
competition it's a it's a very expensive
drug you know Cancer drugs hemophiliac
drugs those kind of things there are
maximizer plans and I know that uh uh
what is it Anthem has a very big one
that's very popular that patients like
and then I pay anything out of pocket
for that for some of those drugs once
they get into those plans and those
plans don't cost any hardly anything so
there are other a avenues for these
kinds of things on top of that the drug
companies uh a
question what was it what's your
question no I'm answering him I all
right and would you
believe and would you believe they're
not going to go without the drug okay so
uh
the interesting point here we heard in
the previous bill that generally they
don't give coupon rebate these things
for drugs that have no
competition because there is no
choice the patient's going to have the
doctor is going to give him that
eloquest because the eloquest was the
only one on the market at that time and
that's the right you know that's what
we're going to do so the only adverse
selection that's occurring here with
that is that
theoretically um that person um really
if they weren't for that
coupon and it's a very expensive
medication then really what that person
would have done if the market was the
perfect Market would not would be not to
choose a high deductible
plan because if they had you know if
they had a very low deductible then it
wouldn't seem so bad the the expens
wouldn't be there but that's adverse
selection because they were Ted away
from that to say you know that that you
know that oh don't worry we're going to
give you a subsidy for that deductible
and that's where we it's impossible to
really calculate what exactly is
occurring when you choose that drug that
had that coupon or your doctor
prescribed it and said this is the only
okay representating M thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question do you think that these third
Cy thirdparty co-payment programs help
people who otherwise wouldn't have
access get access to these most critical
drugs life life-saving drugs where
them it's important I think for everyone
to know that everybody's exposed to high
cost drug
we all 93% of our state is insured so we
all by sharing the same risk pool we all
pay the cost of prescription drugs it's
tempting and easy to look at anecdotal
situations
one person's I live the I live the life
that you talk about but we don't have
the luxury in our roles of having a
myopic view of individual situations
rather we try to look at the entire
insured population and we try to make
difficult
decisions that help better most people's
situation and so I just want the the
committee to remember that that that's
an important um priority that we always
have to balance in our roles and so I
think by and large our society does a
really good job ensuring access to these
expensive drugs um for life-saving
therapies for people and when we see
situations like this we try to evaluate
the the betterment of one individual
situation compared to the betterment of
society and we see every year in our
annual hearing report that gets much
maligned but we hold much Credence in it
we see that prescription drug
expenditures are the primary drivers of
health care costs which right now and in
the past five years we've seen this
increase at an untenable trajectory so
we' be remiss to not talk about that and
it's pretty ubiquitous across the
insured population that high cost
prescription drugs are driving that so
that's generally an important underlying
theme that I want all the members of the
committee to be aware about so is that
is that a yes or a no that's a difficult
question to answer it is I agree and
that's a great political answer you gave
but I
just he's nonpolitical no I know but
maybe you should be I mean I just asked
do you think these these programs
provide
access to these drugs for people who
wouldn't otherwise get them just like a
crowdfunding or a church fundraiser
provides access to them I do not I think
in the intermediate and then the long
run they actually inhibit more access to
better life-saving innovations that lie
in the in the near Frontier for people
so by that logage by that logic if we
got rid of them and banned these
programs then more people would actually
get access right so the converse is true
in your in your thought so if you don't
think they provide a more access if we
got rid of them then more people would
get access it's one way or the other I
didn't summarize it that way but I I
think that these types of mechanisms are
are cost drivers for prescription drugs
and they impede this concept of generic
efficiency that is important Market
mechanism to ensure this the control and
the stabilization of high cost
prescription drugs which empirically our
annual report has clearly shown is the
number one cost driver and we have to
constantly evaluate that so I appreciate
you summarizing it that way I'm just not
in accord with the way that you did that
testimony take no
uh thank you Mr chairman and good
afternoon good afternoon uh my name is
Donald Cree I live at 292 Pleasant
Street here in conquer I am a state
official who fights on behalf of
consumers for a living but today I'm
here in my personal capacity or more
particularly I'm here as the dad of a
young woman who is about to graduate
from college despite having been born 22
years ago with cystic fibrosis and
because I'm here in that capacity I'm
not here with analogies or with anything
like that I'm here with stories from The
Real World of life with expensive
prescription drugs like uh all of the
other patient and family advocates that
you're likely to hear from today I urge
you to pass what Senator Apprentice has
called the all co-pays count act but my
family's perspective might be somewhat
different than those of others like most
CF patients my daughter takes a drug
called Tria triaa it's a miracle drug
that costs in excess of
$300,000 a year when I heard about
$10,000 a month cancer treatments and
maybe a $2,000 a month co-pay I thought
oh how quaint fortunately Rose is on the
New Hampshire state employees health
plan triaa costs her next to nothing but
in four short years she will be on her
own health coverage wise and if she ends
up with a high deductible Health Plan
she will need to beg tra's manufacturer
vertex Pharmaceuticals for co-pay
assistance no way would my daughter be
able to afford
$60,000 a year out of pocket for one
drug it is worth remembering and I think
you all know this already from what
you've already been saying why insurance
companies impose co-payment requirements
the idea is to turn patients into Savvy
non-wasteful consumers and to be honest
Rose could respond to that kind of
incentive by going off triaa her death
would not be imminent but no other drug
does what triaa does and some patients
are far more dependent on triaa than my
daughter is and it is in my opinion
outrageous and unfair to expect any CF
patient to make a choice like that
insurance companies should not be
allowed to force such choices on
patients via copay accum ulator programs
but neither should patients like rose
have to depend on the kindness of
strangers by which I mean co-pay
assistance programs offered by
pharmaceutical companies like vertex the
highly respected Institute for clinical
and Economic Review in Boston has
investigated the incremental benefits of
triaa and has determined that the drug
is overpriced by roughly a factor of
three so not what that means it's a
$300,000 a year drug that should cost
one $100,000 a year so there's $200,000
of free money lining the pockets of
vertex Pharmaceuticals at $100,000 a
year it would still be a very expensive
drug to compensate that company's
shareholders for the cost of having
developed it so in other words insurers
like Anthem have a point here copay
assistance programs exist because drugs
are overpriced and the whole situation
puts patients in the middle in a manner
that is absolutely unconscionable so yes
please report Senate Bill 354 to the
floor with an a to pass recommendation
but do not let big Pharma off the hook
this state has a prescription drug
affordability board which is just
getting off the ground and which the
pharmaceutical industry is constantly
trying to thwart or abolish altogether I
urge you to strengthen the pdb by giving
it authority to set Upper price limits
so co-pay assistance programs become
unnecessary every single year my
daughter's pharmaceutical bill is a
multiple of my annual salary as a state
employee that is unsustainable certainly
in the context of state employment my
daughter is about to graduate from
Bowden College over in Maine with an
honors degree in government she hopes to
pursue a public policy career and I
would like her to do that right here in
conquered but she can't do that if she
can't afford to live here as a cystic
fibrosis patient so yes yes to Senate
Bill 354 but please don't stop there
thanks for listening I'd be delighted to
answer any questions that the chair
might be willing to allow anybody to
ask any questions from the member so
you're the consumer protection for the
Pu yes that's right I'm the consumer
knew you look familiar yes I do uh
utility rates for a living that is how I
know when prices are ridiculously now we
okay representative Herbert has a
question all these companies research
and otherwise uh are
certified by the federal government they
have they have the the rights to do what
they're doing correct yes okay now the
federal government also is the one that
issues or agrees to issue
patents yes I correct so from my
perspective wouldn't it be uh an
interesting experiment if the federal
government said to this
company we're going to take your patent
away and if you don't like that we're
going to take your certification away
too and you can go work in
France but but I I mean I I I don't see
the I don't see where the government is
actually making an a difference here
where I can I can see where it obviously
can well I would say that the ability to
protect one's intellectual property
including Innovative medicines are what
give shareholders the incentive that
they need to make the Investments that
they need to make in order to make drugs
like triaa possible to begin with so I
think as a matter of I guess American
history patents have had an enormously
positive effect on Innovation and
therefore our wealth As Americans so I
would personally be very careful about
reigning in the US patent and trademark
office's ability to Grant patents to
manufacturers like vertex but more to
your point what happens with a drug like
uh triaa is in addition to the patent
they acquire an exclusivity period from
the Food and Drug Administration when
the FDA approves and reviews their drug
and there are legitimate questions about
whether those exclusivity periods are
too long and there are issues about
patent thickets and other tricks the
drug manufacturers play in an effort to
take what I consider to be undo
advantage of the protections that they
enjoy under the uh uh patent under the
patent statute so so I I guess my answer
to you representative Herbert is that
this is a very complicated and difficult
area uh you know patents and Drug
exclusivity are matters of federal law
and we're kind of stuck with what
Congress has given all of us by way of
encouraging and promoting drug
Innovation we lead the world I'm very
proud of the fact that triaa is an
American invention that drug was largely
paid for by the nickel and dime
donations that people like me have been
raising from our friends and neighbors
for decades via the Cystic Fibrosis
Foundation I don't I don't want to get
into I I don't want to interfere in that
I just want a drug that is vital to the
survival of CF patients and it really is
a breakthrough and a miracle to be
available to everybody who needs it at a
price that they can
afford thank you very much thank you uh
Gage
okay good afternoon chairman hunt and
members of the committee my name is
Susanna Von in I'm a resident of Warner
I'm the state lead for the New England
bleeding disorders advocacy Coalition a
member of the New England hemophilia
association but most importantly I'm the
mother of a 26-year-old son with severe
hemophilia a a rare genetic bleeding
disorder that impairs the ability of the
blood to clot
properly I'm testifying in support
of SB 354 to ban the practice of co-pay
assistance or a co-pay accumulator
adjustment programs implemented by the
health insurance companies fairly
recently I may say since about
2016 prior to that uh there was not
these programs were not in
existence first let me State um I was
listening to the previous conversation
that nowhere in this bill do I see the
word coupon it is co-pay
assistance we do not receive coupons in
fact right now we are not taking Cay
assistance from a
manufacturer or a third party be that a
grandparent a charitable
organization uh primarily because my son
is now on his own insurance policy prior
to that he was on mine our co-pays were
very low I worked for the federal
government that's a big Insurance Pool
so my insurance policy was is really
good but my son with his bleeding
disorder needs which is by the way
genetic lifelong extremely complex
because of his severity of the uh uh
hemophilia he is requir he
needs expensive
medication in order to have a normal
life and a career pay taxes have a
family and work he's a Timber framer
he's um his own company of one so he had
to go on the marketplace when he opted
out of my aged out I should say of my
insurance
policy it took us a few months to find
one that would meet his medical
needs did you know that 2third of New
Hampshire open market policy
have accumulator adjustment programs I
didn't that's from the AIDS
International report from
2023 not only that but when we talk to
uh
healthcare.gov with an experienced
broker and we asked them which policies
in New Hampshire have accumulator
adjustment programs that person had
never heard of them yet two-thirds have
these
programs so then my husband narrowed it
down to two policies that would address
most of my son's medical needs not just
prescriptions but periodic doctor's
visits he goes to the Dartmouth
hemophilia treatment center and uh
Handover New
Hampshire he contacted the two agents
and asked if they had accumulator
adjustment programs One agent never
responded the other one emailed us did
not say yes but this is and I'm quoting
I need to read this as you can tell I'm
very passionate about this subject
only amounts that the member is paying
would
contribute no discounts or co-payments
from the drug company will apply towards
the
deductible it's only the out-of-pocket
expenses from the member so if I give my
son the money then he can pay his his
deductible if I pay the deductible
directly it it's the co-pay I mean it
will not count to the maximum out of
pocket or the deductible if I pay it
that is what an accumulator adjustment
program
is 19 states have prohibited this
because it's really double dipping it's
not a coupon my son by the way cannot
switch medications they're all expensive
every single one for hemophilia there is
no generic alternative and there are few
Alternatives and if he does he may get
an
inhibitor which now means he needs even
more of the factor to stop those
bleeding incidents those clots so we're
in this situation where
we could use co-pay assistance but it's
useless because it will not contribute
to his out-of- pocket maximum or is
deductible and it's not a coupon the
drug
manufacturer would pay pay for co-pay up
to a point and oh by the way there is a
financial limit for co-pay assistance
for these drugs at least for hemophilia
400% above the poverty
level if you add up the maximum amount
of pocket
deductible if you add up the co-pays and
his premiums it's about $10,000 a year
that's a quarter of what he
earns I don't know who can survive on
that so my son who's
26 might choose I can't he has to take
this medication regularly in order to
keep those factors normal so that you
know if he has an incident he bruises
like us as opposed to having an internal
bleed and going to the ER but he might
say I got to pay rent I have to pay
utilities and copay assistance isn't
going to help me because it doesn't
count towards my
maximum out of pocket or my deductible
so I think I'll just skip taking my
good yeah I guess I've covered a lot of
um I
was
lobbying not lobbying but I was talking
to our federal Representatives a number
of years ago about hemophilia and
supporting the
CDC and bills such as the co-pay
assistance the all co-pays count
bill and the representative we talked to
asked the young woman who was with
me why why should we pay for these
really expensive bills you know it's I'm
I'm a taxpayer I'm an insurance payer my
insurance premiums or covering your cost
and the young woman looked at him and
she said I want to go to
college I want to be a productive member
of society I want to pay my
taxes I want to
live but I want to be productive and so
does my son and he can be with his
medication but he needs help until he
makes enough money to cover it so my
understanding from this bill I have some
notes
Here co-pay assistance is limit at least
for the products that we use through the
manufacturer it's limited by the
household income when it was on my
policy we didn't need it he now needs it
because he's a low to moderate income
right
now there are no coupons no words in the
bill about coupons it's co-pay
assistance so if somebody gets it the
insurance company gets paid
twice yes because it doesn't count to
the maximum out deductible so whatever
other medical bills pharmacies the the
patient still has to pay that until
they've reached their maximum they would
reach their maximum quicker if they had
co-pay assistance if I pay my son's
co-pays and give him the money he'll
reach it faster I
won't but there's no word of coupons
it's just co-pay assistance and by the
way at least from my understanding and
the words from the insurance company it
could be a third party it doesn't have
to be a manufacturer as long as they pay
it
directly so this bill I am so in
supportive because it will help low to
moderate New Hampshire residents with
chronic
illnesses non-generic drugs there are no
options they're going to be expensive no
matter which brand they
pick it will help them get their
medication and live healthy productive
lives without it I don't know what would
happen to many of these patients
including my son if they have to make
tough decisions financial decisions so I
ask you to support the Bill thank you
for hearing my testimony I'll be happy
to answer any
questions okay I I guess I was one how
how is the insurance company paid twice
the insurance company is paid twice
because the co-pay which would go
directly to the insurance company
correct no the coopay the pharmacy
Pharmacy but it doesn't count to the
maximum out- of pocket deductible if I
pay it if if my son pays it to the
pharmacy it goes towards as deductible
right okay but if a manufacturer pays it
to the pharmacy it does not go to the
deductible so he still has and I think
it's thousands of dollars
deductible he still has to meet that
deductable before the insurance company
will pay 100% for his medication so you
see well I don't see the double pay no I
still don't understand how are they
getting paid twice they they're looking
for the co-pay and they get something
from and the the insurer is
is let's put it in dollars and cents
okay
and it's going to be low because my math
isn't
great if he has a co-pay he has a
deductible of
$500 right out of pocket maximum
deductible and he pays the
co-pay
$100 goes towards the maximum out of
pocket right now he only has $400 he has
to pay right okay if he pays the next
medic ation round $100 now it's $200 or
$300 and so forth however if a third
party be it a manufacturer be it a
grandparent be in a charitable
organization and they have helped people
before I know and certainly in the
hemophilia Community they are if they
pay that
co-pay his maximum out of pocket stays
at
$500
but the company's been
paid oh you're saying there accepting
the money but then they're saying but we
will not apply it and so what do they
say they're doing with the
money I don't know ask an insurance
me Senator Andis mentioned 19 states
have passed this um we are working on a
federal bill as well with many other uh
organizations I would
ask because my math not a
statistician I saw that insurance
premiums would rise if this bill
passed the rate of increase over the
years for those 19 States has not
exceeded the
norm for those states that have banned
it so the rate of increase insurance
premiums are going to rise every year
the rate of increase did not change if
the rate of increase changes I'd like to
know how the insurance company can can
only to this co-pay assistance Bill and
at what
percent there are not that how many
patients in New
Hampshire do not
use do not have the option of generic
drugs have expensive drugs and need
co-pay
assistance and if there are a lot then I
would think this is a significant
problem for the state if they're not not
a lot I have to question why premiums
would
rise and and now I'm not speaking for my
notes because I heard the previous
conversation so does that answer your
question I I I and then like you said I
got to find out from the insurance
company what they do with that money if
they're not allowing you allocating it
so what are that what what's happening
to that money yeah than you got to
follow the bouncing ball thanks
okay all right thank you very much for
Guerrero uh hi representative hunt and
members of the commit my name is dunan
um I live in
Hudson and uh I grew up there my whole
life uh today I'm representing the New
England hemophilia association and the
national bleed bleeding disorders um
Foundation um me personally I have
severe hemophilia type a um I was
diagnosed at
Birth and um when I was two years old I
developed something called an inhibitor
um and I know Susie mentioned this
before I came up here but what an
inhibitor is is an
antibody that
[Music]
um pretty
much inhibits the body
to uh absorb the factor that many
hemophiliacs take so when I kind of like
relate it to people who don't know are
not very involved in hemophilia and
don't really have much knowledge about
it is like a game of Pac-man
so you have Pac-Man eating all these
ghosts which are the
factor um so for me I take actually the
same medication as Susie's son it's
called hem Libra and I've been on that
for seven years now and um it's worked
well for me but you know I've had still
very severe bleeds to the point where
I've had to you know take leave of
absences from college uh um I've been
fired from uh a job in 2022 because of
my bleeding disorder um so the drug has
worked well for me by and large but
still overall it's a tough diagnosis to
to live with um especially when you
consider my choices for treatment like I
said I've been on this factor for seven
years and
um you
know the PO pool of Factor products as
small as it is um when we talk about you
know generic drugs it's a very small
pool and then for me I have an inhibitor
like I said so the pool only goes down
smaller with my choice of um factors
that I can
take
um so this is you know a really hard
thing for me if my Factor isn't really
working or if I'm having insurance
issues like I was you know in 201 21
then I'm not really left with many
options
um yeah I'm here you know just again
just to support um Bill SB
354 um you know I really believe that um
this bill will help patients with uh
chronic illnesses not only hemophilia
alone but um with cystic fibrosis like
um The Man Behind Me
was mentioning earlier with cancer
patients with diabetics any patient that
needs you know medication that has to be
provided by a specialty
pharmacy not a regular Pharmacy that is
a serious chronic illness you know I
believe that this bill will provide
support to them uh so I ask that you
support this bill as well um and like
Susie said you know 19 States have
already you know supported this bill
um and
um you know especially when I get into
costs um I paid 20% since I'm a college
student still I paid 20% of my um income
last year was due to medical
expenses um so I have had to force or to
face
situations where I'm choosing to take my
Factor
or uh pay my rent for college pay my
housing or pay for my textbooks or other
educational expenses I've had to face
that decision before and sometimes I've
chosen
to not take my Factor because of that or
um some you know very hard decisions
about
um not even going to the hospital if I
need to
um or taking ambulances and emergencies
like I had in 2022 where I had to go to
the ER four times for a different bleeds
and I couldn't afford to take an
ambulance I couldn't afford
to stay in the hospital uh in as an
impatient uh
long
um and as I'm 23 years old right now I
look to the Future and you know in a
couple years I'll have to get my own
health insurance and I'll have to get uh
something a plan that will be uh stable
enough to cover my
Factor um and that's a big priority of
mine right now uh looking ahead to the
Future as I you know transition out of
my father's Insurance um similar to
Susie I
pay just just as much as as she said cuz
I'm on the same medication called him
Libra
um and I mean that's all I can really
say about the expense side of it but
um yeah I just want to reiterate the
fact of the coupon that we've been that
I've been hearing um once again it's
just not a coupon it's a it's a whole
process of how it works and you know I
can explain the process again if nobody
understands it or needs some
clarification on it um
because I'm I'm aware of how it works
and so is Susie as well so if nobody has
a solid understanding of that I can
explain it but yeah if anybody has any
questions I'm happy to answer but just
thank you for letting me speak
today thank you for coming do we have a
question Reverend post thank you and
thank you for coming and and giving this
testimony um my question uh revolves
around you said you need a special
Pharmacy to go to are they all over the
state are they far away uh yeah so you
know we have regular pharmacies like
Walgreens and CVS that you can get
regular prescriptions for common
medications my medication is not common
it's not generic um it's one of it's
produced in you know limited quantities
so you know I am on a specialty proy
called a CREDO and they've been around
for many years um they're older than me
and uh I I've used them for about two
years now since uh the beginning of
2022 and they're all the
way I think they're based out of Ohio I
may be incorrect on that but they're
definitely not based around here but
they have locations around here uh where
I'm fortunate enough to you know I they
can ship factor to me the next day or or
two days later so
yeah I hope that answers your questions
about where they're at yes it did I I
was concerned because I know that if you
have issues and you can't get to get
can't get your drugs that that would be
an issue so I wanted to make sure that
you have the ability to get those
drugs so thank you you're
welcome thank you very much thank you uh
hello everyone um thank you for having
me um my name is krie bue I am an adult
living with cystic fibrosis and I'm also
a lifelong New Hampshire resident cystic
fibrosis is a rare genetic disease that
affects many areas of the body one of
the primary areas is the lungs where it
creates thick sticky mucus which makes
it difficult for the individual to
breathe this also causes issues with
chronic lung infections and frequent
hospitalizations and even the need for
lung transplant in some individuals when
I was 5 years old testing confirmed that
I had CF as well as my younger sister
mallerie at that time my parents are
told that most likely we would not live
long enough to graduate high school
since there are no treatments that could
help correct the underlying cause of
cystic fibrosis despite this my parents
did everything that they could to keep
me and my sister healthy they would
stress to us the importance of doing
treatments that we did have at the time
such as antibiotics and Airway clearance
in the hopes that we would be healthy
enough someday if there was a cure so
far there has not been a cure found but
there are treatments for Cystic Fibrosis
that have improved tremendously over the
past 35 years in 2010 I was able to
participate in a clinical trial for
ptico which was the first medication to
address the cause of cystic
fibrosis this medication made a
difference for me almost immediately and
it has helped me stay healthy for nearly
eight years even though it was not the
medication's fault I became very sick in
2018 and
2019 to the point where my lung
functions were starting to deteriorate
bringing the need for a lung transplant
closer to my reality I also so thought I
was going to need to stop working
full-time and things as simple as
sleeping were difficult because the
mucus in my lungs made it difficult to
breathe simple everyday activities were
no longer easy and I wasn't able to
enjoy my life or being with my family
and friends in late 2019 a miracle for
most of the CF Community was approved by
the fpda traa gave me and so many others
a chance at a normal life my health has
improved drastically since then even to
the point where I ran the boss Boston
Marathon in 2022 wow
wa I truly believe this medication saved
my life however one of the downsides to
triaa is the cost this life-changing
medication costs over
$300,000 a year which is impossible for
the majority of people in people in the
CF community community excuse me to
afford personally Coplay accumulators
will impact me once my time in my
current clinical trial ends my employer
has told me and I've been at my employer
for 20 years so I am on their plan I
don't have a large choice in the plans
that they select um but they have told
me my out-of pocket maximum will be
$8,000 for triaa even though I have
co-pay assistance to cover this amount
this is a huge cost and burden that
causes great uncertainty and anxiety
about finding a new way to cover this
bill with the ability to access co-pay
assistance it has helped to ease the
anxieties of financial burdens for many
in the seaf community so that they can
continue to access life-changing
medications I ask that you please stand
with those in the chronic illness
community and consider the impact that
kpe accumulators have on those fighting
for a chance to Simply live a healthier
you well well thank thank you very much
for coming thank you I appreciate your
time um I also can say that
copay um they're not coupons just from
my experience over my life um you have
to go through a process with the CL with
the pharmaceutical company um submitting
like your wage data and your earnings
for them to decide if you're eligible
for one of their
co-pay assistance programs and when I go
to the pharmacy I don't have a card um
that looks like a coupon it looks like
an insurance card that I give to my
Pharmacy and they send that out as like
a bill um and that's how they get paid I
don't see any money from that um people
who have probas ass since don't have any
other benefit other than the company the
pharmaceutical company third party
whoever they are paying for that portion
of the men for them so if I have an
$88,000
deductible and I receed co-pay
assistance they paying for that for me
to cover the cost of this
medication but my insurance company is
not going to apply that to what I owe so
they're receiving this money from the
pharmaceutical company but still asking
me to pay the
$88,000 so what are they doing with the
$88,000 that they've already received
from the um pharmaceutical company
that's my we will try to find out to the
GP bottom of that yeah so that is the
main point like just from listening to
everybody in the room that you know they
are getting the money they're getting
paid but then they're expecting the
patients to pay it also so that is a
huge burden for anybody who's trying to
you okay uh Curtis Barry I call you
because you're going to take one
minute
okay Mike Rolo
from the American Cancer Society support
bill I'll try to be even quicker than I
put it on on my card Mr chairman because
a lot of what I wanted to say has
already been said but for the record I'm
Mike Rolo government relations director
with the American Cancer Society here in
New Hampshire and we are in full support
of um Senate Bill 354 and we are
actually leading a coalition of 19 other
public health organizations if you see
the second page on your packet on the
back of it there's a list of all the
different
organizations uh some of the volunteers
of those organizations have already
testified uh this afternoon as to their
experiences with um with these so-called
benefit of a co-pay accumulator program
as part of their insurance uh but for
many cancer patients having a difficulty
affording their cost of their
prescription drugs uh even if they have
uh Insurance um it's especially true uh
for newer drugs including um uh as I
said for cancer drugs um even if there's
a especially because there may not have
been yet in generic equivalent and to
help uh temper the high cost of these
prescription drugs many individuals are
um turning to co-pay assistance uh often
times offered through manufacturer
programs and other charitable uh
assistance programs and as you've
heard um the Crux of the problem is
these folks will get assistance they'll
go to the pharmacy
they'll get the assistance paid for for
them whatever the dollar amount is um
Susie used nice round numbers let's say
it's
$500
um the $500 is paid on their behalf
apparently through a card as we just
heard
um but at the end of the year these
folks are still on the hook for that
$500 doesn't count towards their max
amount of pocket and that's what this
bill is aiming to try to stop that
practice I think at the very beginning
of this hearing we kind of went a little
sideways I think and maybe what I no
100% I understand that's part of the
process I think but I think we're trying
to get back to really the Crux here I
think that's really the problem why
we're trying why this bill has been
brought forward and why we're trying
what we're trying to solve um however
with the implementation of Senate Bill
354 these barriers to co-pay assistance
would be removed and it would require
all payments made on behalf of patients
either directly on their behalf or or
whether directly on their behalf or or
by some other organization be counted
towards the overall outof pocket maximum
or they're deductible and requiring
health insurance carriers to do so will
protect cancer patients from Surprise
bill
and treatment delays as well as allowing
individuals to utilize the full benefit
of co-pay assistance programs and just
to be clear s SP 354 is not a mandate a
coverage mandate and does not require
that insurance companies cover any
particular drug or class of drugs
nothing in this legislation prevents
insurers from using their existing
utilization management tools such as
step therapy or prior authorization
we're only addressing co-pay assistance
that is being used by patients for drugs
that their insurance company is already
made the decision to cover and that
their doctor has determined that they
need um patients uh still have plenty of
skin in the game in the sense that
they're still paying their premiums um
and that patients living with chronic
illnesses don't always have the luxury
of foregoing their uh their treatment
and um it can't always just easily um
switch insurance plans as we're
suggested previously by uh the insurance
department um so with that Mr chairman I
will uh stop testifying although I will
just mention last evening I did send to
the full Committee just so you all have
it in case you might have missed it in
your email um some information they're
very large files I didn't want to print
them all out there's about several
hundred Pages worth of information
there's a study by the AIDS Institute uh
the um the Pioneer
Institute and uh the uh Global Healthy
Living Foundation which actually has an
analysis of all the 19 states that have
already passed this policy um which does
show as it's been previously mentioned
that there has not been an increase um
uh in premiums other than a normal what
we would see as a normal rate of
increase that you would see anyways uh
for um for insurance increases and
premiums but it was not based on um on
this policy being enacted so with that
I'd be happy to answer any questions or
try to Mr
chairman okay any questions see I think
out I I would love to talk about
maximizers though if you really wanted
to because they're are quite we're all
have this in the subcommittee and I'm
sure you'll attend this I would happy to
talk in subcommittee I do have a
question okay here you go it's a nothing
question well
it's yeah
we have insurance companies on one hand
who are desperately trying to keep uh
premiums down we have patients that are
in
need I've done a little bit of of
looking
into what drug companies make on drugs
and especially some of these drugs and
no one has mentioned that maybe the drug
company should take some responsibility
for this what do you think of that yes
yes Don chis did mention it there should
be some responsibility there it can't be
all on the raid paays I have said in
other
hearings and I will say it here
again that I have no problem whatsoever
laying blame at the feet of
pharmaceutical companies I have no
problem laying the blame at the feet of
the insurance industry I think there's
lots of blame to go around I do not
represent the pharmaceutical industry I
do not represent Lord knows they will
tell you I do not represent the
insurance
industry um I represent cancer patients
and their families and I will tell you
that with the system that we're living
in right
now
that SB
354 is a solution to help
people right now now if you're looking
for other solutions to to help solve the
high cost of of of of of drugs we that's
a much larger convers sorry talk with my
hands much larger conversation
representative that that this bill is
not going to solve all pro all the
problems with the high cost of drugs
this is to
help consumers I can stop talking with
my hands I'm sorry this will help
consumers in real time right
now um that that are getting help to pay
for the high cost of drugs and Lord
um the help they're getting needs to
count towards their their deductible and
their maximum out of pocket cost per
year that's what this is addressing
right now and that's really I think what
we need to focus on right now what
you're talking about we can I'd love to
talk to you about that offline we could
talk about that for hours trust me
because it's the larer problem but
you're not going to solve it right now I
don't think thank you very much of
course okay uh this time I'll do Heidi
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee um for the record my
name is Heidi croll I work at Gallagher
Callahan and
gartell um and I'm representing ahip
America's health insurance plans um so
we are opposed to sp sp
354 had a lots of notes written out and
um I think I'm going to try to jump
around to address some of the questions
that have come up
um our concern is that this bill will
increase the cost of health insurance
for New Hampshire citizens and employers
um who are in the fully insured Market
um the bill does nothing as you've heard
to control the sing prices of
prescription drugs for patients and
instead um rewards drug makers for
steering patients toward more expensive
brand name drugs um patients access to
Affordable healthc Care in New
Hampshire's fully insured Market which
is the sole Target of this bill um we do
believe will be negatively impacted by
this
trying to decide where to begin uh I
think well tell us why this how this
money how someone can the money and you
don't count it to the thing can can you
help us out with that one so first of
all I would say that carriers are
concerned about the patient assistance
coupons discounts cash cards whatever
you want to call them carriers are
focused on what is coming from Pharma um
we uh do not track we don't have an
interest in tracking as far as I've been
told assistance that's coming from your
Aunt Sally your local church your
GoFundMe page um and the reason is that
this the source of the assistance
matters and it matters because when you
get assistance from your Aunt Sally or
your GoFundMe page or your local church
they are just trying to help they don't
care necessarily what drug you're on
they're not using coupons and I'll use
that in a very generic way they're not
using assistance to try to corner market
share and drive people to a particular
more expensive brand named drug when
there are lower cost Alternatives that
is not what your family and friends are
doing when they are offering you
assistance when the assistance comes
from Pharma that is exactly the purpose
of the assistance it is a market frankly
that's not what we've heard in this
testimony today what we've heard in this
testimony is very unique
drugs for a very
unique
uh
ailments that there is no other drug
because we always talk about you know in
terms of the other bill it was you know
if there was some other drug that you
can choose but um if we're talking about
cystic fibrosis and there's only one
medication you can take and it has this
outrageous uh cost right and so why
would the insurance company take money
if they if offer assistance other words
if the pharmaceutical company is
offering assistance and we'll forget
about what form it's in but there's some
money coming down because the pharmacy's
happy that he got the money he got
whatever they were looking for what the
computer told them they needed to get
they got it they could apply it to
whoever going to pay it so what I'm
asking is is if we're if we're really
narrowing it down to just these
unique medical conditions that only have
one
drug that can
solve why would we turn down why would
you not respect the fact that the that
pharmaceutical company is giving a
they're calling assistance a subsidy
they're doing something that something
that made that Pharmacy happy okay that
they're doing that why would you be
opposed to that if there is no other
medicine to
take so um my understanding based on one
analysis I saw is that 88% of brand
named drugs with manufacturer coupons
were medications for which lower cost
Alternatives were available so under
that math that would leave the 12% of
what you're talking about the that goes
back to
555 this bill this bill it talks about
that you but that's from the testimony
we hurt now maybe that's we're getting
limited testimony maybe we're not
getting as focused the way this bill is
written and certainly I didn't think
this committee is more than motivated to
narrow it to what we heard in today's
testimony which is to solve these people
who I I would assume they I mean I would
assume a human feedback is on on
Medicaid I mean I would assume like
Social Security or you know Social
Security you know but maybe not I don't
know I mean the fact that they're still
in the market you know in the insurance
you open market you know obviously the
employer is going to set the co-pay or
the high you know the deductible at what
what they think is right and has nothing
to do with the individual pay you know
employee but what I'm saying is if if we
can narrow
this to
those drugs which really don't have
anything else and that if the drug
company is willing to um help that
deductible for that
employee knowing full well that you
could say is well they're just raising
the price at the back end that that
they're going to get whatever they just
donated they're going to get back from
you okay but that you know from the from
the insurance company but if it's just
is if we were to narrow it to these
unique medical conditions that are are
that these are the only drugs available
that are that but you're saying is you
know that what you know is that it's 80%
or they do have competitive products yes
that's my understanding and the bill
talks about any amounts paid by the
enrol e or paid on behalf of the aoli so
I think the bill whether intentionally
or not intent Al muddies the waters
about the source the source of the
assistance we want to make sure that yes
if if if if if grandma wants to make the
payment we we will be more than willing
to take that money and apply it to the
right and I think you know again this is
not this bill is not about whether or
not people can use the assistance it's
whether or not the assistance gets
counted toward their deductible right in
terms of whether what's coming out of
their pocket versus what's
because what we heard today is pretty
outrageous that that there is this
assistance that money is coming in that
you're the pharmacy's collecting that
money and yet at the end of the day
you're not showing it on their on their
uh what is the benefits what do we call
the uh and again I think it depends on
whether it's coming from the Pharma or
not because if it's coming from Pharma
it's it's a whatever you want to call it
a coupon patient assistance discount
whatever it's coming from Pharma to the
to the pharmacy and then back up to
Pharm so do you re do you have the
pharmacy refund the money that the
person gave when you did
disallowed I mean what we just heard is
that there you're there's double
payments so maybe maybe the the the
person who's taking the double payments
is the is the the pharmacy maybe the
pharmacy's been is holding on to this
payment I can tell you carriers are not
holding to the extra payment the the
issue
is PBM must is is PBM must be hold on
that money who's hold on of that money I
mean if you're not allowing it the the
fact of the fact of the matter is if the
pharmaceutical manufacturer is
essentially discounting their price the
price of their
drug right and the patient is simply
paying
their their share okay so you're you're
holding up that maybe what's happening
is that that assistance money is then
reducing what the insurance company has
to reimburse the pharmacy the PBM has to
reimburse the pharmacy for that
medication you're saying it's coming off
at a different end it's not coming off
on the consumer end on their co-pay it's
coming off to how much is build uh uh
I'm saying it I'm saying basically that
Pharma is paying itself with some of
these so then when they come time to
Bill Bill you the build the pharmacy or
build excuse me the build the insurance
company or the PBM that there is a
discount on that billing that reflects
this assistance dollars I don't know if
it's showing up as a discount but it's
effectively a discount let me see if I
can give you an example and maybe this
will help um so in the example that I
had come up with let's take someone who
has not yet met their $5,000 deductible
right the option of taking either $1,000
and I guess here I'm more focusing on
where there's an Al a competitive
alternative but I just want to
illustrate why carriers are honed in on
this issue so they the patient has an
option of taking a, drug that offers a
$900 coupon which means they would pay
$100 out of pocket or the option of
taking a lower cost alternative that
comes with
$125 out of pocket cost okay they're
going to choose the drug with the coupon
because it means a lower outof pocket
cost for themselves $100 instead of
125 under SB 354 instead of just the
patients $100 expense counting toward
the
deductible the value of the coupon and
I'm using coupon very generically the
$900 manufacturer discount would be
counted to meaning $1,000 would get
counted toward the patients deductible
not just the patients 100
$100 $100 that they took out of their
pocket right you do understand that's
not the testimony we gotten today the
testimony we got today is they don't see
that N9 that extra $900 showed up and
that that they see that they still have
not met their personal deductible other
than paying that $100 so they're getting
the benefit in my example they're
getting the benefit of the $900 they're
paying $100 out of pocket and the $100
is getting being counted toward their
deductible so the from Pharma
perspective what they're trying to do is
put patients on an accelerated path
toward meeting their deductible because
once the deductible is met in the PES as
far as I understand Pharma withdraws the
assistance okay once the deductible has
been met Pharma withdraws the assistance
and the cost of these high cost drugs
whether there's competition or not is
then shifted to the premium pay
and our concern is that when there are
lower cost Alternatives we want people
to be looking at those we understand
that there is not always going to be
lower cost Alternatives but when there
are we think people should be looking at
those first okay the problem gets worse
um in my example and the problem is that
our concern is that 354 adds an
incentive for drug manufacturers to
increase their drug prices so when the
example I use where the patient has the
$5,000 deductible a manufacturer would
have the incentive to raise their price
in the extreme case to $5,000 for the
month they give the patient a
$4,900 discount coupon assistance
whatever you want to call it the patient
pays their $100 out of pocket and uh now
the patient has met their deductible in
one month and pharma's scheme it has
premium payers paying for $5,000 per
month drug for the remaining 11 months
of the year even though there may be
lower cost alternative out there so that
is our concern with this bill got it so
we have two folds we have the issue of
where does this money go how is it
credited okay and but I have to admit I
always thought the purpose of a PBM was
that they're negotiating a price over a
year that they're getting and that they
the far the Pharma can't just go raising
prices willy-nilly because they have a
contract with the PBM uh formulary that
that they're locked into for a year but
Maybe I'm Wrong well this in these cases
they may not these drugs may or may not
be on the formulary and they may be
placed off the form anyways and they're
just paying the rack price I'm just I
was trying to illustrate the incentive
the lack of an incentive right for a
farmer to kind of keep try to keep a lid
on prices um I mean we do see there's a
lot of shortfalls with the bill um we've
talked some about um there's there's
more types of lower cost Alternatives
than just generics there's biosimilars
there's therapeutic equivalents and in
some cases there's even just
over-the-counter medications that in
combination essentially amount to um uh
prescription drug um so that's not
addressed in the bill um we would like
to see more consumer protections for
example if some form of assistance
whatever you want to call it is made
available to a patient it should be made
available by Pharma for the entire plan
year they shouldn't do this bait and
switch the deductible has been met they
withdraw the uh withdraw it and they
should also be allowing consumers to
make informed choices by letting them
know when the patient is in their open
enrollment period or the business the
employer offering the assistant is in
the open enrollment um
informing uh those consumers if any
there's going to be any changes in the
uh value of the assistance is it going
away is it being decreased increased so
that people can be making informed
choices
um we also um we don't agree that uh
maximizer programs should be banned um
they are very beneficial to patients and
premium payers and we should not be
passing laws that harm New Hampshire's
Healthcare consumers um and I think um
Miss Dunlap will talk more about this
but there are programs that are offer
essentially capturing the full value of
coupons that are available for
manufacturers spreading that over out
over the course of a year and and
allowing these patients to get those
very expensive drugs for $0 $5 very low
cost um cost sharing um and finally we
think that this bill there should be
notification requirements from the um
pharmaceutical manufactures to the
carriers when these types of assistance
are being made available um disclose the
name of the enrol E the name of the drug
the amount of the coupon any other sort
of terms and conditions as you heard
from one of the prior speakers they
essentially have something that looks
like an insurance card at the same time
that they're at the counter maybe um
with their with their normal insurance
card and making a making a payment out
of their pocket um sometimes the
pharmacy systems um will allow the
insurance company to see that some sort
of assistance has also been playing a
role other times those systems do not um
and so if we are being asked in any
circumstances to apply assistance to the
deduc
the first step is we need to know about
the assistance and right now we don't
always
know um so I'm happy to try to answer
any questions
and okay representative spear I see if
if we would kind of amend this bill to
cover many of the things you talked
about uh and also what you talked about
uh one of the things I'm I would also
add to that
is that in the case where we would just
limit this to some of the kinds of
situations that people are talking about
here where there is no competition for
the
drug I think they're usually typically
tier five drugs in the formulary where
there's no competition and there's only
the one drug and it's very expensive
which I hate to begin with but that's
what it is that doesn't mean next year
there won't be in other words so if we
ever did such an amendment there has to
be some time considered that if
competition does get in there that that
gets taken into account so that we're
not uh I don't know uh supporting a drug
for which there now is a lower
alternative that has come on the market
and they're coming on quicker and
quicker so I I think that has to be
added to your list of sure I would agree
y thank you so um
do you know why the the woman that spoke
earlier um she made a payment for her
son and they didn't use that towards the
deductible why would that be an
issue
so my understanding is that again if a
family member a friend a church a
GoFundMe you know if PE if if a patient
is getting money from from some a source
like that um and they're going to the
either you know the pharmacy counter or
the virtual Pharmacy Counter um the
pharmacist and the carrier are not
really going to ask you know where they
got the money to be making their their
cost Shar their you know their out- of-
pocket payment um
so I don't have a good answer for it un
I mean unless she was directly trying to
make a payment to the carrier toward a
deductible I I I don't know I don't have
a good answer for the question but what
I'm saying and the reason that again you
know carriers are not concerned about
those sources of assistance because
again those people are making
contributions to that patient because
they just want to help they're not
trying to corner market share they're
not trying to game the system and I have
all kinds of information which I don't
won't get into to today there's plenty
of evidence that coupons or you know I
use coupons very generically that is
exactly what CP that Pharma tries to do
with with the assistance it's a it's a
marketing Ploy um but with respect to
your question
um you know I guess if she had simply
given her son the money directly and
then he had gone to the pharmacy to make
his payment I don't see that there would
have been any problem we will certainly
whatever if we're going to pass anything
we're going to
specifically identify that and clarify
that in in a bill that would say that
that
it's this is only about assistance from
the pharmaceutical manufacturer that's
the only one we care about
representative Emon thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking our questions um I
guess help
me validate my understanding and and
tell me if I'm wrong there there's two
ISS ues with this right so the
deductible that the patient pays let's
say a patient has a $1,000 deductible
and they get $1,000 in co-pay assistance
that doesn't count towards it if it did
count the insurance company would get
,000
fewer and would have to eat that cost
somehow right so that cost would have to
get spread out to other rid payers is
that's that's the first half of it that
I see is that correct
so the issue is um yes I mean the the
assistance coming from Pharma is
designed to accelerate the patient to
meet their deductible at which point
they withdraw the assistance and now the
more in the cases where there are
competitive lower cost Alternatives the
patient is now taking a more expensive
drug because they were you know kind of
lured into taking it and you know the
other half is the disincentive or the
the Mis incentives for the Pharma
company so there's the one half is the
insurance company's getting less money
because the deductible is met sooner and
and they're not getting the patients
money as they would normally but they
shouldn't care and
and well they're they're they'll be
getting fewer dollars than they normally
do no the Assumption was that they were
getting double paid that's that's what
we heard today was they were getting
double play they were getting the
assistance and not crediting that still
making the patient pay the uh the full
under this
under this bill the requirement would be
that the value of the coupon has to be
counted toward the deductible in
addition to any outof pocket expense so
putting aside the disincentives or the
Mis incentives that this would create
for the Pharma company in in the normal
course you're you're not getting
additional money from the patient
through their deductible right ignore
the the disincentives if you had to if
you had to include the the co-pay
assistance towards the patients
deductible now you're not so you're
getting you'd be getting less dollars
right I mean I don't know if this is
what you're getting at or not but I mean
you know for the for the patient who's
on one of these drugs where they're
getting assistance from Pharma so in the
example I use you know they pay $100 and
Pharma has picked up the rest um and now
they've automatically met their
deductible um you know for the consumer
who's not on a drug that has a coupon or
any sort of assistance they are are
meeting their deductible you know in the
usual course of business yeah where
they're just they don't have that
Advantage they didn't you know kind of
you know win that lottery so to speak um
and they're just paying their deductible
as they go um yeah and then the other
half is the pharmaceutical companies uh
you know is this correct the
pharmaceutical companies could be
disincentivized to play with their
pricing structure so that they can
maximize you they could take advantage
of uh the insurance company having to uh
count the co- Paces that is our concern
yes thank you okay yes represent raor um
thank you and thanks for your fortitude
and taking all our questions um the you
read a sentence out of the bill but the
sentence after the one you read said
that this requirement that coupons count
towards deductibles shall not apply in
the case of a prescription drug for
which there is a generic alternative
and I think that was one of your
concerns that you know patients would be
steered toward a higher price um drug
when there is a generic available but it
seems like this bill tries to address
that is that not sufficient so it's you
you are correct it it does address a
piece of it but there are other types of
lower cost Alternatives besides generics
there are also um biosimilars
therapeutic equivalents um and even
over-the-counter medications that can be
taken in combination so we would want um
any sort of lower cost alternative not
just the category of generics okay so if
we change that wording from generic to
something more broad that would be
sufficient
yes all right thank you thank
you we have one more lobbyist come up
you going to ask the other lobbyist the
question or do you think Heidi really
knows the answer better than the other
a okay I knew
that where I'm at right now I'm thinking
that there can't be a lot of people who
have these really expensive
drugs okay I'm thinking there might
be if we had a thousand New
Hampshire maybe just a thousand of them
one why don't we just mandate that the
if they are taking any drug that is that
has no
competitor that has no no competitor no
alternative it's the only drug that they
can take and it's gone through your
formulary and you tell the PBM that you
know you beat that F that farmer down
for the best possible price and we're
going to wave the co-pay on that
particular drug because it's only a
thousand you know with thousand and the
worst you can have is you know wor this
was could to cost us a couple hundred
thousand in the state of Hampshire you
know in terms of the rest of us paying
the premium but then you the the
pharmaceu the insurance companies P pbms
beats down those companies for a cheap
price say you can hold your assistance
we don't want your assistance you know
then we're gonna we'll get that from New
Hampshire citizens but we want you to
give us these overpriced drugs that you
have no competitor with we want you to
give us your best
price what do you think of that idea
that sounds like
Medicare so go ahead Sabrina okay um I I
appreciate that question uh so I'm
Sabrina Dunlap I'm director of
government relations for Anthem and uh
appreciate everyone hanging in there on
this what I think the testimony reflects
is how complicated these issues are um
we are opposed to S SP 354 um and I
think it's important there seems to be
some sort of um confusion understandably
between coupons and assistance programs
and and my understanding is that they
are quite different including how
carriers treat them I don't want to M
misspeak and so I will follow up on this
but my understanding I'm sure carriers
treat them differently in different ways
but for assistance when it's needs-based
um the payments from the drug companies
would would go towards deductible and
out of- pocket max now if we're talking
about the co-pay coupons where they're
not needs based in in many cases centi
pill 55s those are rebates so different
so so that gets to an issue which is
this bill the way it's drafted
definitely applies to assistance and to
co-pay coupons and that is what I'm
focused on because that is what I'm most
concerned with um but I think there is
an important distinction there and and
also just want to point out um
appreciate you're talking about
narrowing the bill Etc but I don't want
to lose sight of the fact that it would
any statutory change on this issue would
only impact fully insured members so I
don't know the people who testified if
they have a self-insured employer
sponsored plan then this bill wouldn't
apply anyway right um so I I do I've got
a few points uh I do want to make and
hopefully can clarify some issues and
I'm happy to take questions as well but
I I do think this brings us back similar
to 555 it brings us back to this
fundamental issue of the high cost of
drugs the reason copay coupon programs
exist is because the drugs cost so much
money so when I'm I'm talking now
specifically about coupon program so
non- needs-based um these are offered
only to specific patients for specific
drugs for a short amount of time now
once the patient hits the deductible and
they don't see the actual cost of the
drug that's when the drug makers stop
providing the coupon and they think this
gets at your question chairman hunt you
asked earlier why don't Pharmaceuticals
allow the coupons to go on for as long
as the patient needs them I think it's a
good question I I think that um the way
it's set up now where patient hits
deductible copay coupon program Ends by
the rules of the drug company that
allows the drug companies to keep their
costs very high that means members pick
up those costs and employers pick up
those costs and to be clear the co-pay
coupon programs do not actually lower
the costs of the drugs the High Cost of
the drugs remain even with the programs
these programs simply create the
illusion of
affordability I also uh representative
spear mentioned this I do think it's a
really important point that copay
coupons I don't know about other
Assistance programs they are considered
illegal Kickbacks by the federal
government they are not allowed under
medicated Medicare and I think this gets
at sort of the mechanics and the flow at
least with c-a coupons the value of the
coupon goes from the manufacturer who
issues the coupon to the pharmacy as a
form of consumer payment applied toward
the cost of the manufacturer's drug and
then back to the manufacturer as payment
for the drug at no point do carriers or
pbms receive the value of that coupon so
getting at this issue of like double
dipping I I think that that's actually
truly a misund understanding of how the
process works um I won't go into the
studies about how this raises cost for
everyone but those certainly exist okay
so bringing us to the the concerns I
have with the way this build function I
think the language of the bill is is
confusing it's not like you read it and
it says this will ban X Y and Z but
having dealt with language like this in
other states we are aware that the point
of bills like this and functionally is
to stop programs similar to ones that
Anthem has and other carriers have
created um sort of in the face of these
coupon programs and I think you know
there's there's a lot of public policy
concerns I have around the existence of
these programs but if they are going to
exist and I believe Massachusetts did
actually ban some of them um and they're
going to be heavily marketed to people
on these medications carriers should be
allowed to find ways to most efficiently
provide these high-cost specialty drugs
to our members and S SP 354 would
interfere with some of these programs um
I'm happy to talk about this more
offline I don't want to get too bogged
in the details but the the issue is that
under our program which helps our
members afford these high-cost specialty
drugs which is what we want um and our
goal here is
coverage part of our program is that the
um the co-pay coupon amount does not go
to the patients
deductible and the drug companies don't
like that for the reasons I mentioned
earlier but our program saves employers
a lot of money it's incredibly popular
with our self-insured employer groups
and it's very popular popular among our
members including in the fully insured
Market because under our program they
pay 0 for the specialty drug and I
believe the way we are reading this bill
is that that program would no longer be
allowed to exist under if this bill were
to pass as is
um I also just want to quickly address
this idea of
contributing contributing to someone's
deductible or out- of pocket max so my
understanding is that if you're so if
you have a deductible the whole point is
that certain medical costs to the
patient go to the deductible usually now
there's so many different plan designs
but I think typically you hit your
deductible then you also have a portion
of co- insurance so it means you're
paying some and the insurance company's
paying some that goes to your out-of
pocket max usually well when you hit
your out-of- pocket max things are
covered at 100% And so I just I think
it's a red hairing and a
misunderstanding this idea that people
would be like trying to contribute to
your deductible and an insurance company
would be saying you can't do that it's
just it's simply not how Insurance works
so payments for medical services will go
to the deductible so if somebody wanted
to help you out they would say oh you
have a high medical bill from your
provider let me give you money for that
and they could certainly pay that bill
and under depending on your plan design
that payment would go towards your
deductible so that's how it works so I I
think it it's really sort of nonsensical
to suggest that there's some like
deductible pot sitting there waiting to
be filled and somehow wor saying no you
can't do that so I just wanted to
clarify that um and I I just I Echo what
Heidi said I think we'd support
amendments that would bring in consumer
protections I want to just I want to
just I'll end by saying this I really
appreciate the patient comments and I
will just note I have a kid with a rare
disease and live and breathe in the
world of high- cost specialty drugs the
world of Rheumatology and so I really
appreciate their comments and um
certainly like personally and
professionally we want people to have
access to these drugs I don't think this
bill helps it does not help lower the
cost of these drugs I don't think it
helps improve access and I think it's
really important to think about consumer
protections I was actually poking around
a drug company's website today looking
at their copay coupon program and how
you sign up I've actually experienced it
myself um and in the language uh it says
this cop assistance program is subject
to change reduction in monetary amount
or discontinuation without any notice so
I think it's important to think about
are these programs you know something
that we should be promoting in the first
place I don't think we should and I
think at the very very least we should
be promoting more transparency from the
drug companies about how these programs
work and also really put in more um
consumer protections if we're going to
move forward with the bill so um anyway
I will end there and I'm happy to try to
answer any remaining questions and thank
you for your time okay retive MCU you
still have your
question does Anthem use any stop loss
coverage for high loss claims High loss
patients such as all the folks behind
you and your own stop I I would have to
get back to you I don't know I don't
know the answer to that off the top of
my
head okay representative post did you
have a question yes thank you very much
um so I'm gonna go back to the same
question I had before the woman who said
she um made a payment and it wouldn't go
towards the deductible but what you're
saying is that money actually goes to
like if they've they're done with their
deductible it goes to like a co-pay is
that what you were saying so no that
sorry thank you for the question that's
not what I was trying to say and I'm
trying to remember exactly what was said
but I think so and I I think this does
get confusing so co-pays typically are
for are sort of set under your plan so
if you go to a PCP you have a $20 copay
it's sort of always that um depending on
your plan design that $20 may or may not
go towards your deductible so you have
to hit your deductible let's say it's
$1,000 once you hit your deductible
again depending on the plan design
then you may have a co- inssurance that
kicks in where the insurance company
pays 80% of the cost and you pay 20%
once you hit so let's say there's
another let's say you have a $5,000
out-of pocket max and a $3,000
deductible you hit your $3,000
deductible then the co- Insurance kicks
in you still are paying you know your
20% and with it when it's a high cost
drug it depends on the situation but you
could hit that out of pocket max very
quickly um so I don't know what the
example was in terms of of saying that
somebody tried to pay someone's co-pay
because a co-pay is usually like you
know when you go for the service to your
doctor's office they'd say you owe your
$20 copay anyone could pay that no I
actually this I'm thinking more of not
so much the co-pay I'm thinking about
the deductible that where um if let's
take the real numbers you have an
$8,000 deductible that means the first
$8,000
that are paid out in any your bills
you've got to pay that and that it's not
until you got
there that now the insurance company
covers it so that if somebody has this
assistance they're assuming that that
assistance is being paid to that co-
that co-pay so if they're getting that
that $2,000 or whatever big large number
and they're thinking they're putting
that to that assistance what I heard you
say is no that $2,000 is actually used
to drop the price of what the the
medicine was so the only person who
really benefits from that is obviously
the payes of the premium I the employer
or they because they're they're kicking
in but that's where it's coming coming
it's coming off that that payment and
they're thinking that that it's supposed
to help them reduce their deductible so
they get to that $8,000 f faster but
it's not being used for that that's what
I think I'm hearing yes I I think I
understand what you're saying um and I
think my response and and I understand
that having lived through these issues
myself I think we would say that you
know sort of generally a lot a lot of
factors go into setting rates we have to
set them far in advance they have to be
approved by the insurance department
every year when I talked to my team
about these issues they were saying
there all these things fit together
deductibles premium co-pays co-
Insurance everything fits together and
things like um co-pay coupons sort of
disrupt the way we have created the plan
and the benefit design and so um I think
also we have we have you know because we
have to deal with the existence of these
co-pa coupon programs we have designed
programs that more efficiently use that
assistance so the our members are paying
Z doar for the drugs and it's true that
that copay assistance isn't going
towards the deductible but I think that
you know we can that's the debate is we
think that's how our plans should
function because it should be the
patients cost going to the deductible so
see no more questions I'm going we have
to give you out of here by five um I'm
going to look at you and know Peter
bragon here but I'm at hi so I what and
okay you want to get in on this Curtis
okay so here's what I I think I would
rather see us do is that take what the
testimony we heard
today about class five drugs and I don't
know how many drugs are how many
Pharmaceuticals are in this
category but that their assumption is
that they're one of a kinds one is and
very
unique and uh I can't imagine that other
states having looked at this to try to
narrow this issue down to just that
problem is how do we handle these very
unique specialized because we keep
saying if there was another drug if
there you know is another choice I think
of you know yes it is true that we have
um you know the insurance companies have
a a system where you call in and they'll
you know and they're going to tell you
well why don't you try this other drug
there you know there you know there I
guess it's the PBM that does that know
who does does when you when you when
your doctor's giving you this
prescription then you're going to get I
guess it's the uh pre pre approval maybe
maybe that has to be in that other bill
that we have but so that's some system
where is that those unique drugs and
that we want to um obviously the intent
was that because the dollar amounts the
co to their deductible are so
high that that's why there is this
incentive by the intern the
pharmaceutical company to give a benefit
to give they say oh we're going to help
pay for that when it's not even sure
whether that's what's really happening
with assistance but now we have these
two different things so I want to just
narrow this down to what we heard in
today's
testimony okay and that because the
assumption would always be if there is
other choices if there's other ways to
solve it then you know the insurance
company will certainly have an
opportunity to tell the patient by the
way there's something else you should do
do and not be enticed by some carrot
whatever you want to call it is dangling
in front of them and say if you take
this expensive drug you'll get this but
if that expensive drug has a competitor
no we don't that's what we're trying to
avoid you know we want you you know to
do what you guys do best which is to get
them to think of another choice but if
there is no other
choice and we're talking about a
$300,000 medication
okay that's class five this unique thing
that I'm like I say I'm assuming that
they're not there's not more than a
thousand people in New Hampshire who are
in this
situation that that you know we will
let's figure out how to solve it for
them differently than everyone else who
really does have a choice about what the
medicine they're taking does everybody
that perfect I will close the public
hearing and we'll see you all next week
we'll do Tuesday Morning Tuesday morning
we'll do health insurance oh that's
right I got another day with this fun
stuff okay and is it 10 or nine some
reason I have it I think we're nine
because I was trying to get everything
in the morning so we wouldn't have to be
here in the
afternoon I'm sure you enjoy that
because you have to be here Thursday and
you didn't want to drive
home no not
yeah that's I'm say that's what you want
to